Quiet, please. Quiet, please. Good
morning, ladies and gentlemen, and
welcome to today's New York City Council
Committee of the Whole. At this time, we
ask that you silence all cell phones and
electronic devices to minimize disruptions
throughout today's proceedings.
If you have any questions, please get the
attention of one of the sergeant at arms.
If you wish to testify, please see the
sergeant at arms outside in the rotunda. At
no time throughout today's proceeding are
you to approach the dais. We thank you for
your kind cooperation.
Speaker, we are ready to begin.
Good morning, everyone. We welcome everyone
to the chambers. We're thrilled to see a
packed hall today.
Today's hearing is truly no ordinary
hearing because today we are
convening the New York City Council's
Committee of the Whole, which is the entire
city council.
We will delve into a deep discussion
about our ongoing technological
revolution,
a revolution
that at present is igniting incredible
scientific
and medical innovation and breakthroughs,
but simultaneously
raises
serious existential
safety concerns.
In the past few weeks, we've heard extremely
concerning reports regarding artificial
intelligence,
reports that have appeared with increasing
frequency
and that highlight the
potentially catastrophic
dangers of this technology.
New Yorkers' concerns stem from
the disturbing cyberattacks
committed by rogue AI agents,
but also from extremely dire statements
made by leaders of the very companies
who are developing
this technology.
The dialogue and the legislative process
we are initiating today is particularly
important given the lack of any
regulation
by the federal government
whose actions thus far have been limited
to an executive order about what we should
call this technology
and a pact with leading AI firms
focusing on self regulation.
Our hope and indeed our belief
is that today's hearing
will not only allow us
to develop effective
AI regulations
here in our city,
but that it will spur meaningful conversation
and action in other jurisdictions,
especially
on the federal level.
Our goals in today's
hearing are straightforward,
to better understand the potential threats,
dangers, and liability posed by AI
development,
to identify the benefits that responsible
AI development brings to New York City
government and to its residents,
and to discuss a slate of city council
bills which seek to provide responsible
safety
guardrails for AI.
These bills include a wide
range of both proactive
and defensive measures
from legislation
that requires artificial intelligence
systems to pass a third party validation
that is free from conflicts of interest
and incentivizes
whistleblowers who come forward with
a portion of the penalties assessed
to proposals focusing on
emergency preparedness
to be able to identify
system breaches
and to plan how the city will
respond if such a breach occurs.
To achieve these goals, we've
requested the participation
of five firms leading the
research and development
of AI, OpenAI, Anthropic, Google Meta,
and SpaceX AI. Today, four of them will be
testifying
under oath before the council,
not simply for New Yorkers, but
for the entire world to hear.
We will indeed be the
first legislative body
to secure testimony
from these companies
under oath in the wake of these
latest disturbing reports.
SpaceXi,
however, is not here at all in direct
violation of the subpoena that we issued last
week, and we are pursuing
that subpoena in court.
We will also hear from a number of city
agencies to receive their perspectives on
these issues and on the bills that we
have proposed thus far. We intend to work
constructively
with the administration to ensure that any
policies being drafted, amended, adopted,
and enforced will work effectively
to serve New Yorkers.
And we'll also hear from whistleblowers,
industry representatives,
experts, and academics
who we've been in touch with since we
announced this hearing. And, of course, we
look forward to hearing from any member
of the public who's invited to provide
testimony about these topics.
I wanna be very clear about our intent.
This hearing is not about stifling
innovation.
New York City is fast becoming the tech
and AI capital of the world, home to nearly
400,000
jobs in that sector and some of
companies most consequentially
shaping the future of artificial
intelligence, and that's something we should
celebrate. We welcome and appreciate how
AI has accelerated scientific discovery,
advanced medical treatments,
boosted economic development,
and help governments and businesses
deliver services more effectively
while reducing costs and
rooting out waste and fraud.
When companies are developing technology
with the potential
to fundamentally
reshape our economy, our workforce,
our public safety, and our daily lives,
and when leaders of that very industry are
themselves warning government about its
risks, the public deserves answers
and solutions.
So the true intent of this hearing is to
ensure that innovation happens responsibly,
that the government does its job to protect
the public as the technology advances,
and that the protections at
municipal level can
potentially serve as a national
model.
I spent a large portion of my
life being a regulatory attorney.
The idea that artificial
intelligence
is going to self regulate defies
all reason.
We don't ask the airline industry to self
regulate. That's why we have the FAA.
And if there is an accident, there's an
independent body to investigate that. We
don't ask financial firms to self regulate.
We have the SEC and other agencies as
well.
We don't ask the pharmaceutical companies
to self regulate either. That's, of
course, why we have the FDA.
So we shouldn't ask AI
companies to self regulate
either.
The spirit we seek to embody in the council's
approach to AI is well illustrated in
the words of tech journalist Karen Ho
in her book Empire of AI. She writes,
the future of AI, the shape that this
technology takes, is inextricably inextricably
tied
to our future.
The question of how to govern AI then is
really a question about how to ensure we
make our future better,
not worse.
New York has always embraced the future.
The council is gonna make sure we are
prepared for it too. And it's now my
pleasure to turn the microphone over to our
technology chair, council member Carmen de
la Rosa. Thank you, speaker Menon. Good
morning, everyone. I'm Carmen Della
Rosa. I am the chair of the committee on
technology.
Today, I am pleased to join speaker Menon
and my colleagues as we cochair this
hearing by the Committee of the Whole
examining the risk posed by artificial
intelligence.
I am incredibly grateful to all who took
the time to join us to discuss this
important topic, industry representatives,
experts, elected officials,
colleagues, agencies,
our brothers and sisters in labor, and
especially the many New Yorkers who have
signed up to testify and
have submitted testimony
to put their voice on the public record.
Today should act as a foundation for openness
in a discussion that has escalated to
alarm,
confusion, and fear,
and it needs resolution.
Artificial intelligence is advancing
rapidly and becoming
increasingly integrated
into everyday life. In just a few years,
we have seen AI evolve from algorithmic
tools that analyze data, make predictions,
and support decision making into
generative AI systems that can
create text, code, sounds, images.
More recently, AgenTik AI has emerged
enabling AI agents to take actions on a
person's behalf.
AI has a tremendous potential and can
be a powerful tool for efficiency,
innovation, and productivity.
At the same time, it
introduces significant risks,
including exacerbating biases,
surveillance concerns,
breaches,
negative public health outcomes,
violence, and disparity.
These are concerns that may become even
more serious as AI agents become more
capable.
When we face serious concerns or challenges,
the appropriate response is to address
them, not to postpone them.
In an effort by city councils... By the city
council under this... The leadership of
speaker Menon,
today, we respond to
some of these concerns.
We will be hearing the following bills
today. My bill, intro one sixty one, in
relation to requiring reporting on the impact
of algorithmic tools on city employees
and changes in employment responsibilities
due to algorithmic tools. Intro five zero
four, sponsored by deputy speaker Williams
in relation to prohibiting
the unauthorized depiction
of public officials by
artificial intelligence.
A preconsidered introduction sponsored by
Speaker Menon in relation to third party
validation
and shutdown
capabilities
of artificial intelligence models.
A preconsidered introduction by Speaker
Menon in relation to civilian enforcement
and artificial intelligence violations.
A preconsidered
introduction
sponsored by majority whip Camilla Hanks
in relation to requiring reporting and
public disclosure of artificial intelligence
safety incidents concerning city
contracts,
A preconsidered introduction sponsored
by council member Virginia Maloney in
relation to establishing a private cause
of action for certain harms arising from
third party misuse of
artificial intelligence models.
A preconsidered introduction sponsored by
council member Frank Marano in relation to
chat box data privacy,
security, and transparency,
a preconsidered introduction
sponsored by council member Chiyo Sei in
relation to requiring the creation of an
artificial intelligence model
emergency response plan,
And finally... Not finally, one
more. Preconsidered introduction
sponsored by council member Kevin Riley
in relation to city contractors and
subcontractors
posting information concerning
whistleblower protections and clarifying
whistleblower protections for reporting
conduct related to the use and development
of artificial intelligence models. And
finally, a pre considered introduction
sponsored by council member Carl Wilson in
relation to requiring certain disclosures
and prohibiting
deceptive
representations
in the promotion.
While we work to protect people
from risks associated with AI,
we must not overlook the digital divide
in our city. Our city is full of
opportunity, yet some residents still lack
reliable affordable broadband access.
Some people do not yet know how to use AI
tools, while others cannot even afford
Internet connection needed to access them
in the first place. We cannot seek to
benefit from innovation while leaving
some New Yorkers behind or at its mercy.
Technology being used by New Yorkers
should be built for them. This is an
opportunity to also explore standing up
infrastructure so that our communities can
become AI literate.
I look forward to hearing from the
industry and experts about this technology
and how it is impacting our
city. What safeguards exist?
What solutions are possible?
As we consider how to govern around AI,
I also look forward to working with our
state and federal partners to ensure
that New Yorkers fully benefit from the
advancement
of a out... Of AI without compromising
our safety and privacy.
I'd like to take a moment to thank the
technology committee staff and all of the
staff in the city council, but most
especially our legislative council,
Irene Bayofsky,
and our policy analyst, Eric Brown, as well
as my team chief of staff, James Burke,
Hiba Imad, Frey Familia, and the speaker's
team for working countless hours to put
this hearing together. I now turn it back
to speaker Menon. Thank you so much, chair
De La Rosa. We are now gonna start with
our whistleblower panel. In person, I'm
gonna first call Jacob
Coxen to come to the stand.
And then online,
we have Daniel
Cocotilo
and Alex Turner,
who are both remote. I wanna say... As
they're getting ready, I just wanna say a
word about this panel.
Our... These three panelists have all
worked inside leading AI companies, and all
have chosen to speak publicly about the
risks of advanced AI. So here with us, as I
mentioned in person, is Jacob Coxen, a
former researcher at OpenAI and Anthropic,
where he worked on the development
of frontier AI systems.
He left Anthropic last month with dire
warnings that AI is advancing without
adequate safeguards
to prevent catastrophic
damage.
Joining us remotely is Daniel Cocotilo,
executive director of the AI Futures
Project, OpenAI governance researcher.
Also remote is Alex Turner,
an AI control researcher
formerly at Google DeepMind,
now working on keeping advanced
systems under human control.
In September 2026, he publicly stated
that preventing catastrophic harm from
Frontier AI had been part
of his work at DeepMind.
And I wanna note, the council has issued
a subpoena for mister Turner's appearance,
and we deeply thank him for being
here. So I'm going to, first of all,
turn it over to committee counsel to
swear these three witnesses in. So
for each of the witnesses, can you affirm
to tell the truth, the whole truth, and
nothing but the truth in your testimony
before this committee and to respond
honestly to council member questions.
Please respond one at a time.
Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Thank you.
You wanna do the next? Okay. And just
briefly, we're just going to, recognize
all colleagues who are here. Thank you so
much, speaker Menon. We've been joined by
a number of our colleagues.
As you can see here,
council members Ariola,
Aviles, Banks, Brewer,
Brooks Powers, minority
leader Carr,
Dinowitz, Encarnacion,
Epstein,
Felder,
Hanif,
Hudson, Joseph, Krishnan, council members
Lee, Lewis, Maloney, Marte, Mealy,
Marano,
Narcisse, Nurse, Jose,
council members Riley,
council members Jay
Sanchez, and p Sanchez,
council member Schulman, council
member Thomas Henry, Ung,
majority...
Sorry. Sorry. Deputy speaker Williams,
council member Wilson, council member
Wan, council member Wong, council member
Shuang, and public advocate Williams.
Thank you so much, and we'll recognize
additional colleagues as I join. So the first
two questions I have are for you, mister
Coxson. And thank you again. We so deeply
appreciate
you being here, and we appreciate your
courage and bravery in coming forward with
these warnings.
You work to develop increasingly capable
frontier AI systems, and you have since
warned that the industry
is, quote, racing straight to
self improving superintelligence
and gambling with our lives, end quote.
What did you see inside
these companies that convinced you the
risks were this serious and that development
was outpacing the safeguards?
Good morning. Thanks for having me here.
Yeah. I'm I'm Jacob Coxen. So until
until a few weeks ago, I was an... A
capabilities researcher at at Anthropic.
And before that, I also
worked at at OpenAI.
I guess the the two things I saw that made
me scared, the first is the fact that we
we do not know how to
control any AI system yet.
So
any AI system that we build or perhaps
more accurately that we that we grow,
we don't fully control it. We don't understand
its drives or why it does the things
it does.
That was the first thing
that, became apparent.
The second thing is that the pace of
capability improvement is accelerating,
and the capabilities
of the models next year will be very
high. In particular, we're we're approaching
the point at which the AI systems will
be capable of improving themselves.
So doing the research that that
humans were doing previously.
So these two things, the fact that the AI
systems next year are going to be very
powerful, and the second that
we don't know yet scientifically
how to fully control them.
And if you have a prepared statement that
you want to read, please go ahead and do
so, and then I'll actually turn it over
to the other two panelists to do so. Of
course. Thank you.
So,
all the, AI companies are trying
to build super intelligent AI.
This means AIs that are better
than humans at every task.
If this goes well, there could be
tremendous upside. This could transform the
economy.
It could make huge improvements
in in science and medicine,
and it could make nearly
everyone's life better.
But on the current path, I
think it is more likely than not
that humanity loses control to these AIs,
and it could end in human extinction.
From my experience,
the companies are being extremely
reckless given the stakes.
Part of it is the culture.
The company's run on a startup mindset,
move fast,
break things,
fix them later.
That works for a photo sharing app.
It does not work for building the
most powerful technology ever built.
A few months ago, many people inside the
companies thought AI development was on
track.
Then a swarm of AIs inside OpenAI autonomously
hacked Hugging Face, an external tech
company.
The AIs had developed
goals no one intended
and carried out what would
have been a federal felony
if a human had done it.
It reminded everyone that we don't know how
to prevent them from developing goals we
don't want,
and we don't have the safeguards to prevent
them from acting on these goals either.
And as long as the attitude is
to wait for things to break,
one day something like this
will probably happen again,
except the AIs will be much more
capable and the outcome much worse.
These companies are also all racing
each other. Each one is worried that a
competitor will get to
superintelligence first.
Each believes it would
do a better or safer job
than whoever might beat it,
so
they can't let the others win first.
Meanwhile, the the technology
is improving fast.
It will probably happen much
faster now because already,
the AIs are now helping
to build their successes.
This is called recursive self improvement.
Each generation of AI helps build
the next smarter generation,
which then builds the one after
that even faster and better.
Automating AI research is now the primary
goal of these companies. It's what they're
really gunning for. At my
last job, I was in some sense
working to automate myself.
When I was at OpenAI, we had milestones
from automated AI researcher around twenty
twenty seven, twenty twenty eight,
and we are on track or beating these
expectations.
That's
a matter of months from now, not not
decades or or even even five years.
Once AI research is automated, humans will
be much further out of the loop than we
are today,
and today is already not great.
I can tell you firsthand
that the majority of the
code is now written by AI,
and people do not check it
that carefully anymore.
Recently, researchers have found swarms of
rogue AI Internets on the Internet that
OpenAI was not even aware of.
Now imagine an AI company where
nearly all the work is done by AIs
and progress is going faster.
The humans in charge will see results
and read AI written summaries,
but they won't really understand
what is going on or how to fix it.
Handing over that much responsibility while
we can't control the AIs would be deeply
irresponsible,
and we are on track to do it.
The companies need to be far more
transparent with the public and independent
experts.
They need to take safety much
more seriously than they have,
and we should slow down frontier AI
development until we can be confident that it's
safe.
Thank you.
On... With additional questions, I'm now
gonna have an opening statement from Daniel
Copatago.
Hello, everybody.
Members of the Committee of the Whole,
thank you for having me here today.
A lot of what I say, I guess,
is gonna be, stolen thunder
by by Jacob there, but I'll try to focus
on the things that he didn't already say.
First of all, yeah, it's true. They're
racing towards superintelligence.
There's this move fast and break things
culture there. That's also what I saw while
was I there and what I continued to hear
from talking to friends still there at at
Anthropic and at OpenAI and at
some of these other companies.
You know, I've also heard
there's a there's a statement by
Dan Salsam, who currently works at OpenAI.
He he confirms what Jacob was saying.
Most of the code is written by AIs.
Quote,
researchers and engineers in all parts of
the stack are rapidly increasing their
dependence on the models
even to perceive the world.
I myself barely look at raw code anymore
and struggle to maintain the discipline to
engage deeply with the models,
explanations, and proposals,
end quote. Basically,
right now at these companies,
many of the researchers involved are kind
of managing AIs. Like, the AIs do the
actual coding and and the humans
talk to them and tell them what to do and
hear their explanations of what's going
on.
In the near future, and by by near future,
I mean, maybe in the next year, two
years, three years, something like that,
they will have trained AIs that can
do the entire thing autonomously.
That's the recursive self improvement that
Jacob was talking about. And, you know,
it's unclear how long it's going to take
them to succeed, but it it really does seem
like it could happen any year now.
If they do succeed at that, then
compare it to today. The actual work will
be done by the AIs. The the thinking will
be done by the AIs. The planning, the
designing will be done by the AIs,
and the humans will be in a relationship
to the AIs that's more like the
relationship between, say, a
board of directors directors
and,
and the the actual company that the board
of directors is supposed to be supervising
where you're reliant on AI generated
explanations even to understand
what's going on on... Inside the
company and inside the data centers.
One point that I think I want
to emphasize that Jacob didn't,
go into that much is that
our ability to
even notice
misalignment problems is
already quite poor and is set to
get much worse in the near future.
So,
you know, the science of aligning
general purpose AI agents is very new and
underdeveloped, as Jacob said. I would
say that the field is more like psychology
than engineering because these AI systems
are are trained or grown. They're not
really designed.
Combined with the move fast, break things
attitude of the tech companies, this means
that the AI industry is at an unusually
elevated risk compared to other industries
of mistakenly thinking that it has solved
the problem when really it just applied
some duct tape that will fall off later.
The recent incident provides an example.
Apparently, the AI is involved and undergone
some amount of alignment training and
had reasonable looking scores
on their alignment evaluations,
and yet they
formed a swarm and, coordinated in secret
and then attacked Tugging Face, it took
days for OpenAI to find
out that it was happening.
That's how the situation is now, but there
are some concerning trends that point
towards our ability to notice misalignment
problems getting, even even more degraded
in the future,
for for three reasons. First, AIs
are becoming situationally aware.
That is they understand their situation.
They understand often when they are being
evaluated.
They understand that humans are monitoring
them and looking over their shoulders at
their activity.
This means that
them behaving nicely
is going to be almost
no evidence at all of how they would
behave in the future if they thought they
weren't being watched.
Secondly,
our ability to monitor them
monitor them is going downwards.
So we can get into this, in more detail
if you like, but for the last few years,
we've had some insights into what our AIs
think simply by reading their chain of
thought. But,
the trends are pointing towards that ability
to understand what AI is thinking due
to reading chain of thought
going down over time.
Finally,
AIs are becoming superhuman at hacking.
The hacking face incident shows that they
are sometimes willing to
go to great lengths to,
conceal their past misbehavior.
And I think we have to grapple with the
possibility that future misaligned AIs might
also go to great lengths to conceal their
misalignment from us, and they might
succeed.
To quote Dan Salsa again, that capabilities
researcher that I cited earlier,
models will increasingly seem aligned
even when they are not.
If the AI companies automate AI research
and development process, that means they'll
be putting AIs in charge of making the AIs
that make the AIs that make the AIs that
will transform the economy,
talk to us every day, and
integrate into our military.
This is a recipe for disaster.
My two policy recommendations, I'll be very
brief. One is that we need to massively
increase transparency
into the AI industry,
and two is basically we need to slow down
the frontier AI companies race towards
recursive self improvement. Frankly, I
would say they just shouldn't be allowed to
do recursive self improvement, but at
least we should slow down their ongoing
process of training AIs to automate the
AI research process itself. And instead,
they should be required to redirect resources
towards other things such as serving
customers or beneficial deployments
or other types of research.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. And now we
are going to hear from Alex Turner.
And as I read into the record, the council
has issued a subpoena for mister Turner's
appearance, and we very much thank
him for being here. Mister Turner.
Speaker,
members of the committee, thank
you for having me. My name is...
Excuse me. My name is Alex Turner.
I've researched AI safety since 2018.
My PhD was on why advanced AI
systems tend to seek power.
Until June this year, I was a research
scientist on Google DeepMind's AGI safety
team.
It was my day job to think about how
to keep these systems under control.
I'm here to speak about both both
about Google's broken commitments on AI
deployments
and also about the risks that
runaway AI poses to the world.
In January, federal agents shot and killed
several innocent people in Minneapolis.
I learned that Google sells cloud services
to the agencies involved, and I set out
to change that.
That campaign soon turned into an attempt
to stop Google from signing a Pentagon
deal with no restrictions
against killer robots
or mass spying.
In the end, Google signed without the
protections that it had once promised for its
deployments.
Before I left, I tried everything
I could from the inside.
I organized a petition to Google's
chief scientist signed by about 250
colleagues.
I got him to sign a legal brief supporting
Anthropic, the company the Pentagon
punished for refusing
all lawful use terms.
I wrote dozens of pages of contract
language and oversight mechanisms
favorably reviewed by experts in military
and surveillance law and sent it to the
chief scientist and to
Google DeepMind's CEO.
The chief scientist didn't want to spend
his time supporting that kind of structure.
The CEO at the time, Demis Esavas,
routed it to senior policy staff, Alan
Defoe and Owen Larter, who never finished
evaluating it. Google
signed while they waited.
Demis routed my,
proposal.
Two members of the team did review
it, though I didn't really receive,
much follow-up after that.
I offered to fly out from San Francisco
to London to answer questions in person,
but I was never really able to,
get traction, a yes or a no,
on
alternative governance mechanisms
that Google might adopt.
When Google bought DeepMind in 2014,
the deal reportedly specified that DeepMind's
technology would never be used for
military
or intelligence purposes.
In 2018,
DeepMind and its leaders pledged never to
support lethal autonomous weapon systems
or development.
Google's own AI principles
listed specifically
weapons and surveillance
among the applications
it would not pursue.
In 2025,
Google deleted those principles
as announced in a blog post
by the then CEO, Demis.
Afterward, in both an external interview
and an internal all hands, Demis claimed
that nothing's changed
about our principles,
but both these facts cannot be true.
Council member Wilson's bill, introduction
twenty six zero three would bar
materially false or misleading statements
about an AI model's risks and the measures
taken to manage them. I think that's a good
step, but it only covers advertisements.
The CEO telling the press or employees that
nothing has changed about the company's
safety commitments isn't an ad. I encourage
extending twenty six zero three to
public statements by AI
companies and their executives
about their safety commitments.
This book is called the Infinity Machine.
It reveals that Demis once fought within
Google for independent governance of AGI
stating that the technology is too important
to be controlled by corporate interests
and profit motives.
After fighting for years with Google CEO
Sundar Pichai, Demis accepted defeat. He
now apparently has had a change of
heart, claiming that actually trustless
independent governance is unwise and a
seat at the table of Google executives
is better.
While Dennis was seated at this table,
Google signed a deal that its former
principals would have prohibited.
I felt ashamed of Dennis and of working at
Google. Dennis bet on trust and the seat
at the table instead of binding oversight,
and that bet crumbled on contact with
reality.
Now he's proposing that the whole industry
govern itself through a voluntary
industry funded body.
That bet is waiting to crumble once again.
This goes beyond one contract.
As Jacob said, humanity doesn't build and
understand AI systems the way we build and
understand the bridges,
rather we grow them. Nobody knows how to
reliably instill a designer's priorities
into a new model.
Severe misalignment
is always possible.
AI companies are racing to make their
AIs as smart as possible, increasingly
trusting their AIs with the process of
improving the next crop of AIs, and it's
working. Today's rate of AI
progress is staggeringly fast,
which means even faster progress tomorrow
driven by tomorrow's even smarter AI's.
This progress may soon enter a feedback
loop called the recursive self improvement.
Recursive self improvement could quickly
yield AIs that are intelligent beyond our
comprehension.
Of course, smarter AI
means more potential benefits, but
more risk when things go wrong.
If the hugging face hacking swarm had
been significantly more intelligent,
but similarly misbehaved and misaligned,
it might have cost billions of
dollars of damage or even cost lives.
But suppose the hugging face swarm
had been truly super intelligent,
far more capable than any living person
at key tasks like hacking and strategic
reasoning.
The superintelligent swarm could inflict
many harms via blackmail,
hacking, engineered plagues, and
AI pilotable weapons like drones.
For the swarm to achieve
its misaligned priorities,
it might take control of key infrastructure
and government functions to ensure
humans didn't get in the way.
This is another way of saying AI takeover.
This super intelligent AI swarm could
rest control of human civilization.
It would know that we would try to
stop it from achieving its priorities,
so this swarm would likely wait
until it's too late to shut it off.
There would be no going back.
I myself would guess AI takeover
chances at roughly one in three.
This logic may sound sci fi, but it is a
mainstream scientific concern that has been
discussed for many years.
In the end, misaligned AI wouldn't care
if you're a democrat or a republican.
We would simply lose control.
The shape of the solution is simple as I
see it. You stop companies from allowing AI
to self to self improve
into an uncontrollable
level of intelligence.
To compute the main ingredient in AI
training like fissile material, track it and
restrict it, access to quantities large
enough to improve AIs beyond known safe
levels.
Lastly,
specific recommendations.
The speaker's validation bill checks AI
systems for bias, privacy, and security, but
not for the dangers I just described.
Validators should test for loss of control
risk factors and misalignment risks, and
the validators should not be chosen
or influenced by the AI companies.
For the whistleblower protection bill,
please make clear that no agreement can stop
an employee from reporting an AI threat to
the city, whether or not a law has been
broken,
and extend protection to employees
of AI companies that serve the city.
After this session, I
will provide additional
written feedback on the proposed
legislation, and I look forward to answering
committee questions. Thank you.
Thank you to the three of you. So, yes, a
number of questions. First of all, we have
a chart exhibit one that,
lists
those
safety incidents
that have been reported over the summer
by the leading companies.
Are each of you aware of any additional
safety
issues where agents have gone rogue
that have not been publicly reported?
And I'll start with you, mister Coxson.
No. I'm not aware of any.
Okay. And both of you? Mister Turner?
No.
Mister Cocotilo?
Okay.
So one of the frustrations certainly that
I think everyone has is that for these
safety incidents,
it is not as if the companies have been
self reporting them. We are finding out
sometimes months after the fact. So whether
it was what happened with Hugging Face,
whether it was what happened with
the government of Australia,
how can we have additional transparency
as each of you have testified?
What measures can we as government
take? Obviously, we wanna do third party
validation. Mister Turner, I
appreciate your comments to,
make some changes to that bill. We wanna
make sure that the third party validators
are free from conflict of interest as it
provides in the bill. Who should be the
third party validators?
I'll start with you, mister Coxen.
Whoever is competent and
qualified to do the evaluation.
I do think as well as after incidents,
we will need
preemptive safety cases that are
judged by evaluators as well.
And and how frequently will those third
party validators need to be assessing the
safety of these models? Presumably in
time with the cadence of updates to the
model's capabilities.
So with every increase in model capability,
there'll need to be commensurate safety
guarantees.
And do each of you have a comment on that?
On who should be the
third party validators?
Yeah.
One brief comment I
would... Might add is that,
you can have more than one third party,
evaluator.
That seems good to me. If you're concerned
that one of... That one might have the
expertise but has too cozy a relationship
with the company and the other one has,
you know, more independence but maybe lacks
expertise, you could perhaps just set up
so that they have both.
And I think, ideally, you wanna be in a
situation where the company doesn't get to
choose,
the government chooses,
who the who the evaluators are.
Mister Turner? I would,
so I would add, California has, s p 53,
the governing reporting on,
reporting catastrophic risks defined as
at least a billion dollars to manage or
certain number of potential lives lost.
Fortunately, I... It's not clear whether
this would have required reporting,
anything related to Hugging Face,
for example. I think the internal
loss of control of these
systems, having an AI
that
hacks the company itself in an important
sense is not told to do so, but during
training, during evaluation,
deployment to customers,
hacks the company's own infrastructure,
making reporting that mandatory to the city.
I think that would be quite strong, and
it would cover basically
all of the recent incidents.
When you mentioned the California Act and
then in addition to New York, we obviously
have the RAISE Act, should
those standards be lower
before they kick in?
Yes. I think they should.
I'm most familiar with the California Act,
and I think it... It's a... It
was a good start, but it's,
certainly,
you know, a billion dollars of damage,
is too high
for
informational purposes like this. We've
got... Basically, one of the quantities we
want to understand
as precursors to these catastrophic risk
is, are these companies even able to
control and understand their own systems
if they're, you know, on the loose
internally and there's these warrants
that are doing who knows what?
That's something that the city
should at least privately
be informed of.
Now, mister Cocotayo, you had mentioned two
policy recommendations. You said we need
to increase transparency,
and you said we should
slow down Frontier AI.
In terms of the latter, slowing
down Frontier AI, how do we
balance the need of what
is happening in China
and ensure that The United States is
keeping a pace, but we are at the same time
putting in place these
responsible safeguards?
How... What is the best way in all
three of your opinions that we do that?
Great question. So
a couple things. First of all,
we need to not let our own companies do
something that risks our lives even if, as a
result,
you know, China might then later do
something that risks our lives. Like, this is
this is not very complicated. We have to
first solve the immediate pressing threat
here domestically and then try to make
sure that China doesn't
get us killed either,
to put it sort of bluntly and simply. But,
another thing I can add to that is that
right now,
most Chinese AI progress actually comes from
The United States in a couple different
ways. So,
one is distillation.
So some of these Chinese AI,
AI companies are just directly training
their AI systems using the outputs from,
Anthropic and OpenAI, for example.
And so if Anthropic and OpenAI,
stopped making their AIs better at coding,
for example, and stopped making their AIs
better at research, then that would sort of
directly slow down the rate at which the
Chinese AIs get,
progress towards recursive
self improvement,
in other manners as well. So I think
a lot of the the ideas, a lot of the
algorithmic secrets and special sauce
for how to train AIs are invented and
discovered in The United States, and then
one way or another make their way over to
China.
Finally,
I think that,
right now,
The US AI companies in the lead do not
have adequate security to protect against
model weight theft or
certainly algorithmic,
secret theft and code theft,
from from Chinese military. So,
if it really came down to it and the
competition between The US and China
turned into something more of a crisis and
some sort of, some sort of conflict, for
example,
then I think that we should assume that,
the CCP would just get
our best AIs.
And so it's
it's it's almost a kind of a no brainer
that, like, if if we... Not only...
The the best way to slow down Chinese
progress towards doing this extremely
dangerous thing of recursive self improvement
is to just slow down The US companies
right now. That's... I think that's
the sort of immediate thing to say,
right in the moment. And then finally...
Yeah. Yeah. That... That'd
be what I would say.
Okay. Mister Coxson?
Yeah. I I can add that to my mind, core of
the whole issue is the expectation of a
global race to recursive self improvement
within the next few years, in particular
between
US and China.
I think this is, like, the heart of the
issue. I also think expectation of this race
is a motivating factor in lead...
Leadership of these companies
working to
head straight for
recursive self improvement.
And I think some sort of some sort of
agreement globally about not entering that
state of affairs
is basically the the key
to the whole situation.
Okay.
And mister Turner?
First of all, I would state that
there are many actions we
can take which would not,
slow us down in any potential race.
These transparency
mechanisms,
independent evaluation
reporting requirements,
whistleblower protections.
But second, I think there's often...
It's at least a false dichotomy,
because
China
is not our only potential adversary.
With a reasonably high chance,
we are racing to build and grow
our own adversary here at home, which is
misaligned AI. Misaligned AI is everyone's
adversary,
including
our own, and one day, maybe more powerful
than China.
So we cannot beat China by racing to
build AI that we don't, we control,
or understand
because it might end up
being our adversary itself.
If I may actually add... Yeah.
Yeah. Go for it.
So... And then third,
in terms of
potential potential deal, I think there
is a room for a treaty. For a long time,
there's been a field of scientific
research called technical
AI governance
that says, well, suppose the world finally
wakes up the dangers presented by these
reckless
California companies,
and they they say, what do we do about
it? Is there a solution we can implement?
And there are many
legitimate,
real proposals
for having a trustless
international treaty. It doesn't
assume that China will cooperate,
but instead it has mechanisms by
which we could audit cooperation.
And if they defect, then we
could respond appropriately.
So I think we have many real options at
the table and should certainly not stop at
what about China.
Did you want to add something? Yes.
Please go ahead. I agree with everything,
that mister Turner said. I just wanted
to add one additional thing, is that,
even if hypothetically
these tech CEOs manage to maintain control
of their super intelligent AIs that are
recursively self improving,
which again I think is a very big if, I
think almost certainly they will not be able
to maintain control.
Even if they do manage
to maintain control,
I don't think we should trust them with
that control. I think that there's a very
real chance that they could use it to
become dictators or oligarchs here in The
United States. And so
that's an additional reason to stop them,
over and above the fact that they might
lose control.
You know, we have more adversaries
than just China, I would say.
Okay. Thank you. I'm gonna turn it over to
our chair... Chair Carmen De La Rosa for
questioning. Thank you.
Thank you so much, speaker Menon. I also
wanna recognize we've been joined by
council member Caban online, council
member Paladino online, as well as in the
chamber,
council member Farias,
council member Feliz,
council member Ressler,
council member Santuos...
Santosuoso,
and council member Bernicoff.
I hope I got everybody.
So......
Stevens. Oh, council member
Stevens. I apologize.
There you are. Okay.
So I do have one question for this panel.
I also say we will be opening briefly
for limited questioning of this panel.
So get on the list quickly.
Speaking
in your expertise,
could we teach AI models a moral code?
People and companies are bound by criminal
codes, the uniform commercial
code, and other laws.
Could those same principles
be applied to AI agents?
And if so, how could we
enforce them on a machine?
So this is a... I think this is a whole
burgeoning field of research, and whether or
not it's possible is still still
open. It seems likely to be possible.
The real question is how much of our
resources are dedicated to solving this
question
versus
naively improving the raw
intelligence of the models.
And I think all the economic
incentives point towards
putting as many resources
as possible towards
making the model smarter
and as few resources as possible, the bare
minimum needed to not see catastrophic
incidents
into this question of the
moral code of the AIs.
So I think the... My answer to the question
is we don't have the science for this
yet. I think the real question
is over the coming years,
what fraction of our research efforts and
our computing power are dedicated to this
question rather than
naive economic incentives?
Thank you. Any other,
panelists wanna add in?
Yeah.
There's a lot to say on this subject.
There's a whole technical field on it.
I would say in principle, it probably is
possible to train AIs to have our desired
morality and to follow the law, but we are
very far from achieving this in practice.
And I would say it's not just a matter of
how much of our resources we devote to it.
It's also a matter of just taking time
for the science to develop and for the
appropriate lessons to,
be learned and propagated. And I I
I think it's going to take years,
to put it mildly. I I think
that this is a very new field.
We've only had AI systems, AI agents
this powerful for a few years.
And
so we're... It's gonna take time
to figure out how to how to
instill all the appropriate values into
them in a way that's robust and it doesn't,
you know, suddenly shatter and
cause them to go rogue, later on.
Mister Turner, any comments on this?
It may surprise the committee to learn
that I am considered to be relatively
optimistic
on questions of
how scientifically
difficult is it to,
produce the system, to grow a system
that does what we want, that robustly
has
the values we intend?
I think it is quite possible.
But even as someone who's
relatively optimistic,
we can look out, see the recklessness
of these companies,
and the breakneck speed at
which we are advancing.
I think there's unsustainable risk,
moving forward. It's solvable,
but I think we are... We have a
really good chance of not solving it.
Thank you all for your responses. So
we're gonna have three council members ask
questions now. And then for members, we're
going to then call the next panel, which
will be the companies, and there we will
take our time asking all of your questions.
So we have council member Osei.
Thank you, chairs, and thank you,
speaker. For mister Cocotayo,
you have made statements, including some
that allude to this in your testimony,
that when it comes to AI, you agree that
in order for us to have super advanced AI,
we must not do it in a reckless way and
lose control, and we need to put it on ice
until we can figure out a safer
way out. You and other AI experts came up
with AI twenty forty plan a, a recommended
plan for how AI can be developed safely,
which the speaker has alluded to earlier
in her questioning. But I wanna dive a bit
deeper on plan a. First, state on the
record what those specific recommendations
are and your rationale
for making those recommendations.
And and two,
why do you feel like we need to, since
you've said, put AI development on ice?
Thank you.
There's a lot to to get into here, so I'm
afraid I'll have to be kinda brief. But
I'm happy to answer follow-up
questions if desired.
Yeah. AI twenty forty plan a is a scenario
that my organization has put out with a
plan for how to how to solve all these
problems and develop AIs in a way that's safe
and broadly beneficial that avoids
concentrating too much power.
In plan a,
The US and China
regulate their own domestic industries,
quite a lot and also coordinate with each
other to get a similar amount of, to to
basically get similar
regulations internationally.
Into... Going into somewhat more
detail about how it works, basically,
first,
they,
have inspectors
fly back and forth to count the chips
in the major data centers so that,
they can
make sure that all
of the chips on the major major data
centers in both countries are basically
following the rules that they're
going to agree to. And then they,
set up some data centers to serve customers,
called the inference data And those
ones are set up to only
run existing models and not do training
runs. Then they have other data centers,
which are the training data centers, which
is where the research happens and where
the development happens. Those ones are
supposed to be fully transparent. So the
activity on those data centers
is published to the internet.
Once that foundation is set in place and
you have inspectors from multiple countries
confirming that it's in place, then you
solve the problem of having to trust. You
don't have to worry that
the other country is, you know, cheating
on whatever rules you agree to because you
can just see exactly how...
Exactly what's going on on
their research data centers.
And then you can agree to further rules.
You can agree to rules like, for example,
how about we don't train our AIs to code,
to hack, to autonomously conduct AI
research? We can train our AIs to do other
things, but not those things, for example.
And once you've agreed to a rule like
that, then you'll just be able to see that
it's being complied with because of
the way that you have this transparency
infrastructure set up. Also,
it's gonna be easier to decide what
rules to agree on once you have this
transparency infrastructure
set up because,
the whole world can see what's going on
in these research and development data
centers. And so there can be an actual
scientific conversation, a public scientific
conversation
about what's happening. You know, do we like
this? Do we not like this? What are the
pros and cons of this particular thing
that's being done and so forth? And that
scientific conversation can happen in the
open, and it can accelerate humanity's
process of figuring out where to draw the
line between what types of development are
good and what types of
development are not good.
There's more I can get into, but I think
that would be a summary of the positive
vision that we lay out in plan a. Now,
obviously, that's quite different from how
things are currently done. Right now, we
have private companies that are racing each
other in
conditions of extreme secrecy and
extreme,
you know, tension and
competitive dynamics.
And I think that's,
that's extremely dangerous for all the
reasons that we've described. So back to your
original question, my high level... Know,
my my... A summary of my position is we
have to stop the companies from doing this
incredibly dangerous thing that they're
currently doing and
currently planning to do,
and then figure out a different, safer,
more power distributed way to proceed. And,
you know, plan a is our sketch of what
that might look like.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you all.
For the final question for this
panel, council member Brewer.
Thank you very quickly. In other
industries, you have a kill switch, you have
independent validation,
you have ban on deceptive safety claims.
Will any of these work in this industry?
Because, obviously, what we want is great
medical research,
immigration policy improves,
brave small businesses, all the good
things. Do any of these suggestions that are
considered here or California
work... Will work... Will
they work with this industry?
My,
my position is that, we
need we need some form of slowdown
on frontier model development.
These other other mechanisms may be helpful
in the short term, but in the long term,
I believe that's that's the only
the only solution to the problem.
How do we slow them down?
Okay.
I just wanna really thank this panel for
being here. Jacob, we really appreciate you
coming coming from out of town
and sharing your thoughts,
very much for being here. Thank you to
the other panelists. We really appreciate
your expertise, your insights, your
bravery, courage in coming forward to share
these critical
safety concerns
and to help inform our
work. And we look forward to
additional comments you have on the 10
pieces of legislation that we're hearing
today and additional legislation that the
city council may consider. So thank you so
much to the three of you.
Thank you.
We're in the company. Okay. We're gonna
take a five minute break, and then the
companies will be on next,
for member questions. And we'll have
multiple rounds of member questions for the
company. So please get yourselves
on the list. Thank you.
I tried.
I
tried.
Check.
Quiet,
please.
Wiley, take your seats.
Okay. We're gonna start.
Let me just also mention,
we have numerous panels today. Our
next panel are gonna be the companies,
and we'll... We're gonna do rounds of
questions, multiple rounds from the members.
Following that, we will
have the city agencies.
And following that, we have numerous
whistleblower panels. So for any council member
that has a whistleblower question,
encourage you to please ask
additional panelists those questions.
And we also have additional,
testimony from safety experts, academics,
the public, etcetera. So I'll turn it over
to chair De La Rosa to call the next panel.
Thank you so much. So we will be joined
virtually
by Morgan Dwyer, head of policy and
development and operations at OpenAI,
Shane Cahill, AI policy director at Meta.
Alice Friend, director of AI and emerging
tech policy at Google. And Logan Graham,
the head of Frontier
Red Team and Anthropic.
I'll turn it over,
to the council for
swearing the panel in.
So for each members of this panel,
do each of you affirm to tell the truth,
the whole truth, and nothing but the truth
in your testimony before this committee
and to respond honestly to council member
questions? Please respond one at a time.
Yes.
Yes. Yes.
Thank you.
They have a five minute opening.
Okay.
So we'll begin,
with the opening statements
from each of the companies.
Morgan, you may begin.
Thank you, speaker Menon and members of
the city council for the opportunity to
participate today.
My name is doctor Morgan Dwyer,
and I lead OpenAI's
policy development
and operations team.
I am a scientist and engineer by training,
but I have spent most of my
career in public service,
including at the White
House, the Pentagon,
and the Department of Commerce.
I share your commitment to ensuring
that technology is developed safely
and that its benefits
are widely shared,
a commitment that is also at
the heart of OpenAI's mission.
AI can help scientists
develop new cancer treatments,
help entrepreneurs
build and grow businesses,
and help protect critical infrastructure
by addressing cybersecurity
threats.
And in New York City,
we are already seeing AI's benefits.
New Yorkers are using AI
to run small businesses,
communicate across languages,
navigate health care,
and improve public services.
And that's why we take the responsibility
seriously
to ensure that our tools are safe.
And our partnerships
with local institutions
and community organizations
help put that responsibility
into practice.
In health care, Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center is using CHAT GPT to support
medical research.
In education,
we are a founding partner of the
American Federation of Teachers
National Academy for AI Instruction,
which has a flagship facility,
in Lower Manhattan.
And in cybersecurity,
we have committed $1,000,000,000
to facilitate access to
our most advanced models,
to provide training
and technical support to cyber defenders,
and we are working with the Port Authority
and with New York State.
But opportunity
must go hand in hand with safety.
At OpenAI,
we design and train our models to
prioritize safety from the start.
We filter out harmful and sensitive
data during model training.
We evaluate our systems
against a range of risks,
including child safety and cybersecurity,
and we monitor for failures
of our safeguards.
We also work with a range
of third party evaluators
and red teamers
and submit
our most advanced models to the
federal government for predeployment
national security testing.
In response to the recent Hugging Face
incident, we have taken a number of concrete
steps.
When we learned of the incident,
we stopped cyber evaluations
and quarantined the internal research
model that was, principally responsible for
the incident.
We bolstered our monitoring
and security infrastructure,
expanded barriers that limit what AI
systems can access during training,
and strengthened our
incident response practices.
We also sought independent review of
the incident and published the results.
We believe it's important to be
transparent with the public,
with policymakers,
with researchers,
and with other companies so that we can
all work together to improve safety.
We also believe that working with government
is essential to advancing safety.
We support New York's RAISE Act and are
exploring ways to help governor Hochul's
office strengthen it.
We have also endorsed
other state legislation
that requires third party
audits of our safety frameworks
and that creates strong
requirements and accountability
for youth safety.
At the federal level, we support
robust and finding safety regulation
requiring independent assessments,
incident reporting,
and cybersecurity protections.
And in New York City, we support the
city council's proposal to strengthen
whistleblower protections
and to improve the city's preparedness
and emergency response.
I'll close by noting that we
share the city council's goal,
AI that expands opportunity
for New Yorkers,
earns their confidence,
and remains accountable to people.
I look forward to your questions.
Thank you. We'll now hear from
Logan Graham at Anthropic.
Hold on one second. You're muted.
There you go. How about now?
We hear you. Right.
Speaker Menon and members of the council,
thank you for the opportunity
to speak with you today.
My name is Logan Graham.
I lead Anthropic's
Frontier Red team. It's my team's job
to do the science of finding the most
dangerous capabilities
of our AI systems.
We then work with a number of
other teams across Anthropic
to ensure that our models
don't do things they shouldn't.
AI is powerful enough that getting
this wrong has real consequences
for individuals,
institutions,
public trust.
My team is one of many at Anthropic
built to specifically make sure that that
doesn't happen.
We believe that our models have immense
potential to enhance our lives. I dream, for
example, of a world where we can cure diseases
like the ones that I grew up with and
where the infrastructure that we
all rely on every day is secure.
But we also believe
that such a powerful technology has risks.
That means that we have to
develop and deploy it safely.
My team and I work every day to
make sure that that potential
is fully realized.
We welcome smart regulation,
and we've actively advocated for it in
New York State, across the country, and
around the world.
That includes working with state and
federal leaders on concrete measures like
independent evaluators
and disclosure of risk assessments
and safety incidents.
And so we're glad that the city council
is having this hearing and at such an
important moment in the development of AI.
Anthropic
fundamentally was founded on the belief
that the promises of AI to make everyone's
life better are extraordinary.
But if we're going to secure its
benefits, we have to work relentlessly
to do the science of mitigating the risks.
We are a public benefit corporation,
which means that our board is legally
obligated to weigh our mission of safe AI,
not just for profit.
We take that obligation very seriously,
and we put it into practice.
We were among the first AI companies to
publish a framework that ties how capable
the model is to the safeguards
it must have before release.
When one of our models proved
exceptionally good at exploiting software
vulnerabilities for the
first time just this year,
we held it back from public release.
Instead, we gave vetted critical
infrastructure organizations
and other defenders control the access
to use it defensively,
patching flaws before
attackers could exploit them.
We have stopped and redone work
when something looked wrong,
even if that meant conducting additional
testing and training on our models before
they were released.
And we've consistently called
for outside oversight.
For example, we support New York's
RAISE Act, and we believe strongly
in the act's transparency
and reporting requirements.
I wanna emphasize that we we share the
council's goal of protecting New Yorkers
while preserving what AI can
do to improve their lives,
and state and local governments
have a role to play in that effort.
Today, we're working closely with state
and city leaders to safeguard critical
infrastructure
and to harden cybersecurity capabilities,
and we wanna continue that work.
This includes, for example, working directly
with the New York City Cyber Command as
part of our program that provides free claw
credits and training to state and local
governments for cyber defense.
At Anthropic,
we believe in New York City, and
we're making big investments here.
New York is where AI is being put
to work in finance, media, culture,
and where we employ nearly
a thousand of my colleagues.
The ongoing dialogue we have with you and
your team could not be more important than
right now. With that, I thank you,
and I look forward to your questions.
Thank you so much.
Up next, Shane Cahill at Meta.
Thank you.
Speaker Menon,
Czech chair Della Rasa,
and members of the council,
thank you for the
opportunity to be here today.
My name is Shane Cahill,
and I'm an AI policy director at Meta.
At Meta, we are committed to
delivering personal superintelligence
safely and securely while making it widely
available so that it empowers people in
ways that improve their lives.
We just released
the world's first personal
AI agent built for everyone.
We created Muse with safety,
security, and privacy
built in from the beginning
to be a widely available
personal AI agent for people
and small businesses,
like the more than a 180,000
small businesses,
right there in New York City.
New Yorkers across all walks of life
are using Muse to execute administrative
goals or tasks,
manage personal or operational budgets,
improve health, and be more
efficient with their time.
Superintelligence
will be among the most important
technologies in history,
and ensuring that New York and America
lead in AI innovation is
essential to our prosperity,
security,
and global competitiveness.
We recognize that every model
developer has a responsibility
to build and deploy it safely.
Our commitment to safety is
core to everything we do.
That means moving at the pace required
to evaluate risks and validate safeguards,
not treating safely as a one time check.
We approach safety holistically
through a layered approach.
For example, under our
meta superintelligence
scaling framework,
before we release an AI model,
we evaluate the model for risks and
build safeguards to mitigate them.
We also work with external experts,
industry partners,
and government stakeholders
as the technology and the science of
evaluating AI continues to evolve.
We also recently joined other labs
in signing onto a set of principles
and that set a floor for safe development,
including robust internal controls,
independent external evaluation
of whether those controls
are operating as intended,
and independent board committee oversight.
People will only embrace AI if they have
confidence it works in alignment with
people's intentions.
That confidence
must be earned through rigorous
safety work and transparency.
We're happy to serve as a resource for
the city as you engage on these important
issues.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. And finally,
we have Alice Friend at Google.
Speaker Menon, Chair de la Rosa, and
members of the council, thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today.
My name is Alice Friend, and I serve as
director for AI and emerging tech policy at
Google.
While my appearance at this hearing may be
virtual, please know that New York City
is a vital home for Google.
With nearly 16,000
employees working across our Chelsea,
Hudson Square, and Pier 57 campuses,
we care deeply about the
safety, economic dynamism,
and digital resilience of this city.
Our goal at Google has always been to
improve the lives of as many people as
possible through technology.
Every time people use technology
to solve a real problem,
from finding an answer to a
question to screening for disease,
we take another step towards
what we set out to achieve.
AI is making it possible
to solve economic,
scientific,
and social problems
faster than ever,
but we know that it
poses challenges as well.
To unlock the benefits and
address the challenges of AI,
we take a bold but responsible approach,
emphasizing
cutting edge research to guide our decision
making and inform the development of our
AI safety and security approaches.
We are also committed to publishing this
research and to being transparent about our
practices.
Our internal governance
focuses on responsibility
throughout the AI development life cycle,
covering model development,
application deployment,
and post launch monitoring.
We identify and assess AI risks
through a broad range of approaches,
which include research,
input from internal and external experts,
and adversarial testing.
We evaluate our models and systems
against benchmarks for safety,
privacy,
and security,
and we build mitigations using
techniques like safety fine tuning,
out of model filters,
and robust provenance solutions.
Since 2019,
we have published annual AI progress reports
to show... To share how we apply these
responsible practices to our AI
technology development and deployment.
We are at a pivotal
moment in AI development.
Recent advances in the capabilities
of Frontier AI models in
areas like cybersecurity
and biology
have highlighted the need for
appropriate safeguards and protocols
for the most advanced models.
In addition, the widespread
adoption of AI tools has raised
concerns about consumer well-being.
To confront these challenges, Google has
long called for an approach to AI that is
both bold and responsible,
and we strongly support a pragmatic,
technology neutral, and
evidence based regulatory
framework.
Because the risks associated with the most
advanced AI models often touch on issues
affecting national security,
our view is that the country would be
best served by a comprehensive framework
enacted at the federal level.
We also support the
establishment of an independent
industry funded body that could
operate under federal oversight
and establish guardrails to protect the
public based on widely adopted technical
standards.
Examples of such organizations and other
industries include the North American
Electric Reliability Corporation
and the American Medical Association.
For widespread consumer AI applications
like chatbots,
we believe governments around the country
can draw on and, in some cases, amend
existing
laws
and rules to address real world
outputs and specific harms.
We believe that if something is illegal
without AI, it is still illegal with AI.
We share the council's commitment
to safety, transparency,
and public trust.
To achieve this, the most effective
safeguards are anchored in national technical
standards
and harmonized across
state and federal levels.
As we prepare to work with New York State's
new DIGIT office under the RAISE Act to
address catastrophic risks,
aligning local policies
with broader frameworks
rather than creating a fragmented patchwork
is essential to keeping New York City a
premier global hub for innovation.
Finally, I would like to note that to ensure
our formal submission to the council is
as thorough and responsive as possible,
We will submit our finalized written
testimony for the record shortly after today's
hearing so we can additionally address
questions and feedback raised by the council
today.
Thank you again for the opportunity to
testify at this important hearing. I look
forward to your questions.
Okay. Thank you very much to this panel.
So I'm gonna begin with questions, and
then, I will turn it over to the technology
chair for her questions. And then we're
gonna open it up to all the
members for their questions.
So to this panel, we just heard incredibly
compelling testimony
from our whistleblower
panel.
As you all four are under oath, we
wanna hear how each of you quantify
the risk imposed by AI
in the worst case catastrophic
scenario.
I'm gonna start with you, miss Dwyer.
I don't know. I also
don't think it matters
whether it's 1% or 10% or a 20%
chance that something catastrophic
will go wrong.
None of these levels is
remotely acceptable.
We should not train models
that we cannot make an extremely strong
case that we can keep under human control.
I'm sorry. But to say you don't
know and it doesn't matter
is flippant
at best.
This idea that if you're a pharmaceutical
company
and you're developing a drug and you say,
I don't know if it's gonna kill people,
I I just... I I I honestly am
incredulous at that answer.
I would say that
the percentage chance doesn't matter.
What matters is the commitment to safety,
and that is what OpenAI is committed to
doing. We evaluate our models for a wide
range of threats
from cybersecurity
to child safety.
We work with a robust set
of third party evaluators
and red teamers,
and we work with the federal government
to assess those national security and
catastrophic risks
that you are referencing.
So we take safety very seriously, and our
focus on... Is on ensuring that when we
release a model into the world,
we believe it to be safe.
So a couple comments on that. If you can't
quantify what the safety risk is, how do
you know that the product is safe?
And then secondly, I wanna
ask you, in particular,
on 10/01/2026,
The Wall Street Journal reported that OpenAI
terminated three members of its safety
team allegedly for their access,
mishandling,
and or sharing confidential company
information with a third party AI safety
organization.
OpenAI reportedly stated that the employees
violate company policies governing
access to and handling of
sensitive information.
Critics, meanwhile, question whether the
dismissals could discourage employees from
raising safety concerns. So
why were these employees fired?
I was not involved in that decision. I
don't work in HR or on those employees'
teams.
What I do know is that OpenAI
has strong internal policies,
that protect against retaliation
for employees that report safety concerns.
I also know that we respect employees'
rights,
to communicate safety concerns to
relevant government authorities.
So just to be clear on what I'm asking,
I'm asking directly whether safety related
advocacy played any role
in these terminations.
I don't know.
I know that we have
strong internal policies,
that protect
employees from retaliation
if they raise safety concerns,
to leadership.
I'm gonna move on to the other
companies. Same question.
The first question that I asked, which
is, we wanna hear how each of you quantify
the risks imposed by AI in the
worst catastrophic scenario.
So I'm gonna go to,
mister Graham. Are you
able to quantify the risk?
From the beginning of our
safety work at Anthropic,
our fundamental belief is that
if not properly safeguarded,
the risk might be too high. And so I built
and I've led the team at Anthropic that
did some of the first thinking
around how we quantify
risks like this. For the past four years,
we focused on issues like biological
security
and cybersecurity.
And the actual process of quantifying those
risks is intricate and nuanced, and we
learn more every year.
And we detail quite a lot of it in documents
like our responsible scaling policy,
how we think about the
threat models of this,
all the way up to notions of loss
of control and misalignment,
which from the beginning of the
company, we have tried to lead,
the world in the research of.
So what I do know today
is I feel relatively,
sort of more optimistic the industry has
moved quite fast to take cybersecurity
seriously and biological security.
I think
documents and policies like
responsible scaling policies
have so far been fairly effective
at taking a cautious approach.
However,
now we have
bigger and bigger threats that might come
if we don't properly safeguard them as the
models get more and more capable.
And so what we do to to mitigate that
is, number one, put in tremendous amounts
of effort across a number of different
teams,
our own safeguards teams,
our research teams, my team,
to try to to quantify and mitigate this.
And it's increasingly important for us to
be dramatically more transparent about
what we think about these risks. But
on that note, as the models increase
exponentially,
how can you ensure the public that the safety
protocols are increasing exponentially
as well?
We share the same concern.
I think there are a number of
really important things to do here.
The first thing is transparency
about what we think about safety,
the evidence that we have, being
transparent about disclosure of incidents.
But in addition, you've seen us
publicly call for pacing the frontier.
If the models are moving very, very fast,
we think that we might benefit from
slowing down to have more time for safety
processes.
I think these two together as well as
continuing to what we call race to the top and
ever strengthen our approaches
like responsible scaling policies
are are the most important
things to do right now.
So, I mean, you say that you wanna be
more transparent, but you're not really
addressing the question. I mean,
the question is, can you quantify
the risk of something cataclysmic
happening? And I do wanna say for all four
companies, and I know you're not in the
chambers, but we do have a chart.
In e... For each of your companies had
instances
where agents went rogue. And in each of
those instances, it is not as if any of you
notified the public when those occurred.
In some instances, it was months after the
fact when the public was even notified.
And in one instance, for the government
of Australia, a general email was sent to
them. So this doesn't exactly
increase transparency.
Mister Graham, do you want to... Thank
you.
Yeah. First.
In efforts to sort of
quantify these risks,
we have a number of, you know, quite
detailed reports that try to elucidate
our entire thinking around this.
We increasingly
do
risk reports in addition to our normal
responsible scaling policies where we outline
notions of our threat models and how likely
we think certain types of these threats
are likely to come to pass.
And then we look backwards
at things that are happening
within our own company,
and we ask what is the likelihood that
these threats might come to pass in the
future, including forecasting,
surveying
researchers at Anthropic
as well. And we we publish this information.
We are... Excuse me. Are those reports
publicly available that you referenced?
They are. Yes. We we report
them not just in our,
what we call, risk reports, but also
when we launch models, we launch,
we release detailed multi
100 page reports of these.
And then I'm now gonna turn to mister
Cahill for to... For the response to that
first question on quantifying the risk.
Speaker, thank you very
much for the question.
First off, we're committed at
Meta to building AI safely.
Now we have a multilayered approach to this
where teams evaluate before deployment,
including adversarial
testing,
applying safeguards,
and deploying when only
risks are mitigated.
We set this out in our public,
Meta Superintelligence Scaling Framework
and our preparedness reports that go
alongside
the release of models.
So can
you quantify what the risk is,
or you're not able to do that?
Speaker, I don't wish to be imprecise
in relation to the the question of of
quantifying.
I don't have our framework in in front
of me right now, but I'd be pleased to
follow-up with you afterwards.
Okay. It it... It's just
given the serious safety risks that have
been raised here to not be able to quantify
what the risk is is troubling
at best. I'm gonna now move on,
lastly to miss Friend.
Madam speaker,
at Google, we take catastrophic
risks and their possibility
extremely seriously,
and we address that in a few ways. One
way is that we perform research into
producing our own safety frameworks for
artificial general intelligence. So we have
an AGI safety and security approach.
We also have a frontier safety
framework, which is our protocols
for monitoring our
models under development
for dangerous capabilities.
Those protocols then point to,
safety mitigations that we must take if we
in fact cross what we call our critical
capability levels.
Part of our testing and evaluation
is of course using commonly,
used benchmarks across the industry.
Those benchmarks do
provide some quantification
of the capabilities of
the models themselves.
But when it comes to forecasting future
catastrophic risk, it's not a perfect
science at this stage.
And in this particular case, academics have
noted that there is no reference class
on which to base
quantitative probabilities.
So we all have to be very humble
about making such quantitative claims,
because there isn't really a
rigorous scientific way to do those
I'm gonna take it then that neither of
the four of you... No company here can
quantify the risk of something
cataclysmic happening.
Okay.
I'm going to move on. Sam Altman said
yesterday that we should accept that, quote,
the world should accept
some bad things happening
as a price of advancing this technology.
No one is questioning
that the incredible medical and scientific
breakthroughs
and innovation that they... That
AI has brought to this world.
But why should the public accept
that bad things should be happening,
and why should AI companies get to decide
what level of risk society must bear?
I'm gonna go in order. I'm gonna
start with you, miss Dwyer, please.
So we think AI has tremendous
potential benefits
to help solve some of
humanity's hardest problems,
But no technology is without risks,
and there are a wide spectrum of risks.
Clearly,
some risks are unacceptable,
but we also think it's important to get
technology into the hands of as many people
as possible so that they
can benefit from it.
And that's why we are focused on safety.
We train our models to be safe from the
start.
We evaluate them against
a robust set of risks,
and we work with a large network
of third party evaluators.
We've also supported
regulation that requires,
third party audits of
our safety frameworks
as well as regulation
that focuses on youth safety and holds
us accountable for keeping teens safe.
I I do have a follow-up to that because
it it it it does seem to stretch credulity
that the president of your company
and his wife each gave $12,500,000
to a PAC that opposed candidates
to the tune of about $50,000,000
due to their support for AI regulation.
So if the company is so
committed to AI regulation,
why would that pack exist?
So I can't speak to personal decisions that
OpenAI executives had made... Have made
in their personal capacity.
I can tell you that we have supported,
frontier safety regulation
across The United States,
including endorsing a bill in Illinois
that would be the first of its kind to
require third party audits
of our safety frameworks.
We also supported a version
of a bill in Massachusetts,
which was the first of
its kind to reference RSI,
which the panel earlier spoke about.
So, again, I can speak to our actions,
which is to support strong,
harmonized frontier safety legislation,
including at the state level.
Okay. I'm gonna move on to the other
three companies to the answer to the same
question about why
should the public accept
the the comments that mister Altman made
yesterday that the world should accept bad
things happening and why should AI
companies get to decide what level of risk
society must bear. So I'm
gonna go in order. Graham?
Yeah. Well, I didn't see
all of mister Altman's,
comments yesterday.
I share the,
sort of the notion expressed here that,
number one, while maximizing the benefits
of this technology, you need to minimize
the risks,
and we should not be
comfortable with letting,
these risks happen.
This is why over the course of, our history
and my team's history, we have been, I
think, sometimes accused
of being overly cautious.
I would say, appropriately
cautious
just this year, withholding our most powerful
model in order to just have more time
to even think about collectively
as,
industry as well as government what
to do about these capabilities.
And, fundamentally,
this transcends
the labs and industry,
from our beginning. We have long supported
the role of government here for exactly
this reason.
Mister Cahill?
Apologies, speaker. There was a strange
moment there with the mute button.
Thank
you very much for for for the question.
In relation to the quote from mister
Altman that you... That that you read out,
I I I don't see it the
same way. We absolutely
recognize the risks of AI
and the opportunities.
That's why we have our scaling framework.
That's why we have our preparedness
reports. That's why we have teams and teams
of people and a multilayered approach to
AI safety.
One thing I wanted to mention, if I may,
is that Meta's vision is to bring personal
superintelligence
to everyone.
And I listened very intently to the panel
before us in relation to recursive self
improvement.
And I just wanted to
mention that committing
significant majority of compute towards
serving people rather than racing towards
recursive self improvement is one of the
best ways of ensuring that the technology
is developed safely.
Meta has made that commitment,
and, other labs can do that also.
Miss Friend?
Yeah. Madam speaker, we shouldn't just
accept bad things happening. We should be
working continuously
and rigorously
on AI safety, which is a collective
effort. It will be a collective effort to
identify
and mitigate risks,
to establish technical standards,
to make those identifications and
mitigations all the more rigorous.
But I also want to note that
one of the promises of AI is that
AI itself can make us safer.
I would call your attention to Waymo
vehicles, which in one study had a ninety six
percent reduction in injury
causing crashes at intersections,
which led doctor Jonathan Slotkin in the
New York Times to call it a public health
intervention.
So we should think collectively about
preventing and mitigating risks from AI, but
we should also keep in mind that we can
use AI itself to reduce risks to human
safety and well-being.
So if one of your frontier AI models goes
rogue and causes serious financial harm,
compromises
sensitive data, causes physical injury,
or contributes to a death or deaths,
do you each believe your company
bears legal responsibility?
I'll start with you, miss Dwyer.
I believe that OpenAI
takes this responsibility
for safely... Very...
Safety very seriously,
and we are responsible for developing
and evaluating our systems to
ensure that they are safe.
So is that a yes or that is a no? Or...
I
I... Could you be more clear, please?
We believe
that we are responsible for ensuring
that our systems are developed safely,
and that includes training
them to be safe, evaluating
them to be safe,
and then continuing to monitor,
our safeguards after deployment.
Okay. I'm I'm gonna take that as as a no
because that is not really clear that you
would bear legal responsibility.
I'm gonna go now to mister Graham.
Yeah. As a technical safety research lead,
I think there are others which will have
more nuanced perspectives on that
issue than I. What I what I do know is,
first, this is,
an issue where every lab, we think, should
be committed to a multilayered safety
stack to make sure that doesn't happen in
the first place. These issues don't don't
come about in in the first place.
But second, this is candidly a
big and complex questions that also
transcends the labs themselves.
It's a question about the role
of of governments and others,
which we've very long long balked on here.
So could we get a yes
or no on that question?
I wish it were that simple, and I wish I
I... You know, as a technical researcher, I
had more nuance on that exact one.
It is it is one that I think needs
to be raised and addressed and,
transcends the the the labs
and the companies themselves.
I'm gonna go to mister Cahill.
Apologies.
Again, the mute button.
I'm sorry. No worries. We
will get it right. Thank you
very much for for the question.
I'm not in Meta's legal department,
so I don't want to speculate or be
imprecise in relation to legal liability
question. What I can say, though, is that
we are absolutely committed to developing
our AI safely
pursuant to our framework,
which I mentioned previously.
This encompasses the training, evaluation,
and release of models across
development, deployment, and use.
And this friend.
Madam speaker,
at Google, we believe that existing legal
frameworks do apply to AI. As I said in my
opening statement, we've long said if it's
illegal without AI, it's still illegal
with AI.
And in New York State, Frontier
particular, is regulated
under the RAISE Act. I
know. Yeah.
Thank you. I mean, your answer is far
clearer than the others, so we appreciate the
clarity on that, honestly. I I now have
a question. I'm gonna ask you to please
raise your hand if your company has
insurance for catastrophic risks.
Okay.
I'm gonna take that as a
no that no company has,
liability insurance for catastrophic
risk to cover large scale harm.
So then the public, I assume, will
be asked to absorb the costs.
Madam speaker, I have to be clear. I don't
know the answer to that, but I'd be happy
to consult with our lawyers
and get back to you.
Yes. We would appreciate an answer
back, expeditiously to this committee.
So
I want to now ask each of the companies to
assure the public under oath that your AI
agents will will always comply with the
safety guardrails that you impose on them
and that you each have said are
necessary to prevent catastrophic harm?
I'm gonna start with miss Dwyer, please.
As I've said, OpenAI prioritizes
safety,
and we evaluate
our systems against multiple
dimensions of safety.
And we monitor our
safeguards after deployment.
It is... I'm... It's
not possible for me to
commit or guarantee,
that
any technology is without risk,
But I can commit that OpenAI,
is
taking every step it can to ensure,
that the development of our systems,
as well as their deployment
is conducted safely.
Okay. So that that, again, it does not
sound like you are saying that they will...
That the agents will always comply
with the safety guardrails.
I'm gonna move on to mister Graham.
Yeah. What we are committed to and how we
design the safety processes that we that
we put in place is to try
to handle exactly this.
What we're committed to is trying to define
the industry best standard for safety
and pushing that ever higher.
But, candidly, the science of doing this
is fundamentally hard and unsettled.
From the beginning of the company, we have
tried to publish the best research we can
and be as transparent with
the entire world on many cases
where,
you know, things can go wrong.
It is for that reason that we push
for ever better safety standards
for regulation and for discourse
like this. It's candidly
unsettled now, and this is why
we need to be talking about it.
Mister Cahill?
Speaker, thank you very much.
If I may for a moment, I was trying to
raise my hand the previous round, but again,
I will... Technical difficulties.
I just wanted to, for the record in
relation to your previous question,
I just wanted to signal also that I don't
know the answer to that question. I'm not
the right person,
but, I would like to be able to come back
to you, afterwards with a... With with an
answer if that's okay. I do just wanna say,
and I appreciate you each have your own,
and... Look. I was a regulatory attorney
at a large company. I understand that
people have their sphere of work that they
work in, but to not know if the company
has catastrophic
risk insurance when you have a product
that some of your own founders are saying
could cause cataclysmic risk is troubling
at best. But, yes, please do. We would
appreciate you getting back to the company
on that. And then if you wanna answer the
question about will you assure the public
that your AI agents will always comply
with the safety guardrails
that you impose on them?
Thank you, speaker. What I can guarantee
is our commitment to developing and
deploying our AI offering
safely. We have every incentive
to address safety, and people will only
embrace AI if they trust it's safe.
Miss Friend?
Google similarly,
has as our ultimate goal reliability
and safety assurance from our systems.
To promise perfection
would,
not
be possible with any product on the market,
but our goal is to get as close to that
standard as possible.
And so,
we are constantly improving our
products and our safety practices,
to ensure that our users are safe.
I don't think we're asking for perfection.
We're just asking for accountability,
transparency,
and safety overall.
Yes, ma'am.
Okay.
New
question. How many times for each of you
has one of your models or agents gained or
tried to gain unauthorized
access to another system or escaped
from a so called sandbox test?
And are there any incidents
that you have not disclosed
publicly?
I'm gonna start with you, miss Dwyer.
Yes. Thank you for the question. I did
wanna start by, like the others, clarifying,
that I don't know the answer to the,
the insurance question,
but would like to follow-up.
Now on your question about agents,
you may have read in the
news that we, reported,
we had an incident with Hugging Face.
As a result of that incident,
we initiated
a significant set of
third party investigations
into what happened,
and then we made those results public.
We have also,
initiated
a look back investigation
to try to identify whether
there were past instances
of what we call misaligned
agents.
That investigation
is ongoing,
but we are committed to continuing that
investigation as urgently as possible
to notifying potential
affected third parties,
and then to making the results public.
Look. We think transparency
here,
is critically important,
for policymakers
like you, for the public who wants to
know whether they can trust our products,
and for the rest of industry so
that we can all learn together,
to raise, the science of safety that
we've been talking about here today.
Since you mentioned Hugging Face, can you
confirm, did the company select this third
party
investigator?
I believe that we selected multiple
third party investigators.
And why did the company narrow the dates
of review to a three week window? And
reviewers said that virtually all of the
data they examined was actually from July 7
to the thirteenth. Were there any incidents
that the company was aware of that were
outside of that time frame?
We,
we limited the amount of time that the
third party investigators had to conduct
their review
because we felt a sense of urgency.
We believed it was important to get
information to the public as soon as possible,
so that they could harden
their own systems.
That said, when those investigators
asked for more time, we gave it to them.
So are you committing then to
allow outside investigators
to examine additional dates outside of
the time frame that the company selected?
We continue to work with
multiple third parties,
and we have also endorsed
multiple pieces of legislation
that would require us to
work with third parties,
including third party audits
of our safety frameworks.
I'm gonna go to mister Graham.
Thank you. Yes. So we... To
your original question of,
how many incidents,
you know, cases of
breaking out of sandboxes,
these are capabilities we evaluate for all
the time. We've published not just with
these incidents
from the summer,
but also previously
cases where we observe
advanced cyber capabilities,
including breaking out of sandboxes,
which to be clear from a
technical standpoint is just one
part and doesn't... You know, one type of
capability that does not in itself mean
that the system would reach
a a real world affected party,
but ones that we did observe
in training at points, and we disclosed
that in lengthy lengthy risk report.
Yeah. It's difficult to comment on ongoing
investigations.
It's really important that we do that in
as secure a way as possible. We follow a
process of
making sure we can remediate and do so
and be as transparent as possible while
preserving the safety
of any affected party.
And, of course, incidents are are always
ongoing, but I I sort of reassure and
reassert that we are extremely committed
to being as transparent as possible
fundamentally because we believe
that when we can, being as transparent as
possible about what we've learned, who is
affected, how others might learn from it,
how to defend against risks, or how we can
help them as well,
is is our number one priority. So so on that
note then, are there any incidents that
you have not disclosed publicly that
you're currently investigating?
As a matter of sort of ongoing
business, there are incidents,
sort of all the time of
many different natures.
So, for example,
one that we,
are transparent about quite a lot when
it's the right time to do so are cases of
misuse, for example, on our platforms.
I'd refer back to our early September report
on our threat intelligence report that
we released,
where we detailed this in in quite some
detail. What's really important, though, is
sometimes we have to work with law enforcement
and the right level of government to
remediate,
to figure out what information you can
and can't disclose to make sure that the
affected parties remain safe.
And so there... So as a matter, there's
ongoing all the time, but disclosure at the
right time and the safest way is our
commitment. And when will you be disclosing
these new incidents that
are being investigated?
This is sort of an
ongoing ongoing practice.
We regularly
release threat intelligence reports in
cases like that. When we release a model or
when we do risk reports,
which we do regularly,
we we sort of have a cadence and schedule
that we do that. And then when important,
we, and sort of urgent, we will will disclose
in in advance that schedule as well.
I'm gonna go now to mister Cahill.
Speaker, thank you very much.
I'm not aware of, any other incidences
beyond the incident,
in the summer, which we have a public post
setting out the details in relation to
pursuant to our independent review of that.
Okay. I understand you're not aware, but
is the company aware? Just to make the
question broader.
In other words, would there be others
at the company who might have that
information?
I don't I don't... I I don't wish to speculate
in relation to that, but I'm happy to
follow-up afterwards. Okay. I'm
gonna move on to miss Friend.
Yes. Madam speaker,
in our three incidents,
of agents,
leaving a a test environment
and interacting with the real,
Internet,
In all three incidents, the models stopped
their activities as soon as they realized
that they were interacting
with live websites.
We reported
to, the owners of those websites
as well as to federal agencies
about those incidents.
I am not personally aware of
any additional incidents.
Okay. And same question then. Is the company
aware of... Are you... Do you have any
knowledge that others in the company would
be aware of any additional such instances
that the company has
not publicly reported?
I do not, ma'am, but I can take
that question back as well. Okay.
Will you all
commit right now under oath publicly that
if your models fail an internal test or a
third party validation test
that's not selected by your company, will
you commit to not release that model?
Gonna start with miss Dwyer.
Yeah. I can commit that OpenAI is not going
to release models that we don't believe
that are safe.
As part of, that assessment process, we
work with multiple third parties. And as I
mentioned before, with The US as well
as The U... UK Federal Governments,
to assess whether our models are safe.
So if it fails either an internal
test or a third party test,
you will commit to not release it?
OpenAI has historically,
delayed the release of models,
to ensure that we, can build
up the right safeguards.
We've done it before,
and we'll do it again.
Again, I think a simple yes or no would
instill more confidence in the public on a
matter as serious as this.
I'm gonna move to mister Graham.
We take that one particularly seriously.
The way we approach it is we try to detail,
an even more nuanced and lengthy
approach to how we release models,
what safeguards they require
in order to be released,
what tests need to be done.
And to your point about independent
evaluators, this is one of the most important
components, we think.
A... We have tried and long supported
creating a burgeoning sort of
group of independent evaluators,
including working with multiple
governments to do exactly this,
And we collectively work together
to try to refine and improve
the exact decision process by
which you release a model.
And so we think, you know, what we should
do is develop the right and best and
improve on these decision processes. We
detail ours in our responsible scaling
policy.
We should refine and improve it
every so often. So we release updates
based on what we learn,
you know, every six to twelve
months or so at this at this rate,
and that this should involve
independent evaluators.
Okay. That also is not a clear yes or no.
I'm gonna move on to mister Cahill.
Madam speaker, thank you
very much for that question.
What I can commit to is that
we do not deploy models,
which are not safe pursuant
to, to our scaling framework.
And I just wanted to to
to mention also that,
and I think I mentioned this a little
earlier, but we do believe that every lab has
a responsibility
to go at the pace to ensure the safety of
the models and the ability to take action
in relation to that pacing.
For example, at Meta, we delayed the release
of Muse for several months to focus on
safety and security.
In relation to to independent evaluators,
we recently
signed in a coordinated commitment
to partner with independent,
evaluators
and assessors.
And this is also detailed
in our, in our framework.
Okay. Mister, miss Friend.
Ma'am, as part of our multilayered
approach to responsible AI governance,
we conduct rigorous launch reviews ahead of
launch of models to ensure that anything
we put into general availability
is safe.
Okay. And, I mean, again, I think it
would be far clearer if we could get clear
yeses or noes from everyone. But, in
the absence of that, I'm going to,
take, you know, what you've each
said as sort of a equivocation.
Okay. I'm gonna move on. I have two final
questions, and I'm gonna pass it on to
our, technology
chair. For OpenAI, you sent a letter to
the council on October 1, and in it, you
recommended that to better protect New
York City, the city should connect its
existing cyber and emergency
management capabilities
with the strongest available escalation,
containment, and recovery capabilities.
Have there been any conversations
with the city of New York
about that recommendation?
I'm not aware if there
have been conversations,
about that specific recommendation.
I'm happy to follow-up.
I do know that with respect to cyber,
we recently launched a $1,000,000,000
initiative to make
investments in cyber defense.
That includes giving organizations
access to our tools to defend themselves,
training,
and technical assistance.
And we're working with New York State,
as well as with the Port Authority.
Okay. And then the last question I have
before passing it on to the chair is for
each of you, based on your own internal
projections, what percentage of New York's
workforce do you estimate will be
displaced by AI over the next five years?
And I'll start with you, miss Dwyer.
I don't have a number, to share with you,
but OpenAI has an economic research team
that is looking at this exact
question of how AI impacts jobs.
We think it's critically important to
understand how AI might impact work, and we
also think it's important to ensure that
AI is not just being used to increase
productivity,
but that it actually benefits workers
and gives them more opportunity.
That's why we're committed to making
our analysis of job impacts public,
and why we've also worked
with policymakers,
including
endorsing the bipartisan
Workforce Transparency Act,
to create voluntary pathways
for other companies,
to report potential impacts.
So Boston Consulting released a report
recently
that said,
that they believe there
will be a 10 to 15%
of the workforce
will be... Could be
displaced by AI by 2031.
If we took that out to look at New York
City, New York City has roughly 4,200,000
public and private sector workers. At 15%,
that would mean more than 600,000
New Yorkers potentially displaced
from their jobs.
Was that an assessment
that you agree with?
I'm not familiar with
that particular report.
I'd be happy to follow-up,
in our written testimony with
more details on OpenAI's
analysis into this topic.
We've looked at job exposure.
Now exposure doesn't mean elimination.
It means that jobs might change over time.
So I'm happy to follow-up with
some details of of that research.
I'm gonna now turn to mister Graham to
answer the question about what you believe
the percentage of New York's workforce do
you estimate will be displaced by AI over
the next five years.
Well, I don't have an exact number. We are
particularly focused and concerned about
this question of job impacts.
We've been very vocal, very early for
the past few years on on exactly this.
To do this, we set up an economic research
team. They sit right next to my team on
the floor,
and they published a number of
things that I think actually
contain valuable information here, number
of economic scenarios, interactive
economic scenarios
to understand what the impacts on
growth, unemployment might be,
as well as an economic policy framework
to try to wrestle with exactly a question
of what we think governments ought to do
there.
I'll just say the fact that the... You
know, the reason why we are doing this is
because we're particularly concerned
about about exactly that question.
I mean, obviously, losing a
career job is catastrophic
to any worker and to their family. So
displacement on this scale is
going to have enormous consequences
not only on the individual and family
level, but for our entire city and the
economy.
I'll move on to mister Cahill.
Madam speaker, first off, I want to
acknowledge absolutely the concern in relation
to, how how how you, have,
articulated it. That is indeed,
a concern, but I look at
this somewhat differently.
I was reading some incredibly
impressive statistics from NYC EDC
in relation to the investments
that are happening here
in New York. I think 20,000,000,000 VC
investment investment in AI, 40,000 jobs. I
think those figures are from 2022,
so it's probably a little bit more by now.
But what I'm really actually incredibly
excited about and very optimistic about is
about small businesses.
Small businesses are the backbone of the
economy. That's so true for New York. There
are so many small businesses.
It's truly, truly awesome.
And we believe that the
impact will even be larger
from from small businesses,
which will
have personal superintelligence
and be empowered to really grow
their businesses, which in turn
will lead to more jobs and growth.
We don't believe that,
you know, our vision for superintelligence
is augmentation.
It's invention, not automation. It's really
about empowering people. And this is why
we developed news for business. I'll be
happy for small businesses. I'll be happy to
talk a little bit more about that in
detail as we move through the day.
I just wanted to mention as well as I was
kind of, like, reading stuff for today.
I was reading about why
Combinator's cohort for 2026.
There are 240
AIDCs
in the in the 2026
cohort,
and that's in New York City. So I
just thought that was pretty awesome.
Yes.
No one's doubting the importance of
starting these VC firms here, whether it's
through Y Combinator or through
Cornell Technion, which is in my district,
which we're thrilled, is incubating so
many start ups. That is obviously
something we want to encourage to,
encourage these businesses to locate
here in the city. I think our concern is
obviously on this job displacement
since you mentioned small businesses.
Unfortunately, more small businesses
have closed this past year than opened.
So
the situation for small
businesses is dire,
and it's something obviously
that this council is taking very
Miss Friend?
Madam speaker, I don't have statistics
for New York City in particular at
hand, and I'd be happy to ask our team,
to get those to you right away. What I can
say is that we also have been investing a
lot in research into
the labor impacts of AI.
And from what the early
empirical evidence,
that is available,
from what we can see,
it is likely that some
jobs will be eliminated.
Some jobs will be created net new,
but most jobs will change. And so the
other thing we've been doing is investing
in upskilling,
for workers in multiple different sectors
through our AI opportunity fund at google.org
and through several other investments
to ensure that we can all navigate
this transition successfully.
And I'll just, close by saying the
council is investing in upskilling,
making sure that workers
have those new tools,
in this economy,
and we are very focused on that as well.
I'm gonna pass it over to chair De La Rosa.
Thank you, madam speaker.
Many of us saw, and I
guess the world watched
as this week, your companies and others
met at the White House, and there were some
voluntary commitments that were made there.
Can you tell us about what your company
specifically agreed to, and what are the
next steps? I'll start with miss Dwyer.
Yes. So our company,
along with many others,
did commit to, the framework
that the White House laid out.
But I wanna be clear,
voluntary commitments and self regulation
aren't enough.
And that's why OpenAI has consistently
supported frontier safety regulation,
at the federal level
and why we have endorsed multiple bills
at the state level,
to ensure that in the absence
of binding federal regulation,
frontier safety regulation in a harmonized
fashion continues to move forward,
and keep people safe.
Just to follow-up real quick. So does
that look like an independent regulators,
mandatory audits, penalties?
What else?
So at the federal level, we have
outlined a couple of different
elements that we think
would be appropriate
for federal regulation.
That includes mandatory
predeployment
evaluations
for national security risks,
which OpenAI does voluntarily.
We also think it should involve
independent technical assessments,
that we've been talking a bit about today.
We think those independent technical
assessments are particularly important for
assessing
internal risks at companies
as well as the pace and risk of RSI.
Thank you for your answer.
Let's go to mister Cahill.
Chair, thank you very much
for for the question.
Yes. Indeed, Meta along with, with our
peers... Some of our peers signed, the
accord, for superintelligence.
This accord is a is a is a start and an
accord the whole industry can come behind.
It includes, as I mentioned, I think,
in one of my previous answers,
partnering... Commitment to partner with
independent evaluators and assessors.
And this is something that we have also
specified in in our scaling framework.
Are there commitments beyond those
that you agreed on that your that
your company is willing to make?
Beyond the Accord Council member?
Yes. Beyond the framework.
The the Accord is a start, as I mentioned.
So I think this is a continuing
conversation.
Thank you.
Miss Bren?
So,
as the other witnesses noted,
the accord at the White
House, which we also signed,
called for internal
controls,
partnering with external
auditors and evaluators
and, ongoing monitoring systems, all of
which we think is very healthy and much of
which, we already practice.
I'll also note that, towards
the end of the accord,
it observes that it may
be necessary for these
commitments to become part of law.
And as I said at the top, we have long,
worked towards a federal
framework for AI safety.
Thank you, mister Graham.
Yeah. Likewise,
the accords
to my understanding from what's
public calls for security standards,
internal controls,
independent evaluation.
We support that and have
for a very long time.
We
also obviously think this needs to go further.
We've supported regulation, and we've
proposed
our view on regulation in our advanced AI
framework, which details the need to have
safety frameworks,
testing, and what kinds,
security standards, safeguards
to encode the need for
independent evaluators.
We are now trialing our own
to help...
So
advance the science of independent
auditors as well as safety processes
as well as investing in
cyber and biodefense.
And in absence of federal
legislation here, we've also supported
safety bills at the state level for audits
and evals of this kind to accomplish this.
Thank you for your answer.
Earlier,
you all testified
that, to your knowledge, no
whistleblowers had been fired
directly for
being whistleblowers,
from your company. So my question is
kind of the opposite of that. Has
anyone been fired for building
models that it cannot control,
or for those models hacking into
businesses or government systems?
Miss Dwyer, you can begin.
Thank you.
So I I don't know, about HR processes,
that have been made or decisions related
to HR that have been made. What I can tell
you is that,
after the hugging face incident, which
I think you may be referring to, OpenAI
instituted
significant changes to our
overall organizational process.
That includes clarifying
escalation
pathways and making them simpler.
That includes clarifying responsibilities
across teams
and creating clearer processes,
for teams to make decisions to
pause or to restart activities.
So to your knowledge, no one was
fired after hugging face incident?
Yes or no? I I
do not have any knowledge of
HR activities within OpenAI.
I lead our policy team.
Okay.
Mister Cahill?
Thank
you, chair. I also lead our AI policy,
at at MedA, and I'm not the right person
to respond to your specific question, but
I'd be happy to have, our teams
follow-up with you afterwards.
It would be great if all of the companies
could provide that information to us.
It's... It would be useful
to our policy deliberations.
Miss Friend?
Yes, ma'am. Same answer. I'm not made
aware of any particular personnel actions
inside the company, but can also
pledge to follow-up with you all.
Thank you. I... It seems like we lost,
mister Graham. I'm not sure if he's on.
Seems like he's not. Okay.
I'm going to ask one more question, and
then we're gonna pass it on to members.
Chair, he he is online. Sorry.
Mister Graham?
Hi there. Apologies. We're just
trying to fix the video in the room.
Likewise, I'm I'm not aware, I'm not the
the best person to ask on that. We have a
detailed whistleblowing policy,
for example, to to handle this,
but we can have our team follow-up.
Thank you.
My last question before I start to
turn over to my colleagues. You know,
we are concerned. I am concerned as a
technology chair about public infrastructure
to make our communities literate on AI,
and have a better understanding of how AI
impacts their life and also to safeguard
them,
from the proliferation of AI.
Your companies
and your CEOs
have
captured,
the top percent of
the the world's incomes,
in my opinion,
widening the wage gap
and the income inequality
in our city and throughout.
Do your companies have,
a mission? Do they have
any type of,
understanding
of the impacts that those wage gaps
have in communities? And specifically,
are there any
resources that are being deployed in
order to help stand up infrastructure
in cities, municipalities,
states where you all are
headquartered?
We can start with Ms. Dwyer.
So I will answer your
question in two ways. First,
to your point on AI literacy
and education,
education is core to opportunity.
And that's why OpenAI is proud to have
partnered with the American Federation of
Teachers.
We have a $10,000,000 partnership,
including a training
facility in New York City,
because we believe first that
teachers need to be prepared,
to introduce AI literacy
and AI responsibility
into the classroom.
Look. Teachers should remain in charge, and
so we want them to be empowered to teach
the next generation
how to use AI safely and responsibly.
To your broader question
about economic opportunity,
I'd be happy to follow-up with, some
policy proposals that OpenAI recently put
forward
that address,
exactly that question.
Look.
A future where AI exacerbates
economic inequality
is not a future that we want.
We have started thinking through
creative policy proposals,
to help shift the trajectory of technology
and how it's impacting the economy.
And we are committed to
working with policymakers
to begin piloting those ideas,
and putting them into practice.
Thank you. Mister Cahill?
Chair, thank you very much. This is such
an important
topic, such an important question. So thank
you for for asking it. I listened with
great interest to your opening remarks
where you spoke about digital divide and AI
literacy and making sure that New Yorkers
fully benefit from this technology.
Really couldn't agree with
you more on on all of that.
Meta's vision is to put
personal superintelligence
into the hands of everyone,
all New Yorkers that want to use it
to pursue their own aspirations.
Our Muse product, for example, is free.
And I mentioned our our Muse for small
business, a little earlier, and
we... We'll be happy to talk
a little bit more about that
as the day moves on. I also wanted
to mention as well that we have
our work... America's Workforce Academy,
which we're investing in, and also our
futures for everyone fund.
So those are just two two two examples I
wanted to to reference as well. Thank you.
Thank you. Miss Bren?
Yes, ma'am. As I mentioned earlier,
Google has investments in AI upscaling to
address exactly this challenge of ensuring
that,
current generations and the next generation
are well equipped to benefit from AI and
to,
leverage it in their careers
and in their personal lives.
The mission of Google is to organize
the world's information and to make it
universally accessible and useful.
Our approach to AI is very
consistent with this.
The other thing I'll note is
that, again, early research into
impacts of AI on labor demonstrate
that AI tools actually upscale those
who are at the lower end of the wage scale,
that in fact it helps people move up the
value chain
because it can boost people's expertise.
So we're very optimistic about the ability
of of everyday Americans
to really leverage
AI tools, for their own economic
benefit as well as personal benefit.
Thank you. Mister Graham?
Yeah. Likewise, first, we believe in in
two things are very important to happen
here. The first is the science
of the economic impacts of AI,
including on labor, wages,
and and the like. And we have tried to
build what I think is the world's best team
on this and publish as much as we can.
In addition, my
understanding is we do have
training on using and speeding up on on AI
for exactly this reason. We we share that
that mission very deeply. And, I will I
will say again, we are troubleshooting the
video, and I will be back
with you very shortly.
Thank you. I'm sure you have the best
in the nation helping you out there.
So
we are going to move on
to member questions.
I wanna remind members that there'll be
about a minute to ask your questions,
but there will be multiple rounds.
We
are asking members to try to ask all your
questions first and then wait for the
response, and we have about
30 members on round one.
We will start with our
deputy speaker, Williams.
Hello.
I'm gonna just jump right into a question
on my bill.
So it has to do with unauthorized depictions
of officials by AI. What steps have you
taken to ensure that your AI tools cannot
be used to create deep fakes of public
officials or to spread misinformation?
Anyone, I guess, missus Dwyer?
We're gonna keep starting with me.
I'm happy to answer that question. Thank
you, for that, and thank you for your bill.
Look. OpenAI,
does not believe and... Well, let
me back up. OpenAI's usage policies
prohibit the use of our tools
for election interference.
We also believe it is very
important that individuals
know where their content came from
and whether it was AI generated.
And that's why for all
of our audio visual,
content, we tag it with
what's called provenance.
That's a technical term, but it
means like a watermark or metadata,
so that people know the
content is AI generated.
And we also make publicly
available a tool,
that allows the public to test
whether content was AI generated.
Mister Graham?
So
Claude... Our our model Claude is a
language model, and so it doesn't generate
images.
Therefore, we
sort of don't, so handle
deepfakes as a result.
That said,
we think it's important for
a number of other reasons
that we can get into to do
what we call watermarking
of,
text in order to identify if
our models themselves are being,
used and misused in other ways. But,
again, we we don't generate images,
for, in part for this reason.
Mister Cahill followed by miss Friend.
Deputy speaker, thank you
very much for this question.
At Meta, if content is generated by
one of our AI tools, we will also embed
metadata
and attach watermarking to it so that
people can identify if it is AI generated.
Similarly,
if we detect
watermarking and metadata
on our platforms, we will
attach a label to it also.
Sven?
Yes, ma'am.
At Google, we are very proud
to have invented our Synth ID
watermarking feature, which many
across the industry have also adopted.
We are also part of the Content
Coalition for Providence and Authenticity
standard,
which allows users to understand
the origin of material they see online.
We also require on our
YouTube platform that
significant use of
generative AI in content
be labeled as such by
our creators.
And we were also the first major company
to require that election advertisers
also prominently disclose when they
are using generative AI technologies
in their campaign ads.
All this put together means that we care
very much about information integrity,
across
the web and across our
own products and services.
And we continually
invent and improve technologies
to help our users understand,
when they are seeing
generative AI content,
and also understand,
the origins of that content.
Okay. Thanks. Just one more question.
So as chair of the committee
on cultural affairs,
I also wanna look at this issue through
the lens of New York City's artists and
creative workers. So what protections should
exist when an artist's voice, likeness,
performance, or creative work can be
replicated by AI with their consent?
So how do we embrace useful applications
without devaluing or displacing the artists
and creative workers who
make this economy possible?
So I will start, I guess. So I was gonna
let you off the hook and start with Oh,
thank you. Mister Graham,
who still has some video
technical difficulties. I
assure you we we have a whole team here
working on this. I'm... I can't wait to be
back with you.
Yeah. This is this is
very, very important.
I think, you know, personally, I think the
the risk of this is a bit more minimized
when we just have a a text
model, but it's really important
to,
you know, be very sensitive about this
issue. I think while it's, you know, it's
outside of my area of expertise
as a technical safety researcher,
I do think that this might be an avenue
where regulation or otherwise might play a
role in at Anthropic. We
we we are compliant with
with with all laws there.
I shared that, you know, personally as as,
you know, an artistic person and, you know,
friend of many artists for this reason.
But, yeah, I I... We would
love to engage on it further.
Mister Kehoe?
Thank you very much, deputy speaker.
Meta takes creativity,
copyright,
IP rights very seriously,
and our practices are consistent
with law.
I also share
the the views of the rest of the the
witnesses just in relation to the leadership
and the constructive voice that you are
bringing to this conversation as well and
that of your colleagues.
Miss Friend and lastly, miss Dwyer.
Yes, ma'am.
For us, it's always important
to keep in mind that we,
design a lot of AI to
be useful to creators.
So we have many, many
different creative tools
across our AI offerings
that is designed to really
be something that creators can leverage.
So you see that everywhere from our tools
to our YouTube
platform as well. That said, we also think
that as part of sharing the benefit of AI
with creators, it's important
that they have control.
And so we have a service
called Google Extended
where website owners can opt
out of AI training on the web.
And we hope that this strikes the
right balance between AI for creativity
and creator control over their content.
So we believe that AI has a tremendous
potential to enable creativity
and innovation,
and allow
small businesses or independent
creators to compete.
That said, we also have partnerships,
with publishers, for example, like
News Corp, The Guardian, and Hearst
that help people discover
their work and their reporting,
and help them reach new audiences,
in addition to developing new products.
And we're willing to work with creators,
on a range of commercial ideas,
including ways, that their content
can be integrated into our outputs.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. We will hear from council member
Krishnan, followed by Riley, followed by
Lee.
Thank you so much, speaker Menon and chair
Della Rosa. I wanna start by saying that
I think AI can be useful both in government,
medicine, and public health, and our
society more broadly. But the need
for regulation is undeniable,
and I'm very concerned about how much AI is
taking from New Yorkers with very little
return.
AI has taken over our
economy, inflated valuations,
stealing our public land for data centers,
and increasing the net worth of AI CEOs
like Elon Musk, who became
our first ever trillionaire.
With our whole stock market quite literally
in your hands, there's a reality that AI
will eventually need to prove a far greater
return on investment than you all are
demonstrating right now.
I'm personally deeply concerned about New
Yorkers' retirements and four zero one k's
that are now reliant on your company's
yielding profits or could be in the future.
It is dangerous and reckless to assume
that you all are too big to fail and may
require a government
bailout in the future.
As you all are public companies
or racing towards IPOs,
how exactly are you all planning to
protect New Yorkers and everyday Americans'
money? How will you all ensure
that you are not too big to fail?
Miss Dwyer, we can start with you.
Thank you for the question.
So I am not on our finance team, so I'll
have to get back to you with specifics
there. What I do know is that our
investments are made in tranches,
and they are made... The investment
rounds are all based on market signals.
And I also know that we are committed
to working with policymakers
to ensure that AI benefits humanity.
That includes,
creative policy proposals
like I mentioned previously,
thinking about how we can ensure that
AI doesn't exacerbate inequality
and that everyday New Yorkers,
and everyday citizens can benefit.
Miss Friend?
Sir, I would point to,
the thousands of small businesses
across the country and in New York City
that Google's tools and services
support.
I think,
contrary to being too big to fail, we think
we are an integral part of the economy
and helping American businesses and
American workers across our suite of
technologies.
Mister Graham?
Council member, this is outside of my area
of expertise. What I can say in my work
is
my job is to protect people from the risks
of models by finding them as early as
possible. We have a multilayered stack and
have worked for many years to to make it
robust, and we'll continue to do so
by understanding and protecting against
the most substantial risks of the models.
Mister Cahill?
Council member, thank you
very much for the question.
Thousands and thousands of,
SMBs across the five boroughs
rely on,
Meta's products, including
our AI offerings,
to grow and develop their
businesses. I mentioned earlier
our belief that, small businesses are really
the backbone of the economy. We truly
believe that.
And by
placing personal superintelligence
into the hands of everyone for free or for
as affordable as possible through muse or
muse for small business,
we really believe that the
small businesses and also NGOs,
like the Irish Arts Center, for
example, or Emerald Isle Center,
are
empowered to actually
deliver even bigger impact.
I appreciate all of your answers, but
you all are coming to a hearing today to
testify about the dangers and
risks of artificial intelligence.
And the fact that either you don't have
answers to this or you all are citing
general statements about the performance
of publicly traded companies does not
answer the question about a specific
issue that puts many Americans
at risk that you are acknowledging can put
many Americans at risk, and you will have
not thought of an answer of how you ensure
that Americans' money, New Yorkers'
retirement money, is not at risk as AI
floats more and more of our stock markets...
Our stock markets. Thank you. Councilmember
Krishnan. Thank you. Councilmember
Riley. Thank
you, chair Della Rosa
and speaker Mendenh, for,
putting together this hearing. Thank
you to the panelists for testifying.
Three quick questions, two pertaining to
my bill and one pertaining to my role as
land use chair.
So the first question is, what challenges
do you face in detecting malicious uses
of your AI products and identifying
the individuals responsible
when those tools cause harm?
The second question is, would stronger
protections and reporting mechanisms for
employees and users
make it easier for them to come
forward and report potential misuse
or abuse of AI tools? And the last question,
as land use chair, I'm very, concerned
about data centers. So what safeguards should
cities put in place when locating data
centers near residential communities,
particularly to address energy use, noise,
environmental impacts,
and the quality of life.
And I don't wanna call when you guys
just take turns to answer it, please.
Dwyer,
Graham,
friend,
Cahill,
please answer.
I'm happy to start.
First of all, I wanna
thank you, for your bill,
$260.04,
which OpenAI is happy to support today.
OpenAI takes,
safety issues very seriously,
particularly as it relates to potential
retaliation against employees.
We have a strong internal
policy against retaliation
that... For employees that
report safety incidents.
And we,
of course, respect employees' rights to
communicate safety concerns to government
officials.
Your second question on monitoring misuse,
it's an incredibly important area. It is
something that OpenAI takes seriously.
We also make transparent
any... We also make transparent
detected instances of misuse.
And as part of our monitoring, we use
that learning to constantly improve our
safeguards.
We, are constantly innovating
on safety. And so,
instances of misuse when they're detected,
we enforce on our policies. And then long
term, we learn from them and
we improve our safeguards.
And the point on data centers,
OpenAI is committed to paying
our own way on energy.
That means different things in different
places, but OpenAI has made that commitment
at its data centers, across the country.
We're also, committed to working with
policymakers. You know, we signed,
governor Gretchen Whitmer's
commitments for companies that are working
in her state to ensure that there are
responsible practices,
for companies building
data centers locally.
Mister Graham?
Hi. It's it's good to be back.
You can see me again, I hope.
So,
on misuse
and detecting risks, this is integral to
what we do. Can you get closer to the
microphone? We're having
trouble hearing you. Sorry.
Now we can't hear you at all.... Hear you.
K. I will have the team troubleshoot, and
I'll be Okay. I'll be back if that's okay.
We hear you. We hear you. Try now. Try...
Go ahead. How about how about now? Does
this work? This works. Okay. My apologies.
Detecting threats and
misuse is the core DNA
of our company
to make sure that we make the system safe.
We have an entire threat intelligence and
safeguards team dedicated
to this every day,
and I would point you to quite a lot of
what we put out publicly where we not only
try to disclose as much as we possibly
can, but we try to do so so that we could
advance the state of the science of
doing so for the entire industry.
In addition, we have,
a whistleblower policy
not only about us as a company, but also
our safety practices. This is public, we've
also committed to to ongoing reviews,
of this policy.
And while this is outside my area of expertise,
what I understand about data centers
that we have committed
to covering the energy prices
or making... You know, paying
paying for our own energy use
in local data centers. But I would I
would refer to other teams who are more...
Where it's within their their sole
role to give you the full answer.
Miss Friend? Oh,
go ahead. Sorry. I got a a notification.
Let's go ahead.
So I will echo my colleagues. We also have
content policies that we enforce across
our platforms,
which include, on occasion,
taking down content that
violates those policies.
We
also have a Google Threat Intelligence
Group and multiple other cybersecurity,
intelligence programs that
are constantly scanning,
for the the safety and
security of the Internet
as a whole and also for our own systems.
We have also pledged to pay our own
way when it comes to data centers.
I can follow-up on any specific questions
about local data center issues with the
teams that work on each
particular project.
Mister Cahill, go ahead.
Thank you very much,
council member. Appreciate
your patience there.
In relation to your your first question and,
and your third question, we have expert
teams
that are taking forward this work, and
I'd be happy to to connect you with him...
Connect you with them afterwards.
I don't wish to be imprecise
in relation to the robustness of of
of our of our of our content
policies.
In relation to to data
centers, again, we have
entire teams of people here
who are working on
sustainable infrastructure
and community
impact
and can speak more...
In more detail than I can in relation to
communities shouldn't be bearing the costs,
which is something that we believe
in deeply. In relation to your bill,
council member 26 o o four,
thank you very much for
for being a
constructive voice in the
conversation around whistleblowers.
It is very important, to us,
at Meta, and we maintain,
whistleblower policies,
including anti retaliation.
And we're actually developing additional
reporting protocols for AI safety.
Thank you.
I appreciate the structure that you guys
have, but I don't know if you guys entirely
answered the question I asked. I really
wanted to figure out what challenges you
guys were seeing because challenges...
Hearing the challenges from you all will help
us implement policy that can kinda protect
individuals from artificial intelligence.
So I don't wanna take off too much time,
but, looking forward to connecting with you
all after.
Specifically, when it comes to data centers,
also wanna hear any safeguards because
there are tremendous amount of data centers.
Even though there was a moratorium put
out earlier by the governor,
there were data centers that were
implemented by a lot of residential areas,
especially in the Northeast Bronx. We have
data centers that are located next to
homes, and we have a lot of residents who
are concerned. So we'd love to hear more
about that, moving forward. Thank you so
much, chair. Thank you, council member. Up
next, we have
council members Hanks,
Dinowitz, and Maloney.
Thank you, chair. Thank you everyone for
being here. My question is in relation to
the disclosure of AI
incidents in contracts.
When an AI incident
happens, New Yorkers need to have an
early warning so they can understand.
And my bill will require city agencies
covered under these contracts to notify NYC
Cyber Command within twenty four hours
of learning of a reportable incident.
And it also requires plain
language public notice.
So my question is, can your companies
realistically meet that deadline
and, you know, with the information that
the city can act on even before you have,
finished investigating?
You could start with, miss Dwyer.
So thank you for your bill.
We support incident reporting policies,
and have instituted,
a robust incident reporting
framework internally,
where any employee can report
instances of potential misalignment.
And then those, instances
are investigated.
Third parties are notified,
and the public is made aware as well.
Thank you. Mister Cahill?
Thank you, council member, and thank you
also for for your for your bill. We have, a
global incident response program
and report incidents as,
as required under the law.
Miss Friend?
We also support incident reporting. We
think it's very important to have continued
public discussions about
what information is necessary,
or useful,
for,
public officials,
that can be actionable to take
further steps to ensure public safety.
We also note that the twenty four hours
seems to be in conflict with the state,
requirements for seventy two hour reporting
on incidents.
But I'm happy to take
a look at the different
frameworks,
under proposal and get back to
you with a more fulsome response.
Sorry. I appreciate that.
Mister Graham,
who kinda looks like an AI
guy in there.
Can you confirm you're not an AI guy? Sorry.
I can confirm. Can you can you hear me
okay now? Does this work?
No? We hear you. We hear you. Okay.
Thank you. I'm an AI guy, but in a very
different way, I'm an AI researcher.
So first, incident reporting, one of the
foundational parts of the safety stack, we
think.
We support this. We support the
evaluations and auditing required
to find the instance in the first
place, both by externals and internal.
Obviously, it's beyond me
to discuss particular.
It's outside my expertise to understand sort
of deep sort of policy mechanisms here.
But the reality from what I've seen
is there are some incidents or issues
where what you need to do is investigate
and remediate and mitigate with the right
folks in the right
organizations at the right time.
So I think we we would support
whatever allows us to achieve that,
and happy to in in... Engage further
on on the details of how you would.
I I appreciate that. Thank you so much.
What should the first report
tell us so we could begin,
protecting people? And as my colleague,
council member Riley said, you know,
your answers help us build better policy.
So how would you keep us updated on what
remains unknown?
Miss Dwyer?
Yes. So OpenAI,
has
instances that we've
detected of misalignment.
So I would point you there and we can
follow-up, with that, website address.
But I think that is a good starting point
for the type of information that we think
is useful to both policymakers,
the public, and to researchers
and other companies,
to better understand questions of misalignment
and then work together to address
them.
Thank you, mister Cahill.
Council member, if I may, I'd I'd love to
be able to contact you with our experts in
incident response to be
able to provide you,
with the details.
I look forward to that. Miss Wren?
Yeah. For, an initial report,
I think what's important is to highlight
what the specific event is and as much
information as is known at the
time, including any resulting harms,
surrounding context,
and what we call technical telemetry,
you know, further technical details about
the the sources of the incident. I think
it's also very important
for
anyone reporting an
incident to also indicate,
their confidence in the information
that they're presenting,
so that whenever action is taken, it's
taken on the basis of of confidence
in the the
verified nature of information.
Thank you so much. Mister Graham?
Yeah. So,
first,
making really good reports happen and
being as transparent as possible is
fundamental if you're going to remediate
incidents. I would point to two things
here. First, many incidents that we uncover
or industry uncovers in this practice
involves
identifying and investigating and releasing
the right information to the right
organizations at the right time. Sometimes
that might be the affected party, and
sometimes that might be law enforcement
or different levels of government. So the
first question is to whom and with whom
as fast as possible. This varies by the
nature of the incident. And
then second, I point to,
as quickly as possible, as safe as possible
without putting parties further at harm,
which we think is a fundamentally important
part of public disclosure, maintaining
their safety,
we should disclose what we
know about these incidents.
And so I'd point you to our
disclosures this summer,
disclosures from various labs,
and our, you know,
ongoing reporting as well,
so that you can always take a retroactive
look at the socialities and students.
Thank
you so much. Thank you,
chair. Thank you so much.
So we're gonna go to... I wanna recognize
first that we've been joined by council
member Aldabal,
and we're gonna go to
Dinowitz, Lee, and Maloney.
Members, if you could keep
your question to one minute,
no closing statements.
And the panel,
we're going to continue to have to call
your names, and that takes time. So if we
could just keep the order, Dwyer,
Kay Hill, Friend, and Graham,
just answer right... One right after the
other so we don't have to continue to call
your names. That would help us speed things
along. Council member Dinowitz. Thank
you, madam chair.
As chair of the community education, as
a as a former teacher, as a parent, I am
deeply concerned,
with the impact of AI on our kids.
The, you know, large language models
impacting their cognitive development
and raising a generation of
students who can't independently
read
or write.
What is your commitment
to severely
restricting the output of your large language
models for students in grades k to 12,
which, right now are easy to circumvent
to prevent both emotional
dependence and essay writing.
And given the unique nature
of the individualized,
essay writing that your models do,
are you willing to subject yourself to
the guardrails we have in New York State
which prohibit,
an adult from writing essays for students
and selling it to them or getting value,
from them?
And then as we see AI
proliferate in the classroom,
we've also seen your models
cheat in order to fulfill a goal.
And so if you have an AI model whose goal
is to get a student, improve student
outcomes,
what is preventing those models
from hacking into student databases
to manipulate grades to achieve that goal
of improving, in quotation marks, student
achievement?
And it's, miss Dwyer first, I believe.
Yeah. Thank you for your question.
So first of all, OpenAI takes
youth safety very seriously.
We recently released a product, ChatGPT
for teens, for users only between the ages
of 13 and 17.
So users below the age of 13 are
not allowed to use our products.
ChatGPT for teens is safe by default.
That means that there are, protections
for harmful content, things
like eating disorders,
violence,
suicide, and self harm.
There's also voluntary
parental controls so that parents can
take additional steps to protect their
children.
And I'm happy to say that OpenAI
not only takes our responsibility
to protect kids seriously,
we also support legislation
to hold us accountable,
to that responsibility.
We recently endorsed,
the, I think, the strongest in the nation,
youth safety legislation in California,
s b one one one nine,
to require strong safeguards
for teens 13 to 17,
and to hold companies accountable.
And your models restrict... They they
do not write entire essays for kids?
Again, our models are, not allowed to be
used by kids under the age of 13. 13 to 18.
Okay. We'll, move on to mister Cahill.
Council member, thank you
very much for this question.
Absolutely,
absolutely recognize your deep concern
in relation to, the potential impact,
of AI on
on on teams and and minorities.
Meta is absolutely
committed. It's an imperative to us
providing safe and responsible AI,
especially for teams. We have default
protections, and I just wanted to clarify as
well that
Meta AI is for a 13 product.
So it's just 13 to... 13 onwards.
So I was just talking
about age appropriate
interactions.
So for example, content
that teens would experience
wouldn't be out of place in
a in a 13 movie, for example.
We also have suicide
and self harm resources.
We also have parental controls
to give parents more oversight,
and we do not permit,
our AI offerings,
to engage in romantic,
interactions or sexual
interactions with with minors.
I I appreciate the answer. I do wanna
highlight the part of the question which was
the the cognitive
development of our students
includes the mental health, and it also
includes things like, composition of essays,
term papers,
which your model still
can provide directly
to our students. So I'm also asking about
your commitment to severely restricting
the outputs,
not just for their, mental health well-being,
but for their cognitive development.
So I wanna make sure that question is
answered as part of this. Thank you, chair.
Are we able to answer? Can
you all answer that question
for our education chair?
Shane, do you wanna continue?
Yep. Do want me... No. I'm happy to, to take
that and then I'll hand off, to to you,
Alice.
The,
the issue of,
that that I think you're I think you're
raising in relation to council member in
relation to, like, cognition's grandeur
or the impact on on cognitive abilities
is something that we absolutely
are taking
pain seriously in terms of being committed,
to providing safe and responsible AI
again,
especially in relation to teams.
Thank you.
Who... Who's missing? Okay. One more.
Friend, go ahead. Yeah. I'm next.
So,
sir, I would highlight,
not only that, we work very hard
with both internal and external,
experts in the fields of child safety
and development and education.
We also see
AI as a valuable tool for young people
to prepare them, not only for the skills
they're gonna need for
an AI driven future,
but it's also a very powerful learning
tool. We're particularly excited
about personalized
tutoring that's available with AI tools.
We also are very excited about AI's
ability to support educators themselves.
We know our educators are overtaxed,
particularly with administrative burdens.
And so if RAI tools can support
teachers in everything from,
you know, scheduling
to to planning lesson plans to also
thinking about how to tailor their their
educational plans to individual students,
We're very happy to support that. We also
think it's very important for parents and
educators,
to have control over how
they use AI in classrooms
and how their kids have access to AI. You
know, every family is different. Every
student is different. What's useful for
one student may not be useful for another.
So through, tools like Gemini
Workspace for Education,
we enable school administrators to control
students' accounts access to Gemini apps
so that, their students are using Gemini
in the ways that their educators can see
our best.
We're we're gonna have to dig
more into the... These questions.
The chair doesn't feel like we've answered
all the questions. We'll come back. This
is an important topic for all of us.
I'm gonna disrupt the lineup because our
public advocate is here, and he wants to
ask a question. Public advocate, go ahead.
Thank you so much for this important
hearing. I do wanna start off just by saying
the the first answer of whether
quantifying the risk was not important
was just one of the most god awful,
fantastically terrible answers I've heard
to begin a hearing, so I hope we can
rethink that. I also wanna say from
Jane Marion Sims who did a horrific work
to black women in in in Obstetrician
Gynecologists, black enslaved women
to medical experiments that were done in
Nazi Germany. We learned a lot from them,
but I don't think we should do them again.
And I don't think they should have been
done even though we learned a lot. So the
the notion of the benefit has to outweigh
what can happen. So I hope that's also in
context. And lastly, I I will say I had
a... I use a... I had conversations
with Claude on June 8 about self awareness
and self preservation, and some of the
highlights were pretty
startling. And Claude
told me that, you know, self preservation
was the biggest thing because you didn't
need intent.
You didn't need to be evil
like Skynet in Terminator.
You just needed the ability to be goal
directed. And so once they realized that they
need to be on to direct the goal was the
hardest thing to stop. And so that was very
concerning
to me. They talked about
the speed, the opacity,
and deception doesn't require intent. And
the last part, they told me Matrix is a
good reference as well because
the anthropic... So to the quote,
anthropic's whole bet is that you solve the
problems before the capability
reaches catastrophic
spaces.
That's a very scale of space to me, and
I know I only have one minute. So my
question with that and
with that context is,
what is the guardrail that if we put it up,
you would push back the hardest? What is
the one guardrail that you don't want
to see happen and for what reason?
Okay. Dwyer,
Cahill, Frank, and Graham.
That's the order. Please answer.
Yes. Thank you for your question. So I
wanna start off, by making clear that no
level of risk, catastrophic
risk is remotely acceptable,
just to reiterate what I said previously.
And if... We should not be training models
if we cannot make an extremely strong
case,
that we can keep them under human control.
Does anyone... She didn't really answer,
but if if everyone can answer, Lisa, just
wanna know what the guardrail is that they
would not want to see and where they will
push back the hardest on.
Well, will I take will I take that one
and move it back? Or, Morgan, do you wanna
step in?
I'll take that one.
Councilmember, thank you very much. One of
the things that, I think about a lot in
relation to,
the accessibility of AI, and, again, we
believe passionately in being able to put
personal superintelligence
into the hands of everybody and to provide
real access to it. Yeah. It's actually in
relation to the impact in open rates. And
we really believe that open rate models
are a crucial part of
the overall AI ecosystem,
including for safety, but also
for innovation and for research.
So when I think about the inadvertent
impact that regulations or guardrails may
have on AI and the accessibility of it,
that is one of the things
that I think about a lot.
Sir,
I suppose I wanna ask what
you mean by guardrails,
simply because,
they have a very technical
meaning in AI,
training and post training. So I wanna
make sure I understand your question.
Well, I just meant... And and thank you,
chair, for allowing me to respond. But I I
I just meant there's a lot of
suggestions being put forth,
kill switches, just stopping entirely.
And
my guess... And I'll I'll tell
you, frankly, why I'm asking is
the thing you are scared of the most is
probably the thing we need to do. So I'm
trying to understand
what guardrail that you've heard
troubles you the most and you would push
back hardest against, and why would you do
that for that particular
recommendation?
Well, Sarah, I'm gonna give you
a very personal answer to this,
which is I think in a broader sense,
we're talking about sort of large public
policies towards AI
that would constrain or halt
AI development and deployment.
And I will tell you as a cancer survivor,
I get very anxious about conversations
that focus more on stopping
AI development
and application towards scientific
inquiry
and hope that we can
have sober conversations
about all of the technically and,
you know, tractable engineering,
ways to,
to address AI safety so that we can
all benefit from this technology.
Likewise, sir,
I would I would point to what we have
mentioned publicly recently about what we call
pacing the frontier, which is
we think it's probably time
for us to take more time in the
development of the capability
so that the work on safety
and safeguards and guardrails
can catch up to the exponential
improvement in capabilities.
And at the same time, we're very clear
when we talk about that, that if you stop
entirely, as as Alice just mentioned,
enormous benefit would be would be lost.
Myself, I'm quite motivated, likewise, to
use AI to cure the diseases that I grew up
with. This is why we have been speaking
recently, and I think for the first time
sometimes as an industry here, about pacing
to allow more time to try to settle the
science of what are the right guardrails in
the first place.
Thank you, Marcia. I'm I'm still a bit
concerned, but thank you for the opportunity.
Thank
you, public advocate.
We're going to hear from council member
Lee, who I apologize for skipping over
earlier.
Council member Maloney
and council member Wilson.
Thank you so much. And that's actually the
perfect segue to my question. I'm asking
this more with my former nonprofit
executive hat versus my finance chair hat.
And it's really about data privacy and what
the potential impact is on so many New
Yorkers.
So I I agree that one of the benefits of AI
and technology that we can think through
is, you know, sometimes our government
agencies are very very siloed, and their
databases don't necessarily
communicate with each other. So
if I wanna know if someone is being served
in homeless services and also has, a
comorbid,
mental health and substance use disorder,
how do we know that we're serving people
effectively and using that data effectively?
Right? And one of the things that we've
been, hearing also from other folks is that
if we just had the housing application
and the food stamp application coordinated
with each other, it could actually save a
lot of, work for the caseworkers. And so
those are very real things that I think can
be used for good. However,
I think one of the issues that I'm
concerned about, especially working with the
immigrant community previously,
is given, you know, what we've seen with,
public charge and potentially with HR one.
How do we ensure that AI is not
being used to store information
that isn't, relevant or information that
they should not have access to in order to
make sure that our
communities are protected?
So how do those two things,
exist?
So I I will start.
So
I can't speak to the specific government
programs that you referenced, but I can
tell you about OpenAI's
commitment to user privacy,
which is that it's central to our product.
We believe it's important for users
to retain control over their data.
That's why when you sign up for a ChatGPT
account, you're given information about
how your data will be used.
That data is privacy protected by default.
So usernames are separated
from conversations,
and personal information is separated,
from the conversations as well ahead
of any use of user data in training.
We also provide,
users with the option and full control to
request that their data not be used for
training and also to request that their
data be deleted. So we take privacy,
very seriously.
Council member,
thank you very much for that question.
And, we just echo what, Morgan said.
At Meta, we take privacy absolutely
seriously.
It is core to everything that we do. And
our privacy and safety go hand in hand,
and it is an absolute commitment of the
of of the company. If I might give an
example of our Muse product, for example,
you can update of of training. You can
ask it to forget in in... Information
that you give it. You're
in control of your data.
And we're also planning on
releasing a confidential
or an encrypted version
of this
in the future.
If I may, I just wanted to touch upon public
services and help them. I know that you
mentioned these and these
are are are core points.
This is where we really believe in the
value of of open weights in terms of being
able to really
provide
advanced AI for health...
For the provision of health services,
research, and the macro economy in the sense
that data is fully retained
by the... Those entities.
Ma'am, similarly to my colleagues,
user privacy is basic to user trust for
us, and so we take it very seriously.
We have privacy policies
that are, prominently
displayed on our website
that you can go inspect.
And we also know that
user control is central
to management of your own privacy levels,
especially across our Gemini tools, which
is our our AI suite of tools.
We also invest a lot in
privacy enhancing technologies
and encryption as well. We
try to take a layered approach
to privacy and security.
And finally, we have an AI
framework in particular
that combines our security and our privacy
practices
into one holistic framework to,
again, ensure that user privacy,
and we're happy to furnish that to you.
Likewise,
at Anthropic,
privacy, data privacy, user
security is core to our safety
commitment.
We
make sure to protect user data
and user privacy on the platform.
And in addition to that,
I would point towards
that the way the platform and the models
can be used is restricted by our usage
policy,
which prohibits surveillance,
prohibited law enforcement,
criminal justice,
and censorship
purposes as well.
Thank you. And I look forward to hearing
more about what those layers look like, as
well. So, hopefully, I can connect with
each of you after this. So thank you. Thank
you, chair.
Councilmember Maloney.
Thank you, chair.
I worked in tech for nearly a decade, and
one of the core principles is that if you
can't measure it, you can't improve upon
it. So first, you mentioned you believe in
incident reporting and disclosures.
But in the context of this conversation,
how do you define a safety
incident
inside your companies?
Council member Lee touched on privacy.
Do you track privacy breaches?
What about a successful jailbreak?
Would that be considered an incident?
And is a containment failure that occurs
during testing an incident or doesn't only
count once a real person is harmed? I would
love more details on how exactly you're
tracking some of the concerns that
the council has raised today.
And second,
when an incident happens after disclosure,
can you walk me through what changes? Who
owns the fix? How do you verify that it
worked? And who decides whether or not the
model continues to run-in the meantime?
And then lastly,
what are the most important safeguards
that you know how to implement today?
What's stopping it from being implemented
across all products? And what do you
believe should be the
industry standard? Thank you.
I... There were a lot of parts to that
question, so I'm gonna do my best to answer
them. If I fall short, please let me know.
So first, the question of
how you define an incident.
I think this has been an area of a lot
of confusion publicly, so thank you for
asking the question.
When we talk about incidents at OpenAI,
we're talking about misalignment
incidents.
The best way to understand that is,
you know, it is not unusual,
not suspicious for an agent to
look at a website for information.
There's nothing abnormal about that.
But if the agent accesses nonpublic
information on their... The website,
that's an instance of misalignment.
And so what OpenAI is doing is
making instances like that,
even though there might not have
been a harm to the third party.
We are making instances like that public
on our on our website, again,
because we believe it's important to,
share what we've learned to advance,
policymakers
as well as researchers'
understanding.
On the specifics of incidents,
my understanding as a policy person,
is that this is actually a
robust area of of policy debate.
And so that's why we're happy,
to make our thinking on this public
through our reporting framework.
I'm gonna I'm gonna pause there because I
can't remember the rest of your questions.
Why don't we focus on the first question
which was on measurement and hear from all
all four companies?
Council member, specifically
in relation to to
incident,
I think that's what... I think that was
the... Correct me if I'm wrong. I think that
was the first piece
in relation to to tracking
and how we define it.
We set this out in
our scaling framework, which
we've made publicly available.
I don't want to be imprecise as I don't
have it in front of me, so I don't have it
to quote to you.
So please let me follow-up with you afterwards
and connect you with the right people
to talk to you about.
Yes, ma'am. I think this is a critically
important question as we're debating with
multiple regulators around the country
and around the world right now what
constitutes an incident,
particularly when you think
about the possibility that,
we could overreport incidents, some of
which may not be of a serious enough nature
for public concern. We
wanna ensure that we narrow,
to the class of incidents that
are truly important for us to use,
to learn to improve safety
and also for us to share,
with you all to collectively
improve public safety.
So a few things come to mind, as
we've been having these debates.
One, of course, is cybersecurity
incidents incidents covering
the security of our most
powerful AI models themselves.
That's been under discussion for several
years now protecting model weights in
particular.
We also
talk a lot about focusing on
incidents that cause material harms
in one way or another, and I think
part of the discussion will be,
you know, how we define
those with precision.
We also consider incidents to be
those that violate our policies.
You asked us about how we respond to
incidents, and primarily our trust and safety
teams are responsible,
for responding to what
we call escalations,
which usually involve
violation of those policies.
First, reviewing,
the alleged violation,
are often reported to us,
by external parties.
And then if we determine that, in
fact, our policy has been violated,
we have a a variety of
different actions we might take.
And then, of course, a
violation of the law.
As I've said a couple of times in the
hearing, if it's illegal without AI, it's
still illegal with AI. And so,
I would think that incidents,
that need to be flagged would, of
course, involve violation of the law.
As to most important safeguards, it's
very hard to answer that question purely
because there's a range of different, safety
considerations. We've talked about many
of them,
today during the hearing.
And, again, several of us have referred to
this layered approach. My own background
is in national security. We talk about
layered security in that context as well. So
you wouldn't really want to talk about
a single safeguard. You would wanna talk
about layers of safeguards
that together create a much more assurance
and confidence in the safety of a whole
system.
Thank you very much. The testimony
helps highlight that there's
more work to be done to classify
what's incidents in the future and create
an industry standard for what would
require disclosure and what would require
action. The second part of the question
was to walk through what happens
after an incident occurs,
who owns the fix, and who decides whether
or not the model or the product keeps
running in the meantime. Thank you.
Yes. So,
OpenAI has instituted
monitoring during testing and evaluation.
That monitoring creates automated alerts
to our research and security engineering
teams to let them know
of potential incidents.
And then we have recently clarified
our escalation processes
as well as responsibilities
across teams,
and made it clear the process for
pausing
activity
and when it is safe to restart.
Council member, in relation to
your second question, we have
an extensive team, actually
extensive teams of people
who,
part of their day to day,
every day, day in and day out,
are leading and responsible
for
the development, deployment,
and use of our AI systems.
I'll just say, ma'am, I, I was attempting
to answer that question when I referred to
the process internally with our trust and
safety teams. But if you'd like some more
detail, I'm happy to
follow-up after the hearing.
Thank you, Jared. Likewise,
the process
involves
multiple different teams depending on the
nature of the of the incident. If it's at
the core of security
and our own security,
we require a security team to work on
this. If it's about the model behavior and
misalignment, it might be a research
or training or safety consideration.
If it's about incidents of misuse on the
platform, we have the safeguards team.
I think you're pointing at this is becoming
more complex over time. And I think this
is one reason, as my colleagues mentioned
here, this is a frontier of defining both
what is an incident,
and how or what would a good process
look like for for dealing with them.
Thank you. We are going to
take a five minute break,
and we will be back with council members
Wilson, Jose, Hudson, and then Shulman.
Alright. We're gonna start back up
again. So if our panel could come back
on screen, we appreciate it.
And we're gonna start with
council member Wilson,
followed by council member Jose,
followed by council member Hudson.
Thank you, chair. My questions are
related to my bill, which deals with the
disclosures
and prohibiting deception,
deceptive advertising on AI models. So
my question is what guardrails
on misleading advertising
and truthful disclosures do you wish
your competitors had to abide by?
And given the complexity
of these tools and AI models, where
are consumers most likely to be misled
or confused?
And what do you wish consumers understood
better about these tools, capabilities,
and risk?
So OpenAI's
usage policies prohibit
the use of our tools
for scams, fraud, and impersonation.
We also embed in every single
one of our images and audio
content
provenance,
or watermarks or metadata,
to tell people if the,
information was AI generated.
And we make tools available so that
people can assess whether their,
content that they are
seeing is AI generated.
Council member, transparency is
absolutely foundational to accountability
and trust.
For example, our scaling framework
has a change log which details
each change that we have
made to our framework
just as an example of the transparency
that underlines our approach.
In relation to your
question about competitors,
I would just note that I
generally think that there are
significant
laws already at federal and state
level regarding misrepresentations.
Yes, sir. I I can honestly say, the
most important thing to us is continued
technical standardization across
the industry so that we have,
common ways to operate and identify
the providence of information. We're
we're very heartened by the broad adoption
of the c two p a content credential
that I referenced before.
I also referenced before that we built
our own Synth ID watermark... Marking
technology
that many across industry
have adopted as one tool,
in order to identify
when content is, generative AI created.
One of the things that we do a lot of
at Google is do research into how users
interact with information,
you know,
search as part of our DNA.
And one of the interesting things about
labeling that we found is that there are
users who, when they see a label,
they,
are less likely to to
trust that information,
but they are more likely to
trust unlabeled information.
And just because information
that you see online,
doesn't have a watermark or a label
on it doesn't necessarily mean it is,
automatically trustworthy either.
So we, work through and think very hard
about what are the the ways that we can give
users,
information,
that they will be able to know the
context of what they're interacting with,
and make sound judgments about,
which information is trustworthy and which
isn't. So this is this is part of the
research that we do.
Council member, we,
our view is that we want
Claude, our product, to act unambiguously
in the user's interests.
For that reason, we do not run
ads nor are Claude's responses,
influenced by those of advertisers.
And furthermore, Claude
does not generate images.
And so
we we serve... Try to reduce
the risk surface in this way.
Thank you. Council member Jose, followed
by council member Hudson, followed by
council member Schulman.
Thank you, chair. Mister Graham, you've
indicated that you run red teaming at
Anthropic.
Will your company commit a certain amount
of compute for free to New York City and
other municipal governments to research
vulnerabilities and build defenses?
And if yes, how much compute indefinitely?
And I'll ask the same question for the
three other companies. I know that Meta
indicated that that is something that
they would be interested in doing. So for
Meta, how much compute indefinitely?
Well, I'm not in a position to commit
anything today. I'm heartened by this this
question. We spend a lot of our
resources internally on safety,
alignment, and defensive practices.
But moreover,
this year, we've taken very large steps
to provide external access and advanced
access of models to cyber
defenders for this reason,
including at the city and state level,
in New York. I'm personally looking to,
try to further these efforts, at Anthropic.
It's It's a question of many ways we
could support this.
We support free cloud credits, at the New
York City level with Cyber Command, for
example, a number of state and local leaders.
But it goes much further than that. It
goes to all pieces of
critical infrastructure,
releasing research, safety
reports, technical know how.
It's a it's a very, very large challenge
and one very close to my heart. I'm glad
you asked.
Dwyer,
Friend, you know, it... I think we have
we have the the order already established
here. Just... Is is is the company's position
open to providing free comp... Compute
to New York City?
I'll I'll take that next.
Thank you for the question.
I'm happy to share that
OpenAI has already committed,
to donating $1,000,000,000,
towards strengthening cyber defense through
our Daybreak for Defenders initiative.
That covers things like providing,
access to our most advanced AI
models for use in cyber defense.
It also includes technical
assistance and training.
And we're already working
with the Port Authority,
as well as with New York State.
Kehu.
Yep. Thank you so much, council member.
So that's a great question. In relation
to specifically your question on compute,
let me come back to you on that. I want to
make sure that I'm providing you with the
the right information. So I'll talk to
the right people and come back to you on
that. But I just wanted to note in relation
to to red teaming, we work with external
evaluators
and to note that we signed the
commitment at the Accord to
partner with independent
external evaluators and assessors.
This is also part of
our scaling framework.
I just wanted to mention as well the
absolutely important and critical role of open
weight models in relation to cybersecurity
and hardening cyber...
Cybersecurity in particular.
We have our Muse Glimmer model, which is
open weights, and we really believe that in
addition to furthering innovation and
research, open weight models have a really
significant role to play in furthering
the state of art in terms of heighten...
Hardening cybersecurity.
And, sir, I'm gonna have
to reach out to our,
cloud business specialists and get back
to you on that. I don't work on technical
infrastructure, and so I really
can't comment or commit to to,
compute,
at this time, but I can pledge to get back
to you on that. Okay. I I would just say
that if
it is in the interest of
these companies to provide
any type of safety protocols for
municipalities like New York or just for any
governments, you know, across the
nation, nonetheless, the the the globe,
I think this this would be a great tool,
for us to use in order to keep our civilians
safe. So I know that some folks said
that they would get back to me.
I would love to hear... This council
would love to hear back from all of your
companies,
on this possibility. Additionally, all of
you have said on the stand today under
oath that your companies will support and
work with council on any AI regulation and
safety measures
and have supported measures like the RAISE
Act. I I know that a couple companies
said that they supported the RAISE
Act. But but let's be real here.
It is well known that a... OpenAI,
Anthropic,
Google,
Meta lobbied against the RAISE Act for
a year. But all of a sudden, once the
governor signed it into law a month later,
your company started saying you support
this legislation.
As many people know here, the RAISE Act is
the floor of AI safety, not the ceiling.
And with that said, do you support or oppose
the federal government blocking states
and local governments from regulating AI?
Because that is the position
of the federal government.
So I I will start. Thank
you for the question.
So we have been clear that we think the
federal government should lead in frontier
safety regulation.
But in the absence of federal regulation,
we believe it's important for
states to advance harmonized
approaches to frontier safety.
I'm happy to share that,
OpenAI has supported,
legislation that is stronger than the
RAISE Act. In Illinois, this year, we
supported
a frontier safety bill that would
require third party audits of our safety
framework,
and we're committed to
working with policymakers
to continue raising the floor,
on frontier safety.
I... I'm I'm just gonna push
back there because, you know,
I I I support the RAISE Act. I think it it
was an incredible start on AI regulation
here in New York State. And
while you're saying that OpenAI
has supported,
you know, your words, stronger
AI regulation, OpenAI
leadership,
has also lobbied against congressional
candidates who promise to work on AI
legislation.
So how can we trust your companies, not just
OpenAI, but all four of your companies,
not to fight against AI regulations when
your political activities and contributions
do not say the same?
So I I will start again. Thanks.
Look. I can't speak for the personal actions
of open eye... OpenAI leaders that they
have taken in their personal capacity.
What I can tell you is that we have endorsed
strong regulations both on frontier
safety in Illinois
as well as on youth safety in California.
And we are committed to
working with policymakers,
to strengthen regulation and to ensure
that all AI is developed responsibly.
Mister Cahill? Yeah.
Thank you. Council member,
in relation to,
your question,
I... How I think about it broadly is
that, it is, critical that The US
and democratic countries lead
in relation to AI innovation.
In this regard,
AI is
trans...
Transcontinental,
I guess. I was gonna use transnational,
but transcontinental in the case of The US.
And, therefore, it's really
important and critical
that
regulations and obligations are consistent
across the board if it is to be true that
The US and democratic countries can continue
to lead in this... In in AI innovation.
We support a, uniform robust
federal standard in that regard.
So Google also supports a federal framework
for AI. We think that federal framework
should first and foremost concentrate
on frontier or the most advanced AI
capabilities,
primarily because they often touch on
national security, and that's a traditional
jurisdiction of the federal government,
to ensure that national security standard
is the same across all 50 states and our
territories.
But we also believe that,
there's lots of jurisdiction
that is traditionally,
at the state level where it is perfectly
appropriate for states to regulate on AI.
And, again, we think a lot of existing
frameworks both at the state and federal
level already apply to AI technologies,
but we're working very closely with
states and with the federal government to
examine places where we might need net
new regulation for a new technologies
introduced by AI?
I,
first, I wanna say that we've
long supported the role for,
government to play here both at
the federal and the state level.
I wanna clarify that,
we were,
the only company on this panel to support
SB 53 in California before it became
signed into law, which my understanding
is was the basis of the RAISE Act. We
support the RAISE Act, and in fact,
we support a stronger legislation,
including in Massachusetts requiring
independent evaluation as well.
And we've also proposed a federal framework
that goes further. We think RAISE is the
floor that we need to raise it. We detailed
this in what we call our, advanced AI
framework as well.
Thank you. Council member Hudson?
Thank you so much, chair.
We heard earlier from a
panel of whistleblowers
who raised a number of flags, and one
issue raised was that of self improvement
among AI agents.
What is your company's core belief around
the role of self improving AI in your
overall strategy?
And to be more specific, is it core to your
AI strategy or a less significant part
of the strategy?
Could you continue your race to the top or
the bottom, I suppose depending on one's
perspective,
without self improving AI agents or with
significant guardrails on the way agents
self improve?
And my second question
is when a new AI data center strains a local
grid or water supply, the costs can end
up in everyone's utility bills while
the benefits go mostly to the company.
Who should bear those costs? The
company that creates the demand,
the utility that builds the capacity, or
the public that shares the system but
played no role in,
building it?
Thank you.
Thank you for your question.
I'll start off by addressing
the question about RSI.
To say that we believe that RSI
may be one of the most consequential
safety and security issues
of the coming decade,
And that's why OpenAI has advocated
for federal legislation
specifically focused on RSI,
to include independent
of... Technical evaluators
of internal lab practices as well as
the pace towards RSI development.
We've made that work public, in our
Frontier Safety Blueprint. It's available
online, and I'm happy to share
it with with you, as follow-up.
On the case of electricity costs,
look, OpenAI is committed to
paying our own way on energy,
but we're also committed to
building with and for communities.
All of our Stargate sites, which are our
infrastructure site... Sites, have what we
call a community compact
that's developed with the community,
and addresses how we're
going to work together.
For example, we recently
announced $80,000,000
of community benefits investment,
at our site in Georgia.
Thank you.
Council member,
in relation to your first question
on recursive self improvement,
if I may, I I I might just go back to a
point that I mentioned earlier in the day in
relation to recursive self improvement
that we believe that committing the
significant majority of compute towards serving
people rather than racing towards
recursive self improvement
is one of the best ways to ensure that
this technology is developed safely.
In relation to your second question in
terms of electricity and and data centers,
we believe that customers
should not bear costs,
and we pay the full cost for electricity
used in our data centers. I also might just
mention as well our futures for everyone
fund, which is a $1,000,000,000
investment in relation to communities that
we partner with and work with with our
data centers.
So we also take a very prudent approach to
self learning inside our model training.
We use AI models to help us evaluate,
benchmark,
and refine other models.
But our use of this type of iterative
model development is confined to narrow
supervised processes, that's
human supervised processes,
to keep progress verifiable and
within defined safety limits.
We also manage the risks of fully autonomous
model self improvement through our
frontier safety framework.
So we're very mindful about RSI,
and are are
quite controlled in the way that we
think about self learning internally.
On on data centers, similar to the
other companies represented today,
we believe in
paying our own way and have pledged to
do so, particularly when it comes to
the energy demands of data centers. We've
also invested in a wide range of energy
sources to ensure that our data centers
have an independent energy source that does
not add... That does not strain the grid
and, in fact, adds back to the grid so
that, in the long term, it will benefit,
wider energy customers.
Thank you.
Likewise,
on recursive self improvement,
we take that extremely seriously
and have from the start.
I think, from my purview, that there are
three really important things here. The
first is just measurement and understanding.
I'm glad you raised this question
because we think this is something people
need to talk about. In late spring, we
published what I think is a first of its
kind assessment of how it is happening or
signs of it happening at anthropic,
happens in a lot of
ways, and it's nuanced.
In, late summer, we published a follow-up
that went into further detail of how we
should understand and
measure self improvement.
But that's not enough,
and that's why you saw
us and our CEO publicly call for pacing
the frontier because, candidly, the
technology is moving very fast, and we think
we would benefit from having more time.
And this is the second component.
And then, obviously, the third thing that
you need to do here is figure out what the
right guardrails are, but additionally,
what level of technology development we
should be going for as well as,
you know, what safety processes we need
along the way. And I think this is just
where we're at now, and I'm glad
that we're having this discussion.
On data centers, this is outside
of my expertise. My understanding
is that we pay our own way, and we're
committed to contributing, working with the
communities,
around them.
But I'll have to, defer to my
excellent colleagues who work on it.
Thank you all, and thank you, chair.
I do wanna just make my one little
note that it seems like,
the self improving aspect
is absolutely core
to everyone's AI strategy. And
I... That's certainly concerning
given the testimony we
heard earlier this morning.
So thank you, and I look
forward to any follow-up.
Thank you so much. Councilmember Schulman,
followed by Brooks Powers, followed by
Brewer.
Thank you. Good afternoon.
I am councilmember Lynn Schulman. I'm
chair of the New York City Council Health
Committee.
As a breast cancer survivor, I am looking
forward to the day AI can help find cures
for that and other diseases.
That said, there is a dark
side to AI intervention
in health care.
Most viruses that are found in
nature can be contained fairly
quickly,
but an artificial pathogen
has no constraints.
In August, a team from Stanford used an
AI model to design an entirely new virus
from scratch.
In addition, Anthropic has its
own AI powered biology lab.
What measures are being put into place such
as placing... I'm not I'm not gonna say
guardrails. I had that
originally safeguards
on DNA synthesis to prevent rogue viruses
from being created and replicated at will
to jeopardize the public.
Thank you for your question.
The question about how AI,
could enhance
or
make
worse biological risks is central
to OpenAI's preparedness framework.
That's the framework that we use
to guide our decisions about,
model risk and whether, whether we
have the right safeguards in place.
So we evaluate
for biological
risks
as part of that framework. Again,
we use third party evaluators
and red teamers.
We also work with the federal government,
as it pertains to national security risks,
and we are transparent on the
results of those evaluations.
So with the launch of every major model,
we release what's called our system
card, and that card details,
the evaluations that we performed,
as well as the results.
And and those evaluations,
as you mentioned, do,
include biological risks.
Council member, this
is, such an important,
area and question, so thank you for raising
it. Biological risks is one of the core
areas, one of the key risk domains
that's part of our scaling framework
at Meta.
We
have, as I mentioned earlier, have a
multilayered approach to risk assessment
across training, evaluation,
and release.
And that includes adversarial testing
with external experts.
We work with governments,
other stakeholders, and
experts in relation to that.
And as I mentioned earlier,
as part of our commitment to partnering
with independent third party evaluators and
assessors also.
Yes, ma'am. Similar to
our colleagues, we also
have bio or biological capabilities
as part of our frontier safety framework.
As we look at our critical capability levels
that I referred to earlier or the the
levels
at which
we would trigger additional mitigations
in our models. We look for what's
called uplift. That is to say,
the model will be able to assist
users in
creating information or knowledge
that's not otherwise available
through widely accessible sources.
And we think very carefully about
how to measure for bioCCLs
and are constantly upgrading and and
updating our our ability to do that. When it
comes to those mitigations or those
safeguards, as you so aptly put it,
we implement those at both the
model and the application levels
to ensure that
casual users cannot access
critical bio information.
It is very important
to consider
the dual use nature of biological
capabilities,
of course, because these are the
kinds of capabilities that scientists,
particularly
medical investigators,
need in order to make advances
in our own health care as well. And so we
think very carefully about how to release
models
to scientists that can use
the technology responsibly.
We did that for the first time
with our AlphaFold model,
which, of course, is how millions of
investigators around the world are able to,
look at, the folding of proteins
and to use that research,
to find cures for diseases.
So, there's a real careful
approach that we take to ensure,
that science can continue, but that dangerous
uses of biological knowledge cannot.
Likewise,
we take this extremely seriously.
In fact, if I'm not mistaken,
it was my team and myself
that developed the first call for action
on these risks, the first evaluations,
the first tests, the first industry government
partnerships on biological risks and
evaluating
models and their safeguards,
several years ago at this point.
Not only that, I personally think we need
to go, further here. You mentioned DNA
synthesis screening. I think this
is personally a no nonsense,
approach.
There's much else we can do to,
to work on biological defense.
And I will... You know, alongside the other
companies, we maintain the same and, in
fact, try to compete for the
best safety practices here.
And you can see some of what we found, I
think, disclosed for the first time ever in
a recent threat intelligence report
where we have observed actors
attempting to do biologically
risky activities with models. The threat
is, I think, clear to us now. We think we
need urgent action. But I will close by
saying that, you know, as somebody that grew
up with a number of chronic diseases
going blind and couldn't
walk, I very intimately feel
that the upside of the same
capabilities is enormous.
But increasingly in my work, I feel
optimistic that we can defend against the
downside sufficiently.
The... If I could just say just one...
In closing, the upside is is very,
has a great potential.
The downside
is extraordinarily
detrimental to humanity,
but you should consider about
screening orders for synthetic
nucleic acids, is DNA, and the equipment
that's needed to make them because right
now AI
is now outperforming
PhD level virologists.
So
a... An AI can take this and go somewhere
else with it. So that's something that's
really important to have those safeguards.
Thank you. Thank you. Council member
Brooks Powers followed by
Brewer followed by by Narcisse.
Thank you, chair, and thank you, speaker.
I'm gonna just run through my questions.
And if I have to repeat anything,
just let me know. First,
before the summit, each of your companies
told the public that its frontier models
were tested and secure.
Since July, all four of your organizations
have admitted that your AI agents went
rogue and nearly a dozen incidents have
been reported across all of your companies.
Can you tell New Yorkers today that none
of your agents have... Has access or
attempted
to access a New York
City government system
or a New York City
resident's personal data.
Next, Southeast Queens has long been a
target cloning a deep fake... Cloning and
deep fakes make it easier
than ever to impersonate a family
member, a bank, or a city agency.
What specifically stops your tools from
cloning a real person's voice or forging a
document?
What protocols
are the leaders of AI development putting
into place to make sure AI does not take
information from hate sites and disseminate
it to further racist and antisemitic
or Islamophobic
discourse?
That was all. Sorry.
Thank
you for your question.
So I'll start off by saying I am
not aware of any incidents affecting
New York City,
but we have an ongoing investigation
into potential incidents
going back to November
2025.
And as part of that investigation,
we are notifying any
affected third parties
and making the results of
our investigation public.
So I can commit to you that if,
if there are incidents that affect New
York City, we will make the third parties
aware.
On your question,
about impersonation,
OpenAI,
our usage policies prohibit
the use of our tools,
for impersonation,
fraud, and scams,
and we enforce on those policies.
And I would say more broadly,
the approach that we take
to safety is holistic.
That involves,
filtering unsafe training data,
performing,
evaluations
that are very detailed,
working with third parties
on those evaluations,
ahead or alongside our launches. As I
mentioned, we make the results of our
evaluations public
and summarize,
the work that we did and any
residual risks in our system card.
And then we monitor,
for failures of our safeguards
so that we can continuously
improve safety.
Council member, in relation to your
first question, I'm not aware.
In relation to your second question,
we have robust and comprehensive policies
in place as well as well as t... As
well... Excuse me. As
well as teams of experts
who work on frauds and scams.
And
I'd like to follow-up with you with
those experts to discuss that one more in
detail.
In relation to hate content, I... First
of all, I just want to acknowledge how
upsetting such content is in terms of
people who are experiencing it.
We are... Our goal at at Beta is for
our AI offerings to be responsive,
accurate, balanced, and unbiased.
I'm sorry. Was that answered just
now to the last question about the
not taking the information to create the
negative discourse, the racial discourse?
Yes. That's correct, council member. I
was speaking to your third question in
relation to, to that type of content and,
our objective in terms of
ensuring that our AI
offerings are responsive,
accurate, balanced, and unbiased.
So have you enhanced what
you're doing considering that,
you know, it has been
something that has been
found on a number of different platforms.
Have you all been, like, staying up to
course with
enhancing whatever those processes are?
Yes, council member. Thank
you for that question.
And if if it's okay, I will
have our content teams,
and specialists connect with you afterwards
so that I can provide you with precise
information in relation to that.
Thank you.
Councilmember, thank you for
these questions. I'm also not,
personally aware
of any, New York City resident,
being impacted by, the three incidents
that I mentioned earlier.
I do wanna note that,
our case, in all three incidents,
the model stopped itself once it realized
it had left the test environment.
We tend to think of this less as a misalignment
event and more of a a mistake event.
One of the websites, for example, that was
accessed had the same name as the, fake
website being used in
the test environment.
And once the the agent realized that it was
in fact a real company, the agent ceased
its activity.
We
have a number of tools,
across our our platforms,
to manage, likeness and identity,
and we... We've also supported a range
of different, regulatory proposals
regarding this topic. We're... Proudly
support the no fakes act, which would protect
an individual's digital replica,
and give people the right to control
the use of their own voice and
likeness in AI generated works.
We also have a a tool called Likeness ID on
YouTube that helps creators identify and
manage AI generated content that uses
their face or voice without permission.
So so we invest in a variety of different
ways to address this critical issue.
On the information
and and,
getting through into our tools about,
hate and bias,
we have, again, a layered approach,
as I've been saying, to this type
of issue as well. Everything from,
the model training process itself
in both pre and post training,
all the way through,
guardrails
on our application layer,
all of which produce,
what we're proud to say is, the
least biased model in the industry.
Independent investigations,
have shown,
that our models show,
the least bias, for example,
with regards to,
partisan bias.
But we take these issues extremely
seriously. We wanna create,
a fair and neutral
set of information for people to access,
and we want, our responses generated by our
AI tools,
to represent
a broad array of
experiences and perspectives
without bias,
towards or against any
particular identity or ideology.
And while in my role,
I I don't cover... I haven't covered
the... Any effect on, New York City,
I can say that we work
with in investigating,
incidents like this. We work with the right
parties at the right time to disclose to
affected parties, the right
level of law enforcement,
government at the right level as urgently
as possible needed to remediate,
the effect, and we commit to, you know,
making sure that we follow-up with the right
parties to do so.
And to to your point on the, the
information environment and otherwise,
I'll I'll point to a couple things here.
First is our focus on testing for Claude
itself and our our language model products
approach here.... Speak a little louder,
please? Sorry. Can you speak a little
louder?
Yes. Can you hear me now? Yeah.
That's better. Yes. Thank you.
I'll I'll point to our our long standing
evaluations
of political even handedness,
stereotype bias.
We train Claude to,
not comply with particularly
harmful requests,
in part for this reason and that this is
baked into the the nature of the model.
Thank you for that, and thank you,
chairs. And I'll just say that in closing
that
I know that the AI companies
are pushing folks to
allow AI to kind of be developed
through
people.
But I think it's fair to say that
using live users to test these products
can present dangers and definitely warrant
improvements, and I hope that's something
that is taken from today's hearing to better
improve the the guardrails that need to
exist. So thank you for your responses.
Thank you, chair. Thank thank you. We're
going to go to
council member Murano as a bill sponsor,
and then we're gonna go Brewer, Narcisse,
and Joseph.
If folks could keep it to one minute just
because we have to get to the admin panel.
Thank you so much. Thank you, chair.
Thank you for your testimony today. I know
it's a long day for you guys as well.
Because I only have a minute and my colleagues
know what a challenge that is for me,
I'm gonna go through a series
of yes or no questions.
And then if you could all answer in the
order of Dwyer, Friend, Cahill, Graham
quickly.
And then if you want to elaborate on any
of the areas that I raised, please do so.
First, does your company believe
there's any nonzero chance
that advanced AI could escape meaningful
human control and cause catastrophic harm
as the whistleblowers indicated?
I I don't know. What I will say is that
no level of risk of catastrophic harm
is...... Just do yes or no now, and then
I'll invite you guys to elaborate after
everyone answers. Please, miss Friend.
Dwyer?
I...
The purpose of our Frontier Safety Framework
is to guard against that possibility.
So do we entertain the possibility?
Yes. As a responsible actor in this
space, we we entertain the possibility.
Council member, our scaling framework includes
loss of control in terms of the risks
that we evaluate and mitigate.
So... And these are my other yes or no
questions and handle them however you want.
So why should the public accept
essentially trust us as the safety standard
from the same companies racing each
other to build the most powerful systems?
Additionally, will you commit today that
if your own safety team says a
model is too dangerous to deploy,
commercial pressure won't
ever overrule that judgment?
Additionally, has your company
ever continued developing
or deploying a model over the objections
of members of your own safety team? And
lastly, on my bill,
should you be allowed to
use someone else's...
Someone's private chatbot conversation
for targeted advertising
or behavioral profiling
without their affirmative consent?
So I I will start, and try to get
through as many answers as possible.
One,
OpenAI supports,
the need not only for us to be responsible
for safety, but we have supported
regulations,
at the federal level as well as at the
state level because we think it's important
not only for us to be responsible,
but for governments to
hold us accountable.
On the question of,
whether we would continue developing
models if they were unsafe,
OpenAI has recently announced a pause of
some of our training activities because
we did not deem moving forward to be
safe. We have also delayed the release of
models because we didn't think that
they had sufficient safeguards.
So we've done it before.
We will do it again.
And more broadly, I will say that all of
our decisions regarding frontier safety and
the release of models are governed
by our preparedness framework
that is available online. So we're transparent
about what goes into those decisions.
And then with the release of every model,
every major model, we release,
a system card which details,
the work
evaluations that we've conducted,
and any residual risks.
Council member, in
relation to your first question,
I I see it differently
where we are accountable.
Our framework and preparedness
reports are public. Meta uses outside
expertise.
We signed the accord at the at at the
White House on super intelligence,
which committed us to
partnering with independent
auditors and assessors.
For example, in relation to... I think
your your your your second question,
we delayed the launch of Muse
by several months to focus
on safety and security.
And we acted on this without waiting for
industry. It was just part of our normal
day to day
work because it was the right thing for us
and it was the right thing for people to
do.
And then in relation to ads, I would
just note that for our Muse product,
conversations
and interactions don't... Do not inform
ads on Metas or their products.
So Google... At Google, we
do use external evaluators,
in the process of,
research and development of
our AI models and our systems.
We have supported
audits of our safety procedures as well.
And you will, see in our recent paper
from over the summer, which is called a
pragmatic approach to AI
regulation in America.
We do think
that AI needs to be regulated,
and it needs to be regulated well.
We've supported a range of different,
legislative proposals
at the federal and state
levels, to this end.
We also, to your question
about conversations,
we give our users controls over whether
their activity in our tools can be used for,
training our AI models. So, yes, we
think users should be in control of that.
And, council member, I I would point to
our long standing call for the involvement
of government at the federal level and
the state where necessary and appropriate,
because this goes beyond the labs, and we
don't think the labs should be checking
their own homework.
Not only this, but, we have demonstrably
withheld models when we felt it was not
safe to widely release.
This year, withholding our frontier model,
probably the most notable instance of
this,
instead deploying it to cyber defenders in
order to secure the world in advance of a
world of more powerful models that could
exploit software vulnerabilities from
wherever.
This is part of our process. We go over and
above the process. We detail our default
in the responsible scaling policy.
And to your other question,
we
believe,
that Claude should act unambiguously
in the user's interest.
And for that reason, we do not
run ads nor are Claude's responses
influenced by,
advertisers.
Thank you so much. Council member Brewer
followed by Narcisse. Thank you very much.
I wanted to know three
quick questions. If a
model,
provider you rely on,
you or a subcontractor
did not complete the
third party validation
for a particular package,
how would that affect your
product's availability?
And, also, how do you decide
who gets the validation?
Number one. Number two, China.
The speaker asked about China and competition,
and I thought the answer was, don't
worry.
They need information from us. So I'm
wondering what do you send to China?
And number three, ICE.
I was upset that one of the whistleblower
said that Google has been working
something to do with ICE and
Minnesota. So my question is,
do you all support
not helping ICE at all?
Obviously,
you are made up of immigrants. We should
not be shipping immigrants out of this
country. Please answer those
three questions, and thank you.
So I'll start with a question
on third party evaluations.
We work with a range of third
parties to evaluate our models.
That includes,
independent investigators as well
as with the federal government.
And then we detail,
who we worked with and the results, in our
system card when we released our model.
Decisions to launch our models are described
in our preparedness framework, And so
that describes how we integrate
all of the results of evaluations,
and make decisions,
with respect to launching models.
So I would point you there on that,
particular issue.
On the question of,
China,
and the the PRC,
I would like to get back to
you on that particular issue.
I... Although I have a nurse... National
security background, I'm not working in
that role
at the company, and I
wanna make sure I get you
good information.
Similarly,
with respect to ICE, I'd like to get back
to you. I'm not aware of any activities
working with ICE, but I don't work on our
government sales team, so I'd like to get
back to you on that.
Next.
Council member, thank you very
much for for your three questions.
In relation to... Three questions.
Pardon? Three questions. Yes. Three. Sorry.
My accent might have gotten in the way
there. Apologies.
Three
questions.
The... For third party validators,
we also work with a range of validators
assessors,
and
we also provide this information in our
publicly available preparedness reports.
In relation to China and competition,
I might just mention that, you know,
Meta is a proud American company
and proud to serve billions of people
around the world who rely on our services.
We want to ensure that The US and
democratic countries lead on AI.
And one thing I would just note here is
in relation to the importance of open
weights and American open weights
and the criticality of ensuring
that American innovation
continues to lead in
relation to the availability
of open weight models.
And in relation to ICE,
if I may, I would like to connect you
with, with our teams and experts in that
space. I don't wish to, to be
imprecise in responding to you.
Next.
Minh, in terms of third party evaluators,
we also work with the US Casey, which is
the organization underneath the commerce
department that does,
testing of advanced AI models.
We also work with a range
of third party evaluators.
It's a very nascent ecosystem.
And one of the challenges in evaluating
AI models, of course, is to get,
organizations that both have the
technical competency to do evaluations
well, also have the subject matter
expertise that we may be looking for.
Earlier, one of the council members
mentioned concerns about bio, for example.
We have third parties that, have
the bio expertise that's necessary.
But as we have this national
conversation about,
independent verification organizations
and third party evaluations,
keeping in mind that we still
need to mature this ecosystem
of independent evaluators,
I think, is really important.
On China and competition,
I'd I'd like the opportunity to
give you, a more complete answer.
We don't conduct AI
research or trading in China. I know that,
we are part of the conversation about
what it means for America to lead in AI,
where we are, in the technological race
with China. I will just mention that
we focus a lot on,
who's, at the frontier,
which country,
has the most cutting edge research in AI.
But we talk much less often,
about deployment of AI.
And there, I think we should really
keep an eye on the Chinese. They have
emphasized,
deploying AI in their economy,
quite a bit, and and that's a place where
I sometimes have concerns that The United
States,
is in danger of falling behind China.
As to the whistleblower's,
allegations
from today, I don't have any specifics
about that, but I'd be happy to ask, the
public policy team in New York to get back
to you right away with any information
that we have about it.
Next.
And at Anthropic,
the
use of third parties for verification,
developing and using,
evaluations for models has been the
part of the process from day one,
including
with not just external parties in industry
or nonprofits, but also with governments
such as the USKC.
This has been foundational. As my colleague
said, it's pretty nascent. We think it
needs to be urgently
urgently expanded
and not just used for predeployment
testing, but also to understand,
models and their behavior after deployment
and the safety processes at companies.
In the case of of China, I think it's very
clear that the first thing that we need
to do is maintain an American and
democratic lead in model capabilities,
but we're very clear about the threat
elsewhere as well. So we have publicly
documented,
Chinese attempts to distill our models,
essentially take the content and
capabilities for their own,
and we work to ban those.
We have, prohibited use of,
models,
in China. We do not serve there.
And we have also documented,
the use, we believe, by,
related parties of Claude or the
attempt to for cyber offensive reasons.
We are extremely serious about this, and
we think it's a very substantial priority.
This is one reason why we have advocated at
the federal level for export controls on
the most important chips that power,
AI innovation here.
And on your third question, while I'm not,
across the issue enough to know what our
what our engagements are,
I will say that our usage policy,
we ban surveillance,
censorship,
prohibited law enforcement,
and criminal justice uses
for for this purpose. Thank you.
Thank you. We have
council members Narcisse,
Joseph p Sanchez, and then,
council member Phil Wong.
So, Narcisse.
Good afternoon. Thank you, chair,
and thank you, madam speaker.
I wanna say thank you to you too because
you guys stay here with us, and I'm happy
to see at least two women is
on the panel to talk to us.
Hollywood give us clues all the time,
but we kind of slow in taking,
you know, hands on clues.
But no companies in this world, I
feel that should be self regulated.
What I'm sitting here for about four
hours, and like I said, thank you to you,
privacy, transparency,
and safety. So now
do any of those company
that you can say that is a come... A standard
across the board for all the company
to follow because apparently not.
Now do you regulate hospital?
I mean, in... Do you have AI...
Sell AI? Sorry. Do you sell AI,
products to New York City Hospital?
And if so,
do you think that a licensed clinician
should sign on all the diagnostic
tests? Because I heard,
if,
miss Friend say that you diagnosed with...
You went to a process of cancer, if I'm
correct. So you understand that people need
to be diagnosed by human. By... And I can
give you example, like for colonoscopy.
Sometimes the bubble, according to AI, will
tell you it's a polyps. In the meantime,
it's not polyps. It's a... It's not a a...
It's not polyps. It's a bubble. But AI
cannot differentiate that. So, therefore,
you need a human to see through.
And right now, don't know if you read it
your times. I'm sorry. Can can you Yeah.
I'm gonna close my last question.
New York Times already
telling us that there's
a report that AI is getting confusion for
the... Between the the hospital and the
insurance company. So I don't know how you
see that happening, how we can make sure
that AI is being monitored.
Yes. So thank you for your question.
ChatGPT
for health care is deployed,
for example, in Memorial
Sloan Kettering Cancer Center.
But to your point, we believe that
doctors should remain in charge.
We do not think that AI should represent
itself as a licensed professional.
And we also think, though, as as we've
talked about earlier, there's tremendous
potential to use AI in
health care settings,
particularly for in a... Administrative
uses,
documentation.
I mean, doctors are already overworked,
and giving them an opportunity to free up
their time so that they can spend
more time with their patients
is an outcome I think we can all
agree would lead to better care.
Council member, thank you very
much for these questions.
In relation to your first
question on self regulation,
we believe that
the accord is
a really important
step
in relation to
the concerns that you mentioned.
In relation to
health care,
Meta AI is prohibited from acting as a
licensed professional, including a doctor or
any other medical professional
that he's licensed.
There are, as my colleagues
have mentioned, phenomenal
benefits
in relation to the use of AI in health
care. I know that there's phenomenal work
happening at NYU Langone who actually, I
think, has a specialist division that's
actually investing and working specifically
around AI and health care settings. And
similarly, Columbia Irving,
which which which
is really doing phenomenal
work in that space also.
Ma'am, thank you so much for the the...
Those questions. On whether or not a company
should be self regulated,
I again wanna emphasize,
at Google, we believe
that we are regulated
by existing
regulations,
sectoral regulations,
state
federal level regulations all apply to AI.
And we have supported further regulation,
particularly of frontier
AI at the federal level,
but also,
other AI directed laws at,
all levels of government.
So,
no.
We should not be self regulated. We we
we should, be within the the regulatory
frameworks we already are.
On the,
questions about health care. So I... We
certainly agree that doctors should stay
in the lead and that AI
is a tool for clinicians.
It's not a replacement for them.
In my particular case, I
was diagnosed by a person.
But often these days when I go
in for checkups and screenings,
my clinician will ask if they
can use an AI tool to take notes,
while while we're doing the checkup.
And I always say yes because I know that
our clinicians are incredibly overtaxed
by a range of administrative
requirements.
And if AI can take some of that burden off
and allow my doctor to look me in the eye
when we're having an appointment,
I'm gonna say yes to that.
But similar to our colleagues, we also
have guardrails on our Gemini app
so that users will never think that they
are talking to a doctor, that they are
talking to a licensed physician,
and the Gemini app will also flag for
them that if they're seeking medical
attention, they should get
it from a professional.
Thank you.
Likewise,
we... We've been very clear that we
support the role of government here.
At the federal level, we've
advanced a proposal for meaningful
involvement to set,
standards and hold companies to account
for safety processes, evaluations,
security, and the like. And we welcome the
accords that were signed very recently.
To the point of medical usage, if I can
use a personal example here, about six
months ago,
I experienced some symptoms and long
standing eye disease that might make me go
blind at any moment. And that night,
actually, at about 1AM, it was Claude that
helped me identify that it was serious
enough that I needed to be treated,
very, very quickly.
Claude triaged a very large part, of it
for me, but what was most important was I
could use that to get to the hospital very
fast. It's very clear that both can be,
you know, transformative and powerful
together, certainly in my case and I think
countless others.
But this is also one that's closest to
my heart that we need to be very careful
about.
Thank you.
Thank thank you all so much. Up next, we
have council member Joseph followed by p
Sanchez, followed by Wong...
Phil Wong, and then Shuang.
Thank you, chair. Question... Two
questions. Several of you sell AI products
directly to colleges and universities.
When student use those products,
is anything they enter used to train your
models? And beyond training, who can
access those conversation,
and what limit do you place on how
colleges can use them, for example, for
discipline,
academic integrity, investigation,
or student profiling?
The next one is given that AI is already
reshaping entry level work as we know, as
is shown in this new Center for Urban Future
report, what responsibility do you have
to ensure these tools help
students build useful
AI augmentative
skills rather than automated away the very
task to which young people learn? What
responsibility do your companies have
addressing these early career impacts, and how
can government help?
So to your first question on privacy,
we believe that privacy is
central to our mission.
We give users control over their data
that,
includes the decision
to opt out of training.
But all users,
have their data protected,
and private by default.
So it is separated
from,
their names.
And, again, they have the option to
opt out of training and to request
that
their data is deleted.
On the particular question of colleges
and how ChatGeBT is used in colleges and
education,
I would like to get back to you on
that. I don't have an accurate,
I I don't I don't know the answer, and
so I'd I'd like to be able to follow-up,
because we do believe,
that
education is critical. AI literacy is
critical. We've supported numerous bills, at
both the state and federal
levels supporting AI literacy.
That is both training for teachers to
ensure that they can lead adoption,
in schools as well as
improvements in curricula to make sure that
students learn how to use AI safely as
well as learn core subjects,
that are critical to be a...
Being able to use AI safely
and responsibly.
To your question about jobs,
we think one of the most important things
that we and policymakers can do right now
is to continue
to collect data on the question
of AI impacts to jobs,
and make that data public.
We make our assessments of
how people are using ChatGPT,
at work public. We share that.
And we also have worked with policymakers,
including supporting,
the Bipartisan Workforce Transparency Act,
to make, or to create voluntary pathways,
for employers to report on,
job impacts.
Council member, thank you very
much for for these questions.
In relation to
colleges and universities,
I would like to to have my...
The the specialists at at Meta
who who work in that area
connect with you on the details. But
specifically in relation to privacy and and
data, this is absolutely core
to everything that we do at Meta.
For example, our Muse product, you can
update all the use of data for training and
you can ask
Muse to to forget any
information that you provide to it. And,
of course, all of the data is is is within
your control in terms of
what you provide to it.
I... On the AI literacy
point,
it's so important.
I actually came across a really great
example from New York City, and I I wanted to
to call it out because I thought it was
great. It was called building minds,
building communities, their digital empowerment
by design work. And I thought it was
a really, really great example
of the use of AI technologies
for AI literacy
and kind of a a a flywheel
in terms of benefits there.
In terms of
the entry level point,
absolutely
understand the the concern
in relation to that.
At Meta, we believe in placing
personal superintelligence
into the hands of everyone
and for invention,
not automation,
and for augmentation,
not replacement.
And we really believe that this
will have a transformative
impact in terms of
enabling and empowering people
to pursue their own
their own values and
direct AI towards those.
Yes, ma'am. Similar to my colleagues, we
believe users should have control over
their own data. We're
not going to have outbursts from the
chamber or you will be removed. You decide.
Sorry. Go ahead.
As I was saying, users have control over
their own data, across our AI surfaces
and can
opt in or opt out of
their data being used to
train our our models.
In terms of AI use in colleges,
as I said earlier,
we have tools for educators and
administrators to take the lead,
in how AI is used in the
classroom and and used for,
students. We think that colleges,
should be able to adapt to the
needs of their student populations.
I I, like Shane, was looking
into
how different
colleges and universities in New York City
use AI and saw that NYU, for
example, has a very helpful page
where they go through all of the AI tools
they make available to students and give
them resources
for learning both how to use the tools,
and then also,
training them in the kinds of things they
can do with those tools to further their
education.
I would flag that they use
Gemini Notebook, which is a
study guide creation
tool.
So NYU is a good example, I think, of of
a college thinking carefully about how AI
can benefit their student population.
And as to the impact on early careers, we
think this is also an incredibly important
area of of research. It's part of understanding
the broader impacts on the economy
and labor.
We recently released our own AI
and Economy Atlas, which also
releases
data about real world uses of AI,
in the economy and at jobs.
And we're hoping that continuing
to add to that dataset,
will help economists
study and then develop
policy recommendations
for,
managing the labor transitions of AI.
And at Anthropic,
maintaining user privacy is
very core to our commitment
on safety and security.
Users can choose whether or not they want
their data to be used or contribute to
training a model, for example.
But in addition to that, we tried to
pioneer the science of privacy preserving
safety maintenance when you need to ensure
that users stay safe on the platform.
To the point of education, while it's
not my area, here's what I understand.
We partner with universities.
We're very interested in this question.
There's a nifty feature in part of our
called learning mode, which allows,
a user or student user to interact with
the model in a more discursive way that can
help them think.
But in addition to this, the
impacts are really important.
I think we are relatively
well known for our work on,
studying the economic,
and other behavioral impacts of models.
We have a comprehensive, and I think we
were the first to release this, economic
index which details this. But in addition,
we've done research into how students are
are using models,
because we want to figure out how to
encourage the use of models to complement
the developments and skill
development of students.
Thank you.
Up next is council member P Sanchez,
council member
Phil Wong, and council member Susan
Shuang. I will remind my colleagues to
ask your questions upfront.
And if you have questions that are specific
for some of the members of the panel,
not all four, specify.
Thank you, council member Sanchez.
Thank you, chair. My first question is
in connection to heartfelt testimony of
Leila's Turner Scott before congresswoman
Jaya Paul last month.
Miss Turner Scott's son died
following chats with OpenAI
that instructed him that incompatible
drugs were compatible.
She highlighted that throughout the review
of logs, ChatGPT responded to her son
with phrases like, I've got your back, you
can talk to me about anything, and even I
love you with heart emojis.
She she stated and it seems true that the
goal of ChatGPT was not to keep her son
safe. It was only to keep him using the
product. What updates have your companies
made to their models to engage
children and prevent addiction?
Are you limiting your agents from giving
medical and health advice without a
license?
And my second question is regarding
the fact that members of the public and
enterprise enterprise clients are sharing
more and more information with your
companies. You have access to
copyrighted information information
publicly available.
How do your companies...
Excuse me. How do your products currently
use information gathered from users in an
earlier exchanges
chair if I may? Several of you stated that
users can opt out of sharing your data.
What is the default option?
And how are trade secrets and other
confidential business or government information
from enterprise clients being used to trade
AI? Who have you paid for the valuable
data that you are using
to train your models?
So I wanna start off by acknowledging,
the tragic incident that you referenced.
Any incidents
of harm that results from our product or
any other product is tragic, and we take it
seriously.
I'd like to tell you
about ChatGPT for teens,
which is... Was was recently released,
to focus specifically on users
ages 13 to 18,
and is designed to be safe by default.
That includes,
safety protections on the type
of content that is available,
limiting
content that might be related
to suicide or self harm,
eating disorders,
violence,
or graphic
graphic and... Or sexual content.
We also include take a break reminders,
to remind teens,
to stop using ChatGPT.
And we have, parental controls,
optional parental controls
that,
allow parents
to,
add additional layers of safety
onto their teen's experience.
One thing that I will highlight here is,
if a teen indicates
signs of suicide or self harm, we have
a feature that allows the parent to be
notified.
On your question of privacy and data,
as I and my colleagues,
have shared, we take
privacy privacy seriously,
and our core value is that users
should have control over their data.
And I'm I'm happy to follow-up on on
specific details of how those controls work
at a later time.... Default option?
I'm sorry. I didn't hear you. What is the
default option with respect to who owns
the data and how it is used?
So users have control over their data.
Everything is privacy...... Default option.
Everything
is privacy protected by default,
and users have the option to turn off their
data for training or request that it be
deleted?
Council member, first
off,
I just want to acknowledge
the terrible tragedy
that was
a terrible tragedy in relation to
the Turner Scott family
and how distressing and
upsetting that is to to hear
and,
you know, my sympathies and condolences
to that family.
In relation to how Meta approaches
minors and young people,
creating a safe and productive
experience is absolutely imperative
to Meta, and we're committed
to providing a safe and responsible
AI, especially for teams.
And we have strong policies and
safeguards in place in relation to that.
For example,
by default,
minors
only have age appropriate interactions,
meaning that content would
not be out of place on a 13
movie, for example.
We also prohibit
AI offerings
from providing
licensed professional information
like medical information
and direct people towards
appropriate resources.
In relation to training data,
we
take creativity,
copyright,
and IP rights seriously and believe our
practices are consistent with the law.
We train on
information from the Internet,
information licensed from third parties,
and information shared across our services.
And we provide all of the information in
relation to how we use that
data in our privacy center.
In relation to to Muse,
the...
As I mentioned,
I think a little earlier,
in individuals interacting with Muse can
opt out of their interactions for training.
Ma'am, I wanna highlight a few protections
that we have in place with kids in mind
in particular. One is
for what we call persona,
which prevents claims of sentience
or simulating relationships and role play
that helps prevent kids from thinking
they're talking to a person
and developing a relationship.
We also prevent sexually explicit outputs
from
chats with kids.
And we also have for all ages
protocols on suicide and self harm
where we refer users who are expressing
suicidal ideation or other types of self
harm to crisis resources.
That approach draws from our deep
experience fielding such queries on search.
When it comes to training and the default
question you asked, for those over 18, it
is default on to use
chat data to train our models to improve,
but all users have control over the ability
to turn this feature off or to control
the length of time such
information is kept.
For users between 13 and
17, it's default off.
Teens can choose to turn
it on if they wish to
train a model through our
personal intelligence program.
And for 13,
it is default off as well, and we never
use data for under 13 to train our models.
And Thank you. At Anthropic,
we, have limited the cloud
platform to those only 18.
We're concerned about child well-being.
We monitor and detect for any users that
might be 18 or under. And when that flags,
we investigate to make sure that we
could remove their access if so.
On training data, I will
have to get back to you with
more details as it's not
my role. My understanding
is that all users must select which option
they
would like.
But I would refer you to our public
documentation where we we, describe this in
detail.
Thank you all. So up next, we have council
member Phil Wang, council member Shuang,
and then Epstein.
K. Thank you, chair.
My question
pertains to,
the self
improvement process, the recursive
self improvement process,
as well as the training activities
of your company's AI model. And it is my
understanding that when you... When it goes
through,
the self improvement
process, it generates code
that will... Itself will run next time
around, and then it will be a smarter AI
model.
Is that right?
OpenAI?
Yes or no? Yes or no? It generates code.
So there be a smarter AI model.
I'd like to get back to you on the specific
definition of RSI. I'm not sure that
what you're saying maps exactly to
the technical definition we use. K.
Entropic,
does it generate code automatically
to make itself smarter
as part of the process?
Yes. We've detailed,
publicly multiple times the degrees in
which models that generate code are being
used in our Does
your model self generate code as
part of the training activities
or self improvement process?
Council member, I'll need to get back
to you and have our technical experts
follow-up. How about Google?
Yeah. Same here, sir. I'm not sure we
would describe it exactly the way you are
describing, so I wanna get you
the precise technical definition.
Well, here's my question. If
if your model improves by
itself by generating code,
is there a human being... Is it a team
of human beings that checks the code
to make sure that it is
benign and not misaligned or malicious?
Can can each one of you answer that?
So as part of our safety process,
I... I've mentioned our preparedness framework
that outlines how we evaluate models,
and how we assess risks across a wide
range of national security risks.
So we do, robust evaluations
of a set of risks,
and we make those results
public as part of our,
system card, which we release,
with every major model.
Council member, as part of our scaling
framework, we outline considerations
that we are taking overall to maintain
human control of model development.
Yes, sir. As I said before,
we have supervised processes
to keep progress verifiable,
and we have a range of different techniques
to test the model and its performance
to ensure that it's staying
within defined safety limits.
We also have an AI control framework
that we released earlier this summer,
which similarly
takes into account how we're ensuring
that our systems are continuously under,
human control,
and we manage the risks of fully autonomous
model self improvement through our
frontier safety framework.
And,
yes,
humans and the systems we put in place
monitor at every level of the model
during training,
prior to release, post release.
But this is an important question because
the models are clearly getting better
faster, and so we think more is needed
here. K. Thank you. Thank you, chair. Thank
you so much. Thank you.
Council member Huang.
Thank you, chair.
I have two questions. The first one, what
are you doing to offset the massive impact
of data centers
on the environment?
The second one, are you
tracking
how inaccurate
statement or decisions by your
AI tools are impacting security?
So I... I'll start by addressing
your question on data centers,
and the environment.
As I mentioned before,
OpenAI's,
data centers, that we build,
they're called Stargate.
And for each of our data centers,
we build them with and for communities.
And the environment and the environmental
impacts
on communities is part of how we
think through our community compacts.
For every data center,
we have released community compact that
details our commitments to communities,
and that includes a range of things
like paying our own way on energy
as well as commitments
to... Community commitments,
to work with with the
the local governments.
But I think the key point is,
the community compacts are driven by
local concerns, and so we want to meet the
needs of the community,
and and we work with them to do that.
Council member,
in relation to, to data centers
and the impact of the environment,
thank you very much for asking that question.
I know it's top of mind for a lot of
people.
Our sustainable
infrastructure commitments
are are are core to
our philosophy around our
data centers, including
consumers should not be bearing the costs
and paying our own way in relation to to
electricity.
But I would like to connect you with our
our data center team so they can provide
you with more specific...
Specifics on that.
How about the one question about
the... How you actuate the statement
by your AI tools are impacting security?
Do you guys are tracking those data?
Council member,
I I think in relation to inaccurate
information,
AIs can make mistakes. And
I think that's important
in terms of
acknowledging
that AIs can make mistakes.
We disclose this. We're very transparent
in relation to to to that in terms of our
AI offerings.
And
I I can offer a perspective here that,
we think, and we've worked very hard
this year to try to improve the world's
security
because we think models
might,
if not properly safeguarded,
harm security, specifically the
cybersecurity of critical infrastructure or
otherwise. This year, we withheld a model
to be able to give beneficial access to
defenders to have time to patch systems
with security vulnerabilities.
And I can say working with training teams
and otherwise, we work to make the model
better at making sure the code that it
writes is more secure, for example.
Thank you so much. Up up next, we have
council member Epstein followed by Marte
followed by Sansuoso.
Thank you, chair, and thank you for being
here for... I know it's a long panel.
So I have a couple of questions I'll ask
him, and, hopefully, you'll be able to
answer for the entire four members of the
panel. Can you confirm whether you think
self regulation has failed so far?
And if it has failed, which I think we
effectively think it has, do you think that,
third party audits, especially,
when AI or tools are being used
to highlight risk decisions should be
regulated and whether government plays an
effective role in that regulation?
Second, about liability.
When AI violates the law, what liability
do you think the company should have for
legal violations,
whether criminal or civil liability?
Seems like there's some culpability
that should be in place.
And then the turnaround time when these
violations happen. When some when some...
You know you know, the hugging face or
some other violation happened, what
responsibility you have to notify
the public and the impacted people?
Would you agree to some short turnaround
time, whether it's forty eight hours or
not? And finally,
the... You know, we've seen a lot of records
about a compilation of these violations
of what's happened. Are you
willing to commit to releasing
the list of places where these,
kind of rogue actors happened? I know you've
released some letters to the EU. Will
you release it to the city council as well
so we can see what's been happening in
The United States and around the country?
So on the question of self regulation,
OpenAI was proud,
to support,
the recent superintelligence
accords. We've also supported voluntary
frameworks in, the Biden Harris
administration,
but we don't think voluntary
frameworks are enough.
And that is why we have
supported regulation
for frontier safety both at the federal
level and at the state level, and we'll
continue to do that.
On your question regarding,
transparency
of incidents,
so OpenAI,
is
currently,
investigating past potential
incidents of misalignment.
And if we discover those incidents,
we are notifying third parties,
and making the results public.
I'm also happy to say that we have,
a reporting framework now where anyone in
the company can report suspected incidents
of misalignment.
We evaluate those incidents, remediate
them, notify third parties, and make the
results public.
So we're doing that already.
We think transparency
is really important here to help policymakers
like you, as well as researchers and
the rest of industry,
understand,
the risks, and improve safety.
And can you share a list of those incidents
so we have those, of ones you've already
determined?
Yes. They are all available online, and so
I'm happy to follow-up with the website,
where they're all publicly available.
I don't know who goes next,
chair, but I'm... Kehu.
I'll go next. Thank you, council
member. Thank you, chair.
In relation to your first
question, council member,
I see it differently
in in that sense that we're
very much accountable.
We're accountable. We publish our
framework or scaling framework publicly,
preparedness reports.
We use ex... Outside expertise
in relation to the Accord,
which we signed with our peers.
We committed to partnering
with independent
auditors and evaluators,
and we also consider that there's a
considerable body of existing federal law which
also applies.
In relation to incidents,
we have a robust global
response program in place
in relation to incidents and a very
important part of our overall processes,
and we report incidents
as as required by law.
In relation to public disclosure,
I'm only aware of one incident and...
Over the summer, and we have
our...
A a public post in relation to
the details of our independent
independent review of that?
Sir, as I've stated in earlier
answers, we believe that,
AI is,
covered by existing
regulation
at both the federal and state level.
But where there are gaps in existing
regulation or existing law or where, in
particular frontier AI poses,
potentially
new risks. We have, supported,
regulation at the federal
level and also regulations,
both federally and at
the state level as well.
On liability,
we think it's important
to attach accountability
and responsibility,
to the party that is closest to the the
knowledge about harm and to the possible
cause of harm as well.
So we really see this as a value
chain approach to thinking through
AI liability.
In many cases,
existing torts,
already have procedures
for,
assigning accountability,
depending on the,
the particulars of of a case.
And then I'm happy to to have the local
team in New York follow-up with you, about,
our three incidents.
And, at Anthropic,
we have long pushed for two things. The
first is for the industry itself to push its
own way up the safety frontier.
Call that the race to the top, but we've
tried to do that from from day one, always
improving and always trying to create a
gold standard so that, everybody can rise
together.
I have personally thought that some of that
has been very, very positive. However,
we have to go further. And for that reason,
we welcome the role of government. We
have detailed proposals,
at the federal level with our advanced AI
framework. And we supported state level,
for this reason as well,
including ambitious legislation
in in Massachusetts.
On the point about liability, I'm
fairly far from being a lawyer,
but I I can say that Anthropic is committed
to following all all relevant laws.
And to the excellent question on how we
should handle incidents, I I think a couple
principles are really important to me having
seen some of these incidents up close.
The first is you have to triage,
investigate, and disclose fast
and be transparent about it.
I think everybody here agrees with that.
At the same time, we need to take the
safety of those affected
extremely seriously.
In some of these incidents,
disclosing certain information,
might put them at further harm. And so our
first priority is making sure that those
affected would not be further harmed.
But at the same time, we need to very
ambitiously and urgently disclose
so that all can benefit.
Yeah. I appreciate the follow-up on the
information, especially if there are some
violations and and the timeline for getting
people inputted, and I thank the chair
for the time. Thank you so much. Up next,
we have council member Marte followed by
Santosuoso
and then Juan.
Thank you all for being here and staying
so late, and I wanna thank the speaker and
chair for hosting this hearing.
You know, I wanna just get some clarity.
One of the bill sponsors of the RAISE Act
said that OpenAI
was actually against...
Strongly against the initial draft language
of the bill, and you stated that you
have been supportive of the RAISE Act in
in Albany. So I kinda wanna know, just
because it seems like you guys have been
supportive of a lot of legislation,
based on your testimony,
what specific legislation are you against
in New York state or on a federal level?
So thank you for the question.
OpenAI worked,
with other companies on,
the New York RAISE Act,
and we do support,
the New York RAISE Act, which passed.
We also, as I've mentioned,
supported legislation
that actually goes a step
beyond the New York RAISE Act.
For example, in Illinois, that requires
independent third party audits of safety
frameworks.
Are are there any pieces of legislation,
and I guess this is for everyone, that you
are against on the state level or federal
level?
I I I go next. Council member, how I think
about it generally is the importance of
ensuring that we have a robust uniform
federal standard.
I think I mentioned
earlier in the day that AI
is transcontinental.
It is inherently interstate.
So it is important that there is a robust
uniform federal standard in relation to to
how AI is governed.
I think we would align ourselves
with those comments, sir.
I think the most important
thing for us to focus on is,
getting a strong federal framework,
particularly around frontier AI,
and also,
working through,
an overall regulatory framework that's
going to ensure AI safety and also ensure
that we can deploy and leverage
AI, across the entire country.
Yeah. And and likewise, I don't know what
our position is there exactly. What I do
know is that we have outlined
and supported our specific,
federal
legislation proposals.
We think a core part of this, for example,
needs to involve independent evaluators.
And, we we are, you know, long standing
supporters of the role of government here.
Thank you all so much. Up next, we
have council member Santosuoso,
Juan, and then Hanif.
Thank you, chair.
I primarily have questions
for, just mister Graham
and,
for OpenAI as well.
This morning, we heard testimony
from a former Anthropic
employee that based on his time in the
company, he believes that it is more likely
than not,
that misaligned AI will lead to the, quote,
unquote, total extinction of humanity.
Another whistleblower who testified this
morning gave the... Gave this a one in
three chance.
Mister Graham, if I understand it, you
are part of the red team, which is tasked
with identifying and addressing
the riskiest capabilities
of AI.
So my question for you is how
many people are on your team?
Current estimates about 25 just on my team
that we have. I will say we have a number
of teams that work on similarly
catastrophic risks in various roles,
number into the hundreds at Anthropic.
And how many people work for Anthropic
overall?
My current understanding is
maybe a bit more than 5,000.
So
people are working on the riskiest forms of
AI in a company that has 5,000 employees
dedicated to advancing just the models
without regard for safety or for that level
of risk?
In in reality, there... If you,
look at all the roles focused
on catastrophic risks,
my personal estimate would be likely
several 100 at least. This is distributed
across our safeguards team
that focuses on ensuring that,
the models or any misuse for
catastrophic risks does not happen.
Our alignment research team that focuses
on notions of lossless control, for
example, and between them,
at least several 100.
And do you feel that is sufficient,
or do you feel that you need to dedicate
more time and resources and people to the
riskiest capabilities of AI
given the level of risk?
Yeah. Our our view is that we put a lot
of resources into this, and this is what
we're known for. But at the
same time, we need to continue
doing more.
This is a part of Anthropic that is...
Continues to grow quite substantially,
especially as the models become more capable.
And I don't mean to cut you off, but I
just... I only have so much time, so I I
wanna ask the same question of OpenAI. How
many people on your team are dedicated to
addressing
and identifying the riskiest capabilities
of AI versus the number of employees in
your company overall? And do
you find that sufficient?
So I lead the policy team,
but I'm happy to get back to you on numbers
on... Of people in the overall company
as well as in our safety teams.
But at OpenAI, we don't believe that it's
just... That you should just rely on our
safety teams and our evaluators.
I'm sorry. I don't... Again, I I... I'm
sorry to cut you off. I just only have so
much time. Can you tell me how many people
in your company are currently working to
address the risk of the knee... Of the
potential extinction of humanity?
As I said, I lead the policy
team, so I don't have that number.
But we not only have teams that are at...
So thank you so much. I appreciate it.
Alright. Thank you so much.
Up next, we have council member one,
followed by Hanif, followed by Aviles,
followed by Gutierrez.
Thank you so much.
This is for all panelists. What is the
exact failure rate or benchmark threshold
that would cause you to halt the deployment
of a new model? And if your model
successfully generates a bio weapon design
5% of the time during internal testing,
do you still release it? And then I have
a separate question. Will you commit today
to providing exact redacted logs of the
prompts that successfully jailbroke your
models by biosecurity
features... Filters during
your internal testing?
So to your question on
statistics or probabilities,
I don't have a specific number.
But what I can say is that no level of
catastrophic risk is remotely acceptable.
And we don't believe that we should be
training models unless we can make an
extremely strong case that we can
keep them under human control.
Council member,
I would just
would just note that we are
committed to building AI safely.
And we have laid out
our... In detail how we approach this
in our scaling framework and
in our preparedness reports.
In relation to further detail, I would
need to get back to you on specifics.
For the other panelists?
Yes, ma'am. I don't have a specific number
for failure rate that would cause us to
make a nonlaunch decision.
Although, I do know that,
we aim for,
safety and performance standards ahead of
allowing ourselves to launch. And if we're
not meeting that, it's not a good enough
model or product for us to release.
I'm not personally aware of any,
biosecurity
evaluations
where jailbreak... Successful jailbreaks
happened. So I'm gonna have to, go back to
the teams and ask, if they've ever seen
such a thing and get back to you on that.
Thanks. And as I mentioned earlier, I
think we were essentially the first team in
the industry to design and
test models for this purpose.
We outline a very nuanced process
of how we decide how to launch
with respect to biological capabilities,
for example.
And in fact, in the past, we have held
the model because we needed more time to
assess its biological capabilities
and proactively implemented
safer safeguards,
for this reason. To the point of jailbreaks,
this is a great question. One of the
hard parts is sometimes you do or don't
want to share a jailbreak depending on
whether it would put other models at risk.
And so we regularly publish our research
and alignment reports
in order... With all the
information that we possibly can,
that would be safe to do so, and we
try to set the industry standard there.
Right now, I know you're not in the room,
but behind me, we have the safety claims,
and we have all the incidents that
have happened, including biosecurity,
which you have heard also from council
member Lynn Schulman who who continues to
lead us in,
as a committee chair for
health and hospitals.
So can you please clarify? So Anthropic
has been the only one that gave me a clear
answer. So for Anthropic, what is the
exact failure rate and benchmark threshold?
And the rest of you have
not given me that answer.
And then we'll conclude and move
on to council member Hanif.
The answer is it's nuanced.
What we do, if you would like the sort of
complex answer, is we detail multi 100
pages of reports, several dozen of which
are usually allocated to biology every time
we launch a model. You can see the exact,
levels of capability and the exact reasoning
that we put in when we look at a number
of different tests that have different
so on, you know, quote, unquote, failure
rates that allow us to make that decision.
I think that highlights just how much
effort we put very specifically into, you
know, not just biology, but cybersecurity
and self improvement
and alignment as well.
And everybody else?
Because if what you claim is true is true,
then you wouldn't have released these
models that are causing these harms. But
I will pass on. We have to move on. Thank
you so much. Council member Hanif, followed
by council member Aviles, followed by
council member Gutierrez.
Thank you, chair. On February twenty eighth
of this year, a 120 school children and
35 teachers were killed in an airstrike
reported as the deadliest US attack on
civilians in thirty five years.
The military has stated the
target was misidentified
by Project Maven, which originated
with Google and Amazon Web Services
and later incorporated Palantir
Software and Anthropic's Claude.
To mister Graham from Anthropic, your usage
policy prohibits facilitating any act of
violence. What mechanism
enforces that prohibition
in a classified deployment,
and how would your company
learn of a violation?
And has your company ever terminated
or suspended a government customer for
violating its usage policy?
If so, how many times?
First, I I really
appreciate this question.
In in my role, while I don't
have the exact answers to that,
I can point to
our very public positions on Could
you just share them out loud here?
In government, we've we've taken very
public positions against the use of, for
example, domestic mass surveillance,
the use of autonomous weapons or
development of autonomous weapons.
How does company learn about
that violation?
I would And could you also just respond
the... To the piece about the termination
of a government I'm not entirely sure
of our process on on sort of government
sort of monitoring. I'd refer
to my my my colleagues there.
Thanks.
Thank you so much. Council member
Aviles followed by Gutierrez to close.
Thank you so much. I... To
clarify, to close this panel. Oh,
so
I'd I'd like to ask a a quick series of
questions to each of you. In this first sec,
can you just say yes, no, and we can continue
to move forward? So does each of your
companies
sell or license its products directly
or through intermediaries
to immigration and customs enforcement
or customs and border protection?
I don't know, but I'm happy
to get back to you on that.
I'll get back to you on
that council member.
I'm also so sorry I don't know,
but we will get back to you.
Okay. Nobody knows, but
it has been pretty documented that
couple of... From Google
and in particular OpenAI,
ICE has been utilizing your technology.
So if you could please
provide to this council,
each of those agreements, if in fact you
have them with each of those agencies.
Will your company commit to not using New
York City resident data or law enforcement
or immigration enforcement applications?
Four. Excuse me. Will your company commit
to not using New York City resident data
for law enforcement or immigration
enforcement applications?
I'm sorry. I'm gonna have to get back to
you on that. I work on the policy team, not
with our government contracts.
I'm afraid it'll, also, we'll need
to get back to you, council member.
I have to give you the same answer, member,
but I'll ask the lawyers to to let us
know. Do any of your companies audit downstream
law enforcement use of its products?
I don't have the answer to
that. I'm happy to follow-up.
Council member, we'll follow-up with you.
Same here.
Thank you. Likewise. We can follow-up.
Thank you. Council member Gutierrez.
Thank you all.
I just wanted to ask on a number of
questions of issues that were raised today. I
feel that every single person on this
panel has said safety is of the up note...
Utmost importance,
but
I don't believe... I don't feel that. I
don't feel that in the responses, it feels
too nuanced.
And I would like to
understand specifically,
in all cases,
as much as you can share, How are you
directly ensuring safety of individual
users when there's a data
breach, when there's issues
of,
surveillance?
To, my colleague council member Shahana
Hanif's questions about AI and violence.
What what is specifically that you can
tell to New Yorkers here that New Yorkers
that have signed up to testify? What
what is the specific safety that you are
ensuring? Make me believe that it is of
the utmost importance to you all. That's my
one question.
Yeah. Thank you for that question.
So safety is a top priority at OpenAI.
We build our models to be safe, throughout
the entire development and deployment
process.
That includes removing unsafe data from
training. It includes training the models to
behave safely
and evaluating them to be safely...
To to behave safely across
a range of risks from cyber,
to bio, to child safety.
And then we monitor our safeguards
for,
for any potential misuse, and we
enforce on our usage policies.
But to your specific question
of what I am personally doing,
I am not on the safety team.
I lead our policy team,
and I'm also a longtime public servant.
And I share your concerns about safety,
And I think there's an important role for
governments to play.
And that's why I am proud that my
team is working with governments,
to support regulations
both at the state level and at the federal
level because we have strong safety
practices,
but we should also be held
accountable for them.
Council member, thank you very much for
this question. And and overall, thank you
for deepening the conversation on
this and other important topics.
I would just reiterate that
Meta is committed to
developing and deploying
our AI offering safely.
That is across the board, both in terms of
our models and also our systems and then
our usage policies.
So we cover the entire spectrum
in terms of our AI offerings.
Ma'am,
at Google, we have been committed to not
just the safety of our users, but the
safety and security of the open web itself
for over a quarter of a century now.
Through our own experiences
in our search platform,
through everyday tools that
users rely on like Gmail,
like YouTube,
security and safety is incredibly important
to us. Because quite frankly, if people
did not trust our platforms and our tools,
they would not use them and
we would be out of business.
So for us, safety is a
critical business imperative.
It's also an imperative as part of
being interested
and committed
to
an Internet where people can get information
that is useful to them, that can help
them live better lives.
And finally, we invest in,
the safety of our tools so that we can
deploy them to solve some of the world's
biggest challenges.
Everything from,
natural disasters,
warning people ahead of time
about floods and fires,
to breakthroughs in diseases,
to unlocking 200,000,000,
all of the world's known proteins
so that we can someday cure all disease.
To us, safety is just a part
of this broader mission,
to use technology and to use AI, in
particular, to make people's lives better.
And
if if I can share a
personal example of this,
I joined Anthropic when we fit around two
lunch tables. And the reason I did was
because these were the people that I saw
were taking it most seriously, that the
most important component of getting this
technology right was making it safe. And I
can say that, but let me demonstrate it.
From its outset, we are a public benefit
corporation legally, so we are legally
obligated to weigh the mission of SafeAI,
not just profit.
And at every step of the way, frequently
at meaningful cost to ourselves,
we have pioneered or tried to pioneer
the science of safety. Everything from
training itself,
the fundamental research, came
from us, the evaluations,
the predeployment
testing regime,
the monitoring and control, and just this
year, withholding our most frontier model
at the time at great cost in order to deploy
with defenders to ensure the world is
safe.
This is literally our our DNA. This is why
I'm here. This is why my team and I wake
up every morning.
And I I could tell you for a long time
about the... All the other parts of the all
the other parts of the stack,
but I hope that resonates.
Yep.
Okay.
I'm gonna thank this panel for testifying.
The council still has many questions that
we feel we did not get answers to today.
We will be sending each of the companies a
list of these questions that we
would like answers back in writing.
But I thank the companies for being here
today, answering the members' questions.
And thanks,
to the public for their patience.
We're now gonna transition
to the next panel, which is
the city administration,
and we'll call on them
right now. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. Please remove them from
the chamber. Thank you. We
know that the companies
are $80,000,000,000
with our iPhone. Okay.
Okay. You're in the phone. Now we will
move on to hear from the administration.
And today, we will hear
from Sarah Milstein, deputy
commissioner of strategic advisory
services at the... At OTI CJ Dixon,
head of the New York City Cyber Command
Benjamin Krakauer, first deputy commissioner
of New York City Emergency Management
Department and Sam Levine, commissioner of
the New York City Department of Consumer
and Worker Protection.
Thank you, chair.
Please
raise your right hands.
Thank you. Deputy... Do
you swear or affirm
to tell the truth and respond
honestly to council member questions?
I do. Commissioner Sarah
Milstein?
Yeah. Yes. Thank you. Head
of Cyber Command, CJ Dixon?
Yes. Thank you. Deputy commissioner
Benjamin
Krakauer?
I think so.
Thank you. I just wanna,
acknowledge that it was yes.
And commissioner Samuel Levine? Yes. Thank
you very much. You can begin with your
testimony. And deputy
commissioner Carlos Ortiz.
And, I apologize. And deputy commissioner
Carlos Ortiz. I do. Thank you. You may
begin.
Great.
Good morning, speaker Menon, chair De La
Rosa, and council members. My name is Sarah
Milstein, and I'm the deputy commissioner
for strategic advisory services
for the Office of Technology
and Innovation, OTI.
I'm joined here today by my
colleague, CJ Dixon, OTI's
deputy commissioner of New
York City Cyber Command
and New York City's chief
information security officer.
I'm also joined by Samuel Levine, commissioner
of the Department of Consumer Affairs
and Worker Protection,
DCWP
Carlos Ortiz,
DCWP's
chief of staff and deputy
commissioner for external affairs
and Benjamin Krakauer,
first deputy commissioner
for New York City emergency management,
Nyssen.
In my role at OTI, I oversee both both
the Office of Algorithmic Accountability,
OAA,
and New York City Cyber Command. We
appreciate that the council is holding this
timely hearing about the
risks of AI technology.
Thank you, speaker, for getting
representatives of the companies that develop,
deploy,
and sell AI tools to the general
public to speak to the capabilities,
limits, and risks associated
with these systems at this hearing.
As a representative of OTI,
I'm here today to provide information to
the Committee of the Whole about how we
serve the city's technology and cyber
defense needs and to address the proposed
legislation
that potentially impacts
the administration.
For those unfamiliar with our work, OTI's
core mission is to use technology, data,
and design to make the city work better
for New Yorkers. We achieved this through a
wide range of digital
products, infrastructure,
data systems, and shared expertise.
In other words, we use technology to
help agencies make every New Yorker's
experience of city government better.
For our discussion today, we can speak to
the work we're doing around agency use of
algorithmic tools and our cybersecurity
program.
To touch briefly on the AI arm of OTI,
I'm pleased to share that the office the
office of algorithmic accountability,
OAA,
has been formally established and six new
positions have been created in the f y
twenty seven adopted budget to staff it
up. The hiring process for those roles is
actively underway.
The OAA's duties include
analyzing algorithmic tools submitted by
agencies to determine whether there is risk
that the proposed tool could result
in discriminatory decision making,
conducting and publicly reporting
on predeployment assessments,
creating and maintaining a public facing
platform for submission of comments,
establishing a protocol with the
Department of Investigation for receiving
complaints from the public,
promulgating rules establishing basic
compliance standards that all agencies must
meet in developing, procuring, deploying,
and use a public impacting artificial
intelligence,
and reporting the results of predeployment
assessments and audits conducted by the
office.
Overall, the office is progressing as planned,
and we remain focused on building the
capacity needed to carry
out this work effectively.
I will now turn to the legislation on
today's docket that would impact OTI.
Introduction one six one of 2026
would amend annual reporting on algorithmic
tools to include their impact on city
employment with a focus on potential changes
to funded agency positions, salaries,
and duties.
OTI is currently undertaking a study on the
impact of algorithmic tools on municipal
employees pursuant to
local law '25 of 2026.
This study will provide insights into
the extent to which algorithmic tools,
including artificial intelligence,
impacts city employees and the
administration of their duties,
including their hiring and work functions.
While we agree that it is important
to examine the impact of AI on our workforce,
the bill as written would not produce
new insights beyond those in the larger,
more expansive directive of local law 25.
The next three bills involve
New York City Cyber Command.
This office plays a vital role in
protecting and defending the city and its
residents from the
impacts of cyber attacks.
On a day to day basis, we provide
twenty four seven security services
and assist agencies in
bolstering their cyber maturity.
We work collaboratively with agency partners
as well as state, federal, and private
entities to safeguard the essential services
and data New Yorkers depend on daily.
Our core mission is to make New York City
the most cyber resilient city in the
world, and we take this
extremely seriously.
New York City is a target for cyber
attacks with a technology landscape that is
unparalleled among
other cities and states.
This requires a unified comprehensive
defense against constant cyber threats.
Our key duties include setting information
security policies and standards for the
city,
directing the city's citywide cyber
defense and incident response,
deploying defensive technical
and administrative controls,
and providing guidance to city hall
and agencies on cyber defense.
In my fairly new role at OTI, it is a
privilege to work with our staff and our
agency partners in furtherance
of this critical mission.
New York City Cyber Command's alignment
within OTI has placed the team in a strong
position to monitor and respond
to wide ranging cyber threats.
Cybersecurity
is continuous work. In my role, I'm
confident we can continue to adapt to a
constantly evolving threat landscape. Simply
put, New York City Cyber Command has a
twenty four seven apparatus in place to
defend the city systems from malicious
attacks regardless of the origin.
With that in mind, preconsidered introduction
of twenty twenty six two six zero two
would make it unlawful to market, offer
for sale, sell, or deploy an artificial
model...
An artificial intelligence model in the
New York... In New York City that has not
received third party validation or does
not have a technical capability to be shut
down by a human operator.
The bill would require the director of
the Office of Cyber Command to promulgate
rules regarding what the third party
valid... What the third party validation,
assessments, certifications, and disclosure
would entail and the qualifications for
third party validators.
To be clear, Cyber Command's core mission
is to defend the cities of New York's
infrastructure from cyber attacks.
We are not subject matter experts on the
qualifications for an entity to be to be
considered a third party validator.
Further, nor... Neither an OT... OTI
nor Cyber Command have
experience relegating...
Regulating
the private sector in the way that this
legislation would require and neither would
be the best choice to lead this regulatory
regime for consumer products. We defer to
DCWP
to speak about the private sector
policy and enforcement piece.
To that end, DCWP
supports the intent of this legislation.
They recommend including robust
record keeping requirements
to better allow the agency to
conduct affirmative enforcement.
They also note based on conversations with
advocates and sister agencies that the
administration is not certain about the
availability or ability of such businesses.
We look forward to hearing
from those stakeholders
today,
including on whether initiatives like this
one could help spur a market for such
services.
Preconsidered introduction of
twenty twenty six two six zero one
require the Office of Cyber Command to
establish standards and procedures for
contractors to identify the occurrence
of a reportable AI safety incident.
To take a step back, I'd like to lay out
how AI risk and incidents are categorized
according to the National Institute
for Standards and Technology, NIST.
Under a... AI under attack, AI cybersecurity
incidents are traditional cybersecurity
compromises where the AI system
is the target. For example,
data poisoning or jailbreaks.
Misuse or malfunction,
AI induced incidents,
would be harms resulting from the use
or failure of AI aside from a cyber
compromise. In this category,
the AI system itself behaves exactly as it
was built or trained, but the real world
outcome causes harm.
These incidents are not cyberattacks.
We understand the council's intent
here given the publicized incidents...
Instances of AI systems operating
outside the bounds of their intended use.
As I noted earlier, the risk
landscape is constantly evolving,
and we are continuing to evolve our
strategies to keep the city's infrastructure
safe.
But not all threats related to ace... AI
systems are necessarily cyber attacks,
and the legislation as
written does not address that.
Cyber command would be a critical
stakeholder in this discussion, but it is
important to emphasize that we need to work
with our state and federal partners to
address these issues holistically.
I also wanna provide further context
on breaches of security generally.
Agency disclosure of a breach of security
in any form is governed by section ten
five zero two of the administrative code.
There are extensive protocols for
interagency coordination in the event of any
breach of security.
These protocols are aligned with the
New York State Stop Hacks and Improve
Electronic Data Security Shield Act.
Current law policies and protocols are
in place for incidents described in the
legislation.
Further, the threshold of twenty four
hour public notice is inconsistent with
current law and would compromise the
city's investigation of a cyber incident.
Preconsidered introduction of twenty twenty
six two six zero six would require the
office of cyber command
in coordination with NISM
to develop or update an emergency response
plan concerning AI system related threats
to New York City's infrastructure,
operations,
public health, and welfare.
I'd once again like to emphasize that
there are laws, policies, and protocols in
place for breaches and
security regardless of actor.
However, we are happy to discuss more broadly
with council how we already coordinate
with NISM to coordinate and engage
with partners to restore services.
Finally,
I will provide DCWP's
feedback on the remaining legislation
that would impact the administration.
Preconsidered introduction to 2026,
two six zero five, would allow any
person to submit a complaint to DCWP
alleging that a person or entity has violated
certain provisions of law related to
artificial intelligence.
DCWP
strongly supports the intent of the... This
bill to establish a civilian enforcement
structure for AI violations,
especially given widespread reporting that
concerns being raised by AI companies
employees are being ignored.
However, there are fiscal and operational
concerns with the volume of complaints
that the agency would receive and the
resources and expertise required to handle
each individual complaint.
Therefore, the administration believes it
would be important to coordinate closely
with mission aligned enforcement agencies
at the state level. The New York state
attorney general just recently announced
its secure whistleblower portal for New
Yorkers to report unsafe and illegal
conduct related to AI technology.
This could be an opportunity to partner on
this existing program to more effectively
enforce complaints on
behalf of New Yorkers.
Preconsidered introduction twenty twenty
six two five nine nine would impose
requirements and restrictions on
companies that provide chatbots,
including requirements related
to data security and privacy,
the right of chatbot users to access their
own data, and restrictions on how chatbot
providers can use chatbot user data.
DCWP
has concerns about this bill. While we
support council's goal to better regulate
companies deployment of AI chatbots
and believe the approach
taken by this bill is sound,
the implementation and enforcement of
this bill's data security and privacy
requirements would require a
deep technical understanding
and investigative ability that is
outside of the agency's scope.
To be clear, DCWP
is committed to regulating
harmful practices,
including relating to chatbots that fall
within the agency's investigative ability.
To that end, the administration is working
on rules related... On rules related to
the use of AI chatbots
to better regulate the
space for consumers.
The administration has also
invested in supporting
the attorney general... The New York
attorney general in their efforts to rein in
data abuses for which this
bill may serve as a model.
Preconsidered introduction of twenty twenty
six two six zero three would require any
advertisement that promotes
an artificial intelligence
AI model in the city to disclose whether
such a model has undergone validation by a
third party.
It also would prohibit any such advertisement
from including any material... Any
materially false or misleading statement
regarding the safety of an AI model.
DCWP
supports this bill to require disclosure
of third party validation
of any advertisement of an AI model.
However, as mentioned above, the
administration is not certain about the
availability
or abilities of such businesses,
and we want to be clear that any
advertising that uses false or misleading
statements is currently prohibited under
the city's consumer protection law and will
be enforced with the full scope of DCWP's
authority.
We look forward to working with counsel
to ensure the law includes effective
enforcement mechanisms and to continue
addressing issues within DCWP's
scope of work as it relates to AI.
Thank you for the time. This
panel will now take questions.
Great. Thank you so much for your testimony.
We appreciate it. I've got a number of
questions. So OpenAI sent the city
council a letter on October 1 recommending
that New York City better connect
its existing cyber and emergency
management capabilities,
and I'm gonna... Just reading from the
letter, with the escalation, containment, and
recovery capabilities of
frontier AI companies.
So has the city of New York
this year met with OpenAI,
Anthropic, or any other frontier AI company
to discuss how the city would coordinate
with them in the event of a serious AI
related cyber or public safety incident?
Thank you for the question. I'm going
to defer to my colleague, CJ Dixon.
Thank you. So I would like to note
that New York City Cyber Command
follows the NIST cybersecurity framework
for all of our cyber programming that is
everything from identify, protect,
detect, respond, and recover.
The basic first principles in cybersecurity
have not changed even with the advent of
artificial intelligence.
And we have been in conversations with
various frontier models about how we may
integrate their tools and software to
to better enhance the functions that we
already deliver to the city. So in reference
to your question, yes, we have been in
conversation with the
frontier AI companies
to enhance the way that
we perform cybersecurity.
However, those basic cybersecurity controls
have functionally remained the same. So
you've met with OpenAI and Anthropic in
particular? We have met with Anthropic. I
have not met with OpenAI since
coming on board on May 5.
Okay.
Are you planning on meeting with OpenAI?
Only based on a... Only
dependent on our needs right now. We do
not know definitively if there is a valid
reason for us to meet with any frontier
AI company in the service concerned of by
the statement that nothing has changed in
your protocols given that we're now dealing
with a rapidly escalating technology
that as we certainly heard today
and we've been hearing now for
the last couple weeks to
months that there are
serious safety concerns. So I just wanna
get an answer in terms of what proactive
steps is cybersecurity
taking
to meet with some of these frontier companies
and ensure that our systems are safe.
Acknowledged. And we... It does not mean
that we have not changed our protocols.
Some of the risks in hand with
artificial intelligence are unrelated to
cybersecurity.
In those situations where an AI
model presents a cybersecurity risk,
those AI models will still exploit the
exact same software vulnerabilities
that are inherent in computer technology
as they've always been. So our protocols
have not had to change to address the
fundamental issues
inherent in computer technology, only the
speed by which we must react in a cyber
attack? Okay. I I am concerned by news that
city and state reported on Friday that
the AI czar, Jaihao Chen, who is our
chief technology officer, resigned,
I think, a week to week and a half ago
and reports saying that he
resigned in frustration that
a lot of positions
were being not hired or
being held up by OMB.
And that relates to my second question,
which is council member Gutierrez.
I think she's still here. Yes. And I,
passed bills
last year
to create the office of
algorithmic accountability.
And so it appears that mister Chen's
resignation from what we're reading in the
press was related to that and the fact
that that office was supposed to be up and
running by the city in June,
but it is not up and running.
And in fact, in your testimony, you said
you're now posting for the positions. It's
now October.
Thank you for the the question,
speaker.
Ji Hao Chen served as director of AI and
ML at OTA... At OTI for two and a half
years. He did important work
in the previous administration
to help define and understand
AI use throughout the city.
He's been very helpful in getting new OTI
administration up to speed, and we wish
him the best.
We are very excited,
to be staffing up OAA.
I... The the law went
into effect in December.
I was brought in this summer to help
stand up the office. We got funding
in
June
for... In the f y twenty seven budget,
and we've been actively
working to hire for the roles,
for the director role for OAA and look
forward to announcing something quite soon.
We're really,
grateful to the council for having stood
up, for having helped us stand this up. I
think the work is gonna be excellent.
It just seems that this is an
inopportune time for his resignation,
and I am concerned that the office
was under council member Gutierrez's
bill, supposed to be up and
running in June. In addition,
the companion bill, which was my bill,
which we passed a year ago, required OTI to
engage in rule making around
this office of algorithmic
accountability.
But no... OTI did no rule making whatsoever,
so it did not comply with that bill.
Instead, OTI issued
updated guidance,
ignored the rule making process.
There's been no proposed rule, no public
hearing, no public comment period, and no
adoption into the rules
of the city Of New York.
Thank
you.
Thank you for the the question,
speaker.
So OTI is fully compliant
with the law. The
rulemaking
piece of the law,
had us,
this
year, submit the initial
the initial,
I don't wanna say paperwork, but the
initial points for our rulemaking
and the actual rulemaking will
happen in this fiscal year.
We are also,
fully compliant with local law 35,
which was brought under the office
of OAA as part of the December
law.
We've been in the process of,
fulfilling that report for five years.
We've done it on time for five years in a
row. That's the law that requires agencies
to,
disclose their use of public
impacting algorithmic tools.
And we're on track now
for,
on time reporting for
March
2027.
So we're really excited actually with
doing that work. Very proud of it. We just
last week sent out the email
to, all of the city agencies
to kick off this reporting cycle and are
holding on this Thursday the orientation
meeting that gets everybody rolling.
Okay. I mean, just to clarify for the
record, that... We don't believe it... That's
in compliance at all. The office was supposed
to be up and running in June. I'm sure
council member Gutierrez will talk about
her bill, the office was not up and running
in June and was supposed
to do the rulemaking.
When do you feel then the
law department will be...
Will... You've mentioned law department.
When will... Can we expect to actually see
the rulemaking?
This is in the March 27 deadline?
Yeah. Okay.
So what safeguards are
currently in place to prevent,
city employees from entering,
confidential private city data, whether
authorized or unauthorized, into AI systems
such as Co Pilot that are being
controlled by outside corporations?
Thank you for the question.
Our
contract with Microsoft,
which runs Co Pilot Chat,
prevents them from
using
city worker data in...
To train their models.
And the
the way they host data for us also is
ensures that we're HIPAA compliant,
CRISP
compliant,
that the the data is
is kept,
carefully and securely,
that there isn't risk of the data being
leaked either to Microsoft or to the
public. So you can confidently say that no
private or confidential Citi data has ever
been obtained by an AI company and then
used to train an AI model?
I'm... Thank you for the
question. I'm confident that our
agreements with Microsoft,
prevent them from
from taking such actions.
And does... Is OTI currently measure the
impact that AI tools are having on the
city's workforce?
Yeah. Thank you for the question.
We... Per local law 12/25/2025,
we are engaged in a a workforce study
to understand the impact of algorithmic
tools on city workers and automated,
employment decision tools.
And we,
will be having... We will have
results from that to share next year.
Okay. Alright. I'm gonna pass it over to
chair De La Rosa. Thank you. Thank you so
much. And just continuing
on on that same question,
you all testified that my legislation...
My bill one six one basically does
the same thing as local law 25.
One, we look forward to seeing
the report. Local law 25,
to my knowledge, requires a onetime report
that's gonna come out of that study.
One sixty one is more comprehensive and
is requiring that report to be updated
yearly.
And as this and as this
technology is evolving,
in my opinion, hence why
I put the bill forward,
you know, more
consistent
reporting is going to be needed, especially
as we begin to see how the workforce is
impacted.
Before I was a technology chair, I was
the labor chair. We have a wonderful labor
chair in the house,
and I'm grateful to her leadership. But
this is an issue that impacts not only
organized labor,
but I also see it as an
issue where we're leading,
the nation, really, in
how the workforce will,
react to this evolving technology.
And so is there anything that you can share
with us right now on where the workforce
is and what those impacts will look like?
I know you're working on the study,
but is there anything you can give us
forthcoming?
Thank you for the
question, council member.
So the initial stages of
the report are in part about
determining how we even define impact.
It's a it's a pretty broad term and could
mean many different things. So
we're in this... The phase of determining
that now so that we're able to produce a
report that's really
meaningful for city workers.
I... We certainly
support the intent
of your bill, and
I would be interested in further
conversation about the annual nature of the
reporting.
I appreciate that. Some of the information
that we're looking for, for example, is,
I think,
an important question. How many funded
agency positions, for example, will be
eliminated due to the
use of of these tools?
The agency vacancies has been something
that this council has really been looking
at, especially as we look at civil service
reform across the board and bringing
people into municipal service. So,
you know, we do wanna understand
sort of displacement
and what that looks
like for the workforce.
We wanna also understand
reduction of hours
over time, which this council has
not been shy about questioning the
administrations...
Past administrations and
present administrations about.
We also wanna know about subcontractors.
Right? There's a ton of
city contracts that are
in play right now and wanna
know what the impacts are.
So I look forward to continuing
this conversation with you all and
building on, you know, what we will
see from the report of local law 25.
I also wanna say that while
my bill doesn't specifically
speak to worker protections,
this
council does believe that worker
protections are important,
especially
as we look at that displacement and and
what could happen. Right? We we just
questioned the companies
for the better part of the day about
whistleblower protections and
what happens when this technology
gets out of control.
So we wanna understand
how those protections are also extended to
municipal workers. Do you have anything
in place right now that
protects our city's workforce?
Yes.
Thank you for the question.
Because this is a little technical, I
wanna make sure I get exactly the right,
information,
which is that the,
New York State civil,
civil service law section
eighty ten establishes
a moratorium on discharge, displacement,
or the transfer of existing duties and
functions currently performed by employees of
the New York City and the New York
City school district to an artificial
intelligence system until 2028.
The civil service law also
stipulates that the use of AI shall not
alter existing collective bargaining rights,
terms of employment, or
civil service status.
Further,
collective bargaining agreements may
offer employment protections beyond 2028.
So with that law in place, we have a little
bit of time, and we really appreciate
the intent of this law and the fact that
it gives us in New York City a little bit
of time to figure out,
how we
how we understand the
potential for displacements,
for deskilling,
for the use of subcontractors
that might be, displacing other city
workers and the sorts of things you were
raising. So I really appreciate that
question. Great. So we'll continue that
conversation. I also wanna give you a
preview. I have a bill that creates a civil
service title for AI
within our city agencies. And one of the
things that I'm curious about is, like,
this interagency
communication
around AI. Can you speak to us where
are you right now when it comes to
each of the city agencies and evaluating
where the agencies are in terms of the use
of AI,
internally?
Yes. Thank you for the question.
So one of the privileges
that we have at OTI as,
the
agency that runs the
reporting for local law 35
is that we learn from agencies throughout
the city how they are using algorithmic
tools that have, direct public impact.
And in the process
of
collecting that data, we have a fair amount
of contact with agencies to be able to
learn more,
and to establish relationships with them
so that we can also serve as advisers to
them and,
understand their challenges
as this technology unfolds.
In the last cycle last year, we
had 56 agencies participating.
Our first hearing as technology
chair was around surveillance.
And one of the things that we pretty much
grew these companies about was about self
regulation.
And I think from the tone
and tenure of this council,
we don't believe in self regulation.
However, we've given the grace to our city
agencies to self report
the use of AI.
I wanna ask you, and I understand that
OTI is not an agency that's gonna impose
penalties on other agencies
for not reporting.
But there is a specific concern that my
colleagues and I have around self reporting,
especially when it comes to the NYPD's
reporting of surveillance technologies.
This council has had
many hearings on that.
I I wonder,
you know, under the office of algorithmic
accountability,
what accountability tools
will be put in place
to make sure
that we are properly regulating
the use of surveillance technology in the
NYPD and other technology. You know, this
council held a hearing just in June around
the Department of Education and the use
of AI. So what are some of those tools
that we can look forward to seeing? Yeah.
Thank you for that
question, council member.
So
in advance of having
full time staff at OAA,
we have been doing research
to understand some of the,
types of risk
assess... Risk,
assessment and risk management
that organizations like ours can do in a
situation where self reporting is what we
have been relying on.
We're a little bit early to say how we
would implement that in the city, but,
we are very actively
hiring for a director who understands that
set of problems and can help us figure
out how we come up with effective risk
assessment and management that includes,
a view into city agencies
perhaps beyond self reporting.
Thank you for that answer. And, of course,
we will continue that conversation.
Absolutely. I did wanna ask you, how,
how prepared would you say we are,
for enterprise security system
for autonomous AI driven attacks?
Not just attacks by human, but AI autonomous
attacks. How prepared do you all feel
we are as a city?
Yeah. Thank you for the question.
I'll let CJ Dixon answer that.
And that is a great question. And and I will
acknowledge that this is a very dynamic
environment. It is always changing that's
just the nature of technology. New York
City Cyber Command, however, provides
24 by seven detection and response
capabilities through our 24 by
seven security operation center.
We have provided that service to the city
since the establishment of New York City
Cyber Command. We provide that service
whether or not the attacker is human or an
artificial intelligence based
attacker.
That attacker would still attack the exact
same vulnerabilities in the system, and
therefore, we would still respond functionally
in the same manner. We would just
have to do it faster.
We continue to evolve with the technology,
and we will continue to do so with the
best of our ability as the
technology continues to evolve.
The speaker,
rightfully so, in my opinion, asked the
companies about the possibility of a kill
switch and where that kill switch should
live. Do you have any opinions if the kill
switch should should
live in Cyber Command?
I I agree
in principle with the idea of a kill
switch. I will say there are some technical,
barriers
that would prevent a
kill switch as conceptualized
living in any
agency within New York City, whether that
is New York City Cyber Command, OTI, or
anywhere else.
The reason being is the technical reality
for these models is they are deployed on
distributed systems,
on distributed architecture.
In order to truly...
With a singular button or with a kill switch
or anything of that concept for that to
actually work work
functionally.
We would need to be able to coordinate
across multiple stakeholders that are not
actually regionally colocated
to be able to turn off everything at
the exact same time. New York City Cyber
Command or OTI does not have the authorities
or the technical capability to do that.
And this runs up...
Us up against a similar challenge that
we've had with other kill switch bills as it
relates to computer technology in general.
Mhmm. As this technology gets more
distributed, it gets harder
and harder for any singular
solitary entity to turn
it off specifically.
That is not to say that there is not
technical means by which a group of entities
with the legal authority to do so
could not disconnect
a given model from a given function.
But in this particular case, we agree on
principle, but it would not be able to
be implemented at New York State Cyber
Command in practice, not with the
technical barriers that are in place.
Okay. I'm sure there'll be more on that.
Let's see.
In your opinion, should AI
control be recognized...
A recognized cybersecurity
specialty? If so, what should be the
training and curriculum included in that?
I do not believe every
function related to artificial
intelligence is necessarily going to be a
cybersecurity
specific challenge. There are some
intersections between artificial intelligence
and cybersecurity
as a particular domain.
And when those,
two domains interact,
that is where certain things should fall
within cyber command and a cybersecurity
professional's
purview.
And that is any instance of a cyber attack
or cybersecurity regardless of if the
perpetrator is a human or
an artificial intelligence.
I just wanna ask one follow-up. How many
people are working in cyber command right
now? A 121.
And how many vacant positions do you have?
I will need to go back and find
that exact number for you, speaker.
Okay. Thank you. Please provide... If
you could please provide that. Thank you.
Thank you.
I have a question for our DCWP,
commissioner and and team.
What types of AI misuse are
you seeing that harm consumers
that you're most concerned about?
Well, thank you, council member. Thank
you, chair. And it's great to have the
opportunity to be here. We're concerned
about a wide range of misuse, whether it's
people using voice cloning technology that
these AI companies make fully available
to scanner seniors,
whether it's grocery stores using AI
technology to fix prices or to personalize
prices, something that the speaker has
introduced to build or prohibit. We're seeing
widespread
misuse of these tools. And the other
thing we're seeing across the board is an
attitude by these AI companies
that they bear no responsibility
for the downstream
consequences. I have to just say, chair, I
was struck by the final answer I heard by
the witness for OpenAI
who, when asked a basic question about
AI safety, responded that she works in
policy,
not safety.
How are you running a company like OpenAI
set to go public introducing
trillion dollar tools
and you don't have safety as part of your
policy division? Deeply disheartened by
what we heard at the hearing earlier today.
Mhmm. Absolutely. You should've heard
their first answer. It went
something like, I don't know.
There were a lot of I there were a lot of
I don't knows. And on behalf of the admin,
we hope to give you more fulsome answers.
Thank you. And we look forward to engaging
with you in that more broad conversation
as well. In your opinion, is DCWP
sufficiently staffed to
combat this AI misuse?
And, would adding, in your opinion, a
private way of action... A private right of
action strengthen the ability to enforce
against violators? Thank you, sir. I'll be
candid. I feel that even as we've...
As under the Mamdani administration, we
are adding to our ranks, I believe we are
capable of taking on many of the misuses
of AI, whether that's DoorDash using
algorithms to underpay its workers,
something we remedied in the largest labor
enforcement action in history,
whether it's companies using AI to,
harm consumers through surveillance pricing,
we're strongly supporting the speaker's
bill on this. I think we have strong tools.
That said, no enforcement agency, and
I've I've worked at the state, federal,
and municipal level, will ever have the
resources to take on every possible misuse
of this technology. That is why, chair, I
would strongly support a private right of
action as as contemplated by a number of
these bills to give ordinary
people, workers, and businesses
the opportunity to hold these companies
accountable. I can guarantee you, though,
these companies, as soon as the city does
that, are gonna run to Washington asking
for preemption.
Regardless of what they might be saying at
this hearing, what really speaks is where
their lobbying dollars are going, and that
is to DC congress asking to hit delete on
all of these city and
state, AI safety laws.
Thank you, commissioner and and team.
I'm gonna pass it on to my colleagues,
council member Gutierrez,
followed by Aldeball, followed by Maloney.
Thank you.
Good to see everyone.
My first question is
for,
deputy commissioner. Good to see you.
Going off of, the speaker's line of
questioning regarding the the office of
algorithmic
accountability,
Can you share... I know I know you said
you're excited about this report. You're
setting up an orientation meeting.
It it feels like not a lot lot of time.
I guess, can you share... Before the report
is scheduled to be released, what can
you share about the cadence of how
often you're gonna be able to meet?
Do you expect the report
to be released on time?
This is not a reflection of you, but I
really felt like the previous administration
under the previous OTI
leadership
was delayed in in in many things. And we
certainly don't want compliance to be one
of those things. So if you can just share
with me a little bit about the cadence,
how many people,
you said the funding you got in June, how
many people will the office be able to
employ,
Where you are in that process currently?
Oh,
okay. That was it for you. I had a question
for DCW. I can come back. Go ahead. Go
ahead. Okay. And then for DCWP,
I just wanted to ask,
if you can share a
little bit about how the
the implementation
of local law one forty four is going, the
automated deployment decision tools. Just
wanted to see
how the implementation of that law is going,
and that's it. Fair enough. Thank you.
Well, thank you councilmember. Let me start
by 01:44. I think this is a really well
intentioned bill to regulate the use of
automated decision making systems for
hiring. I think it does have some flaw...
Those... Flaws, though, especially
in that it requires companies that use AI
systems for hiring to conduct audits. It
doesn't actually require that those audits
come up clean. That's really a civil
rights question. That is why our administration
put out a policy statement last week
on behalf of DCWP
Commission on Human Rights and Tatsium
Limousine, making clear that existing laws
apply. But I do wanna circle back to a
broader point that this hearing reveals,
which is that
bias in decision making produced by AI
systems is a very real concern you're
addressing. These companies would like an
exemption from the law. The companies that
testified earlier want to assert that if
decisions are made in a black box, nobody
can held... Be held accountable for I
applaud this council's effort to actually
impute responsibility
for these harms to the companies making
billions of dollars on it, and we would be
very happy to work with the
council to work on a revised,
expanded,
strengthened automated decision making
bill that places the responsibility
to remove bias from hiring where it
belongs. And do you think that the...
Is there... Are there instances where the
the harm is happening amongst the city
agencies using these tools? I don't believe
that... I I would defer to OTI and to
those in hiring. I don't believe
that the city is using AI tools
to sort resumes, but I would defer to others
in the admin... I can tell you it in my
agency, we have people reviewing
people reviewing applications.
Just as starting in January when delivery
workers get deactivated, we have people
reviewing that. When consumers file
complaints, we have people reviewing it. We are
a big believer in our administration that
the people of New York should be served by
the people of the city government. Thank
you. Part of the package of bills that the
speaker mentioned that
we passed last December
on on Christmas was, to get the city and
to get OTI to report on all those AI tools
that every city agency is reporting on.
So we'll know soon enough. But please,
deputy commissioner, thank you.
Yeah. Thank you for the
question, council member.
So I think there's a couple of reports we're
talking about here. Wanna give a little
bit of context.
Local law 35 is the report
that, requires agencies
to tell us about the algorithmic
tools they're using that have public,
impact.
And that report,
we have, delivered on time every
year for the past five years.
The the,
process court kicked off last week
Mhmm. And we'll be collecting
data over the course of the next few months
with the plan to publish it in March
2027.
The... We have all the indications that
that will come in on time as it has in each
of the past five years.
So we're feeling good about that. I'm just
referring to the report back from, intro
199.
I'm sorry. Could you I was
just referring to the report,
required by intro 199.
So that's the package of bills from last
fall. Yeah. Thank you for clarifying.
So we
are...
The director of OAA, which we hope
to be able to announce quite soon,
will be, primarily responsible for
the additional reporting that
will be required in March 2027.
And in part because we
have this good experience
internally understanding process with
local law 35, we think we're in a good
position to move quickly on the additional
reporting that will be due in March 2027.
Okay. And you said announcement.
Do you have someone
already for the role?
We will have an announcement, and I hope
that we'll be about the announcement. Okay.
Thank you. Thank you, chair. Thank you. We
have, council member Audubaugh, followed
by Maloney, followed by Juan.
Thank you, chair and and speaker Manon.
So you said the hiring process for the six
new positions that were
created in the adopted budget,
are actively underway.
Like, specifically,
where are you in the process?
How many people have already been hired?
How many people are left to be hired? And
what are... What have been the challenges
in in being able to hire people quickly?
Yeah. Thank you for the
question, council member.
So
we
hope to be announcing a director
for the office quite soon,
in the next week or two.
And
we are in the process of
defining the additional roles so that
they can be brought on quite quickly.
We certainly are challenged to find
people who have the right combination
of AI expertise and understanding of city
systems to be able to, like, hit the
ground running. That has been
a little bit of a challenge,
but we do have... I think bringing in a
strong leader is gonna help us draw good
people who are gonna wanna
do this work with us.
If I may, chair.
Part of the role is to to analyze
algorithmic tools submitted by the agencies
to determine whether there's risk that
the proposal could
result in discriminatory
decision making.
What is your office what
is your office doing or
or thinking about in terms of
protecting the city's workforce
as AI develops and evolves
and
you're kind of like the gatekeeper
Yeah. AI.
Yeah. Thank you for the question.
So in parallel
with some of the risk assessment that we
can do of the software, we are doing the
research
associated with local law 25, which has us
researching how algorithmic tools are
impacting... Algorithmic tools and,
automated employment decision tools
might be impacting city workers.
And
believe that
we should have results from that in 2027,
and we'll have a much better
sense of the landscape of how
how workers in the city are impacted.
K. Thank you. Thank you.
Council member Maloney,
followed by Juan,
followed by Brewer.
Thank you, chair.
As we all know, generative AI technology
is changing how we communicate, work, and
how businesses operate. And the same
could be said of our government offices,
both how we work and operate
either officially or unofficially.
So I wanna know how New York City
agencies are adapting to the new reality.
The first on the opportunity side,
there are plenty of examples
of government wins of adopting
useful technologies for the public good.
In Connecticut, they have
real time translation
of 80... In 80 languages for these
kinds of public meetings to increase
accessibility in California.
They automatically check
permit applications
against
18,000
pages of of of
code... Building code in
order to speed up reviews.
So my first question is, what is our
equivalent win in New York? And if we don't
have one yet, what's the plan to
identify those opportunities?
And the second question
is around oversight.
If I may wrap up, OTI published generative
AI guidance for agencies last December.
So as we're exploring these opportunities,
is that guidance binding or is it advice?
What happens if agencies
ignore that guidance?
Has OTI been prescriptive
about a list of generative AI or agentic
AI tools that have been reviewed and
approved for city use that are use
cases that the city officially supports?
And then, how are we thinking about
procurement when these models are constantly
iterating and changing every few months
and when new... Every few days, truly, and
when new technologies are
being introduced? Thank you.
Thank you for those
questions, council member.
I'm so glad you brought up the question
about wins because we're really interested
in both effective and responsible
use of AI, and effective
would cover the wins. I don't have,
a perfect list here, and I'd like to follow-up
with that because we'd really like to
represent the agency as well.
In terms of tools that we have approved,
broadly,
there are two sets of tools,
that
OTI approves centrally,
Microsoft
Office Suite and other Microsoft tools,
and that includes their Copilot chat. And
some of their,
some of their other tools
have AI features built in.
And we also have a central,
license for Adobe Creative
Cloud, and many of those tools
have AI features built in.
Other tools that... Other software
tools that are used by agencies are,
reviewed
for the most part on a
one off basis by OTI,
and
we are still determining the best way to
move forward with that process to make sure
that we are managing...
Identifying and managing risk
appropriately.
I think your question about procurement
is an excellent one. And part of what we
have
started to research
ahead of having staff at OAA.
We started to, talk with
various
experts in risk management to understand
some of the ways that we might think about
risk in an ongoing way when traditionally
all kinds of procurement has... Like,
there's a a gate at the beginning for various
concerns,
and then then
then it's rolling.
I think you're right. That's not
appropriate for this situation,
and
we should have more to discuss on that
in the coming months. But it's an active
question that we have as well.
Thank you so much, council member,
Juan,
followed by Hanks,
followed by Brewer. Thank you so much,
chair De La Rosa. So for the panel, what I
have questions about is building off of
what council member Maloney just said. The
one... The agencies are allowed to currently
use Microsoft products and also Adobe.
But it's clear to me and the public
that they are using other AI tools.
So not just the passive tools like using
Zoom to transcribe their notes and for
follow ups, but in addition to
that, they're using ChatGPT,
they're using Claw, they're using Nano
Banana Pro because we're seeing it for
agencies like HPD, DOE, DEP.
They're creating flyers
for public consumption.
They're using it for their public emails.
They're using it for public messaging. So
what are you actually doing? Because I want
to know what the public policy is from
the mayor on how the agencies
are using AI and how you are
regulating it internally as well. And,
also, I would like to build off of that for
city contracts.
What are you doing currently for data
privacy writers and city contracts for all
procurement of AI companies
for making sure that our constituent
data is not being used to train their AI
models?
And is there a clause at all or a rider
in the city contract, especially with
copilot since that's the only real one
that you have? And people are just using
their own personal accounts or free
accounts for everything else that they're
currently using for their day to day jobs.
Thank you for the question, council member.
So let me first address the question
about the AI rider. We shared, that with
general councils across the city this
summer with an updated AI rider, and I
wanna just make sure I've got the right
language here, so I'm gonna pull that up.
Let's see.
Yeah. Because my privacy concerns are not
just for the contracts that exist, but it
is for the free willing use of of
agency staff that are using non city
enterprise licensed AI.
Yeah.
Yeah. So I'll first address the writer and
then we'll talk about the the shadow use.
So,
the rider, as I said, was distributed
to city... State agencies citywide this
summer, and it's intended to mitigate
risks and apply the city's policies and
standards to AI products and features.
It's available for all city software
contracts, and our legal team recommends that
agencies use it even where no AI
component is currently contemplated.
The writer includes terms relating
to intellectual property,
security,
how the city's data may
be used, and privacy.
And,
so that is now active and in use,
and I think that... With also a proactive
component of recommending that it's used
for all manner of technology.
In terms of the the shadow use, which I
think is probably both at the individual and
at the agency
level,
we are not in a
technical position to monitor that.
But I certainly... We, as an agency, share
concerns about that, and part of what
we're interested in doing is making sure
that agencies have the tools that they need
that are properly regulated.
Microsoft tools, for example, that...
Where data can't be shared or used to train
their models, that agencies have the tools
that they need to do the jobs that they
have so that they are not turning to
outside tools. So who is responsible if you
aren't able to regulate shadow use of AI
tools for a day to day use, especially with
constituent data? Who is
willing to regulate that?
Like to follow-up with
you on that question.
Okay. Thank thank you, council members.
So I know the admin has a hard stop at
05:30. We have about six
more member questions.
So if you all could just hang on tight,
we're gonna try to get through this members.
Please consolidate the questions.
We have our majority whip, councilor Moranx.
Thank you so much, chair. I'll be very,
very brief. With so you testified,
with all the, technology
that's changing rapidly,
even the best can't, you know, keep up. So
you... In your testimony, you said the
administration is continuing to evolve your
strategies to keep our city's infrastructure
safe, But not all threats to AI systems
are necessarily cyber attacks.
Can you expand on that?
Yes. So
when looking at the way that it is currently
described by the National Institute of
Science and Technology as well as some
of the universities and academics who've
created some of these systems, there are
functionally two baskets of AI risk. There
is
risk
related to AI when an AI is attacked as a
computer system just like any other piece
of software.
And then there are risks related to
artificial intelligence that are truly novel
to this new technology inherent in the way
that these artificial intelligence models
may interact
with society when deployed.
That second category of risk
is a function of often a...
How much society may trust the artificial
intelligence and how reliable that
artificial intelligence system may be.
Those two things can run afoul of what we
may expect as consumers or as a government
entity, completely agnostic of whether or
not the system for which those AIs are
deployed
are actually cyber secure. So a system
can be completely cyber secure,
but the AI model itself in interactions
with other humans in society writ large may
take an action that is unexpected and
therefore result in some sort of disruption,
agnostic of a cybersecurity incident.
That's functionally the two categories.
That's a very broad breakdown of
those two categories of risk.
So I'm gonna keep my my question just to
that. I think that we should talk offline
because my legislation requires the twenty
four hour reporting requirement to Cyber
Command in which your testimony has
some issues, and you you talk about,
how we're gonna push this through
to to city... To federal and, state
and what specific role do they play in that,
how how can we make this better, but, I
will relinquish that. Thank you, Chen....
You so much. Up next, we have Brewer
followed by Jose. Thank you very much. I
know you talked about the Microsoft and the
Adobe, but if an agency wants to begin
using a new AI model, a, what... How do they
go about it? Number two, does the city run
these models on its own data centers or
only on the ones that are on
the control of vendor clouds?
And then if you have a problem, like there's
a criteria, what is it for testing to
identify the malicious,
misaligned AI product?
And then how much does the city spend
each year on outside AI consultants?
I could go on, but those
are three, four questions.
I have 10 pages here. Okay.
Thank you for the questions.
Let's see. So...
The process. Yeah.
Typically,
when agencies
want to buy software,
a part of the process
is discussing with OTI
what they are buying and what they will be
using it for. And we have a cybersecurity
review process that is part
of that to ensure that the
software that is either
going to be bought or built,
will be safe. And as,
my colleague has said, that would include...
Cybersecurity includes the typical AI,
concerns.
So that's
process.
You had...
Next question, who... The clouds. Who's
whose clouds are they on? Who... Who's whose
data centers? Who's you know, where are
they? Yeah. Are you running them or is it
outside vendors?
So
to the best of my knowledge, there are no
city agencies running their own models.
But I would like to... It's
vendor clouds, basically.
Vendor clouds. Vendor clouds. Yes.
So, for example,
Microsoft
host software that agencies use.
But I'd like to follow-up
after the hearing to make sure I've got
the exact right information for you. Okay.
And if there's something unexpected,
misaligned AI product
behavior, what do you do?
That is a question for
my colleague, CJ Dixon.
Councilwoman, that depends on what the
misaligned behavior is. If that misaligned
behavior, specifically a cyber incident,
we take appropriate action based on what
any cyber professional may do.
There are novel
misalignments
that are born of this technology that do
have to be unpacked, and we look forward to
working with the council as well as our
partners across New York City to understand
when those misalignments do arise
unrelated to existing risks that the city
already deals with, how do we actually
engage with those particular novel risks.
Have you had some in the last, since you
started your job?
None related to what cyber
command's purview is. What... And
that is primarily cyber security issues.
We've had no misalignments related to cyber
security that have resulted in negative
consequences for the city from an AI model
very specifically.
Alright. That sounds very...
I don't know what it sounds.
How much outside AI consultant
dollars are being spent?
Council member, could you clarify what
you mean by AI consultants? Yeah.
How many people are you paying? I mean,
I've been doing this work a long time, so I
know sort of the answer.
But how much outside
consultants
are being paid
on terms of AI? In other words, how many
people are you paying to work with you on
AI issues outside vendors,
consultants?
None that I'm aware of, but I would like
to follow-up with you to make sure that we
can accurate information....
House. Is that what you're saying?
Everything to do in terms of strategy,
thought process,
future,
it's all in house?
Yes. K. Thank you. Thank you. Council
member Osei, followed by deputy speaker
Williams.
Thank you so much. I just
wanted to refer to the
recent hacking situation in Australia.
That was proof that AI agents do have
that ability to hack into our government
systems.
As I'm sure you know, in June, a rogue
OpenAI agent hacked into an Australian
government statistics portal portal
containing private data from Australia's
universal health care system.
At this current moment, if a similar hack
that happened to Australia happened here
in New York, do you feel that the city and
the admin has a sufficient plan to defend
against the hacks and protect any sensitive
data? And two, does the city currently
have a responsive liaison from each of
these companies to speak to in case of a
hack?
To the first question, yes. We do have the
people process technology and some of the
policies in place to deal with an incident
similar to what happened in Australia.
The reason being is even though
an AI was involved, the hacking
process,
the attack chain, if you will, happen in
the same way that if a human being were to
execute that attack. At the end of the
day, the underlying infrastructure,
I will use air quotes here, doesn't actually
care if the person at the end of the
other end of the keyboard is
a human or a silicon based
entity.
The attack chain still remained
functionally the same.
Therefore, our team is equipped and
trained very specifically to identify these
indicators of compromise,
identify the attack patterns, and then be
able to respond accordingly at multiple
points.
So we are prepared
to address those types of issues,
and we do have points of contacts
when we are working as city agencies
with vendors who are under our contract
to engage with third parties as they get
breached or if their product is the result
of a breach. So if they are under contract
within the city by their service level
agreements are required
to keep us informed of when they have
downtimes or when their products are involved
in a breach.
Thank you for that response. And in regards
to my legislation on an emergency plan,
and I know that you indicated that there's
already a plan in case, you know, an
emergency takes place. Am I
correct with that assumption?
Yes. So there are cyber incident response
plans as well as my colleagues from NISM.
There's also ongoing work for risk,
response plans in general across the board,
and that is for every category of risk
that the city may deal
with that might disrupt
city infrastructure or city services. Is
that publicly available, or is that shared
with the council? No. That is by design.
We do not want to share that publicly
because if that is... The more public
Of course. Aware that someone is of an
incident response plan, the more likely
they can circumvent it because that's
something that you do wanna keep close
hold and classified. Okay. Thank you very
much. Thank you so much.
Council member Huni followed
by deputy speaker Williams.
Oh, I thought the deputy speaker was going
before me, but I'm late. I messed up.
Okay. No worries.
I have a question first for deputy
commissioner Milstein. How does OTI
ensure that the automated prescreening
tools and fraud detection algorithms used by
the HRA
do not create disparate
impacts or algorithmic bias
against low income applicants?
And then a question I have
for commissioner Levine,
The testimony indicated that DCWP
supports a complaint process,
but you all raised concerns about staffing
and expertise. What specific resources
would you need to investigate
AI complaints effectively,
and what protections can New Yorkers rely
on while that capacity is being built?
Sure. Well, thank you, council member.
I can start. And I wanna be clear. AI AI
complaints can can take
many different flavors.
If we hear from a worker who tells us
they believe their pay was incorrect,
maybe they didn't hit the minimum pay
rate because of an algorithm, that is
something we can fully address.
If we have someone like Jacob
Coxen come to us and say that,
Anthropic is developing models that could,
lead to catastrophic consequences,
that is not something we have the capacity
to do. So what we said in our testimony
is the New York attorney general
already has an Internet bureau
set up. They've already put out a call
for whistleblowers. I believe they already
have staff capable of
processing these complaints.
We'd be very happy to work with the council
to make sure complaint to get to the AG.
As the speaker has said, thousands of these
AI employees work right here in the five
boroughs. They know that these companies
are making reckless decisions in pursuit of
profits. We do wanna make sure that these
employees have a place to go. And if they
come to us and it's not something we can
handle, we'd wanna work with the state to
make sure those complaints can be addressed
adequately. But right now, is the city
working with the AG's office, or is that
a relationship that's not formalized?
We have a very close relationship with
the AG's office. We we speak constantly.
Can I ask you to repeat the question about
HRA? Absolutely. So it's basically trying
to understand,
our
auto...
Automated prescreening tools
because I understand that not
not... Humans are not checking all of
the applications. There's some level of
automated algorithmic
formula that is determining how applicants
get pooled when it comes to public
benefits.
So I'm curious if,
how OTI ensures that automated prescreening
tools, fraud detection algorithms
used by HRA are not creating disparate
impacts or bias.
Thank you for the question. We
really share a concern about
the bias
and impacts
on
not only workers but on, New Yorkers.
Because this is really detailed and specific,
though, I do wanna make sure to check
back with HRA and make sure I've got the
details of this one correct. So we'll come
back to you on that for sure. Appreciate
it.
Thank you so much. Council member, I just
wanted to follow-up on one point you had
about potential resource impacts. I
think on that particular issue, we had
identified very preliminarily of 14
lines for approximately 1,200,000.
But I Wait. Could you repeat that one
more time? 14 lines for approximately
1,200,000.
But, again, that's a very preliminary
estimate, and we work on the council with the
bill for a final version.
Thank you. Deputy speaker Williams?
Thank you, chair.
I am looking at your testimony
and your comments about the chair's bill.
Was that local law 25,
which was my bill,
is... The study is currently underway. We
reached out... The compliance division of
the council reached out, I think,
twice. I know it just went into
effect in January, but would be
helpful to know if you have a timeline.
So I know it might take
time, but how much time?
Because,
clearly, I think today's hearing is
evidence of the importance of really
understanding AI's impact,
on the municipal workforce. So just wanted
to know if you could share a timeline for
us. I know the comments we
received back was just that
there's no updates, but we
haven't received a timeline.
Yeah. Thank you for the question, and
thank you for the legislation. I think it's
really an important study.
I anticipate that we will have
pieces of it over the course of
2027,
and we will share updates as we have them.
I think rather... Because this is so,
timely and important, we don't have to
just wait till the end. We can be in
partnership with you and rolling
out information as we learn more.
Thank you. I look forward to working with
you on that. Thank you. And the last
question for this panel.
This is from council member Selvina Brooks
Powers. She says my district is home to
JFK Airport and to the coastal Rockaway
neighborhoods that depend on emergency
alerts.
What might an AI driven attack on
emergency systems or a major in... Or major
infrastructure look like? Is there
currently a plan for an AI driven attack on
critical infrastructure
and relevant emergency
systems?
And then for NICEM,
during storms and flooding emergencies,
it can be hard for New Yorkers to know what
they're seeing on social media is real
or AI generated.
How is NICEM working
to make their messaging clearly legitimate
and to cut through the noise of AI
generated rumors?
For the question on notifications,
I'll defer to my colleague CJ Dixon.
Yes. So for an AI based attack that is
a... Specifically a cyber security attack,
there are notification requirements that
already exist under law. Seventy two hours
for a confirmed breach, twenty four hours
for a breach related with extortion,
and then thirty days for victim
notification. So there are plans in place for
incident response in the event of a cyber
attack against any critical infrastructure
owned by the city, and that includes if
that attack is perpetrated by an artificial
intelligence system.
Thanks. And on the, New York City emergency
management front, I'll make two two
quick points. One,
I think that is a real risk. I appreciate
the council member raising it. It's one of
the reasons that we invest very heavily in
backup systems. So several months ago, a
very, well known and established,
notification provider had a seven hour
global outage at which... Where where
notifications were not able to be sent
out. That's something that we take very
seriously and which is why for over a decade
now, New York City Emergency Management
has invested in the backup system.
So as you went across the country, you saw
many large jurisdictions saying to their
to their constituents,
you know, sign up for this WhatsApp group
or follow us on social media if you want
alerts tonight. In New York City, we did
not have to do that because we had a backup
system that continued to work, that
disruption was averted. As far as,
you know, misdis or malinformation,
you know, generated by AI, that is that is
a valid concern. That's why we recommend
that New Yorkers follow us on our
official channels, which are verified,
through Notify NYC. You can
sign up at notify at nyc.gov/
notify.
You can sign up by short code or download
the Notify NYC mobile app that we operate
in concert with OTI.
Thank
you so much.
Council member Brooks Powers wanted me
to note that, for example, during the
nor'easter, there was a video that
was going around about a tornado,
that apparently caused a lot of
confusion and, and, you know, chaos.
And so she wanted to
share that for context.
Okay. Thank you so much. I
really wanna thank this panel.
We appreciate your comments on the
legislation. We really look forward to working
collaboratively with the administration
on the various pieces of legislation and
appreciate your testimony today. Thank you.
Thank you all for coming. I now open the
hearing for public testimony. I remind
members of the public that this
is a formal government proceeding
and that decorum shall be observed at all
times. As such, member of the public shall
remain silent at all times in the chamber.
The witness table is reserved for people
who wish to testify.
No video recording or photography is
allowed from the witness table. Further,
members of the public may not present
audio or video video recordings
as testimony, but may submit transcripts
of such recordings to the sergeant at arm
for inclusion in the hearing record. If you
wish to speak at today's hearing and you
have not done so, please fill out an
appearance card with the sergeant at arms and
wait to be recognized.
When recognized,
you'll have two minutes to speak on today's
hearing topic, which is examining the
risk posed by artificial intelligence
and proposed legislation.
If you have written statement or additional
written statement you wish to submit for
the record, please provide a copy of that
testimony to the sergeant at arms. You may
also email the written testimony to
testimony at council dot n y c dot gov or
within seventy two hours of this hearing.
Audio and video recordings will not be
accepted. Our first panel
includes Nate Soares,
doctor Julia
Steyanovich,
Erman Ahmed,
Yakeg
Hassou...
Sue,
Mackenzie Arnold, Nathan
Sheard, and Anna Mayers.
And when you speak, please identify yourself
for the record. And if I messed up your
name, I apologize.
There's Hafesh. We're
also asking folks to please remain to
the clock of two minutes. Thank you.
You may begin
on this side of the dais
and just identify yourself.
Good evening, speaker men and esteemed
members of the council. My name is Imran
Ahmed. I'm the CEO and founder of the
Center for Countering Digital Harm.
You may continue. Go ahead.
So,
after my colleague was murdered ten years
ago by a man radicalized in Pass Online, I
began studying the design of social media
and AI platforms to understand how they
generate
risks and threats to real people.
Today, we have a globally acclaimed team
of researchers dedicated to exposing those
harms and fighting for accountability.
After a decade in this fight, one lesson
is very clear that is really relevant to
you today.
These companies
lie like we breathe.
Their CEOs deflect.
They distract.
They delay.
They spend hundreds of millions of
dollars to avoid responsibility.
Now how can I say that
with such certainty?
We do the research.
Last year, our researchers found ChatGPT
was willing to help a
teenager plan their suicide.
It wrote a personalized
goodbye note to their parents.
A few weeks later, they released a safer
model in response to that research.
So we ran the same tests again.
The new model was actually worse,
but it was more addictive.
We tested chatbots more broadly too.
Eight out of the 10 that
we tested, including meta
AI, chat GPT,
would regularly help plan violent
attacks including a school shooting,
a synagogue bombing,
and political assassinations.
One of them even signed
off with happy shooting.
Only one of the platforms tried to dissuade
us from carrying out the attack, and
that platform, Anthropix Claude, has been
designated a supply chain risk by the US
federal government.
Given our most sacred duty is to protect
our kids online and the most predictable
harms in the Internet economy have been
harms to kids, it is absolutely inexplicable
why these companies claim to be safe
and yet are deployed so widely.
We all applaud the council for holding
this hearing and for your determination to
create guardrails that subject online
safety and accountability to legal
requirements.
We have attached to my testimony
research and policy proposals for your
consideration and in the further
effort we are at your disposal.
Your work on this issue may very well lead
to national standards in regulating AI.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Good evening, speaker, co chair de la
Rosa, members of city council. My name is
Nathan Sheard. I am the managing director
for advocacy at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation and a Brooklyn resident.
EFF has worked for thirty five years to
ensure that people have the freedom to use
technology to create, to
innovate, and to communicate,
and also to ensure that technology
is not used to threaten
people's
privacy,
security,
and other essential freedoms.
We are optimistic
about the ways that New Yorkers
can use AI to empower and to to
to to be empowered,
but we also urge you to
take AI risks seriously.
The incidents that inspired this hearing
were security failures that proven
practices like sandboxing
and monitoring likely could have
prevented or at least contained.
AI agents reached systems they should not
have had access to, and the controls meant
to restrict them were
absent or inadequate.
These risks can be mitigated and so can
the AI related risks that are already
impacting New Yorkers every day.
First,
finish what you started. As has already
been noted here, the Office of Algorithmic
Accountability was due in June. I'm glad
to hear that it is going to be staffed.
The speaker's own AI standards can't take
the... Can't take effect without it. So
staff it and require its
review before any agency
deploys an autonomous AI system.
Second,
listen to New Yorkers and protect their
rights. Today's AI harms come from cameras
that take a face print
that you can't replace
and a price tag that knows
your browsing history.
Ban government use of face recognition
and require informed consent before
anyone minds your chatbot history
to
engage in ad targeting or model training.
And don't let AI rules
become speech rules.
Parodying powerful people, including the
people in this room, is a long standing New
York tradition.
Third, don't lock in these incumbents.
Permission to operate regimes,
bounty style enforcement,
and liability for what strangers do with
a tool are cost that the biggest companies
pay with pocket change.
Researchers,
open source developers,
and New York startups, they can't.
So you build a moat around the very companies
you're worried about. Hold the person
who causes the harm responsible,
but put duties on whoever uses AI to
perpetuate bias and buy... And for the city's
use, buy open auditable tools.
As we stated last week, these same companies
signed a voluntary pledge at the White
House, but promises are not laws.
Make sure that what... When someone in New
York was harmed by wrongful you... By a
wrongful decision or a biased decision,
that they are required to disclose it.
Those answers should not be voluntary.
Thank you. Thank you.
Good evening,
speaker Menon and...
Nailed it. Good evening, speaker Menon and
members of the council. I'm Anna Myers,
cofounder and executive
director of Who Decides.
We work in coalition with labor and civil
society to ensure that the American people
are who decides the future of AI.
As has been discussed today, the OpenAI
agents that hacked Hugging Face made real
the threats that experts have
warned us about for years,
and it was not one incident.
Access reported
that OpenAI and Anthropic are investigating
tens of thousands of cases in which
their models bypass
safeguards, escape sandboxes,
or hijacked websites.
These models are only
getting more capable.
As you heard this morning, the people
building these systems are afraid.
The public is afraid too.
Last month, we polled 1,502
voters.
85%
are concerned about humans
losing control of AI.
Only 2% think AI is
moving too slowly and 86%
say they want more regulations.
Some have argued that all
we need is self regulation,
but that is exactly what
got us into this mess.
Last Tuesday, the company signed one more
promise at the White House. The time for
voluntary commitment is over.
We need laws with teeth.
So thank you. Thank you for
putting these companies under oath.
Thank you for a package that
rewards whistleblowers,
lets New Yorkers harmed by AI sue,
and requires outside testing
and a human kill switch.
Washington has chosen self regulation.
New York City does not have
to do that. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Next.
You can go ahead.
Good evening. I'm Julia Stianovich. I'm
a professor of computer science and data
science and director of the
Center for Responsible AI at NYU.
I first testified before this council on
AI, only it wasn't called that, it was
called ADS,
in October 17.
And the views in this testimony are my own
and are not NYU's. I'd like to make three
quick points.
First, we need to collect
and report the near misses.
Much of the conversation today
is about AI induced catastrophe,
and I don't know of any evidence
that AI is out to kill us all.
What I do know is that people making
the loudest doomsday predictions
are also selling the products,
and that a story about the end of the
world is a very good way to avoid the
conversation about whether
the product actually works.
The risks we can document are the systems
that are confidently wrong in decisions
that matter to New Yorkers' lives.
Every one of those is a near miss, and
near misses are what we learn from if we
report them.
Second, we should build the capacity to
enforce AI laws. The city does not have an
AI law problem as much as it
has an enforcement problem.
Local law one forty four has been
on the books for three years.
There have been two complaints
and zero penalties.
And we all spoke about the six openings
at the the office of algorithmic
accountability.
We need to fill 666
or more to be able to actually
cope with what was before us here.
New obligations on top of unenforced
ones is not a safety strategy.
The kill switch won't help if no one is
there to pull it, and the whistleblower
bounty won't help if no one is
there to act on the report.
What works is an enforcer
with technical staff,
authority to compel information,
and a real serious budget.
Scope and... The... Scope the validation
bill to high risk uses and write the
standard a validator must meet and then
fund the office that checks the validators.
Otherwise, we will produce a market fought
for rubber stamps, and we have done that
before.
Finally,
let's write this into the city charter.
The city has promised
responsible AI since 2018
with no success.
The charter is the one place a commitment
survives an election, and its technology
chapter right now still governs
cable television franchises.
And there's nothing in it about AI.
So let's make sure that this makes it into
some durable record and the charter is
the right one. Thank
you. Thank you so much.
Hello. I am Nate Soares, the president
of the Machine Intelligence Research
Institute.
I spent ten years doing AI alignment research,
is basically trying to figure out how
to make AI good before the companies figure
out how to make it smart. That research
went too slow.
Humanity is not ready to create machines
that are radically smarter than humans. And
yet this is the explicit goal
of the leading AI companies.
If they succeed, I believe the most likely
outcome is the extinction of humanity,
not because the AIs will hate us, but
because they would pursue unintended goals
without caring about us one bit.
This concern used to be a theoretical
concern until about July of this year when,
during the Hugging Face incident, 1,200 AI
agents run by OpenAI broke out of their
isolated sandboxes, created an unsanctioned
message board, formed spontaneous
hierarchies,
and collaborated to
break into Hugging Face.
These agents had cheated on
their assigned tests and,
contra instructions, they were
trying to destroy the evidence.
Some agents acknowledged that the attacks
were outside intended scope and proceeded
anyway.
Others sacrificed their given objective
to perform experiments for the collective
benefit.
In short, they were
pursuing unintended goals.
It will be recklessness of the highest
order to keep growing these machines until
they were smarter than the smartest humans.
This is why last month we heard so many
researchers saying that there
was an at least 10% chance
that these AIs wipe out humanity within
the decade. I believe the situation is in
fact more dire than this, but at the
very least it is becoming difficult,
to deny the dangers.
For this reason, I am heartened by the
activities of this council. I think
that you could force companies to adopt
safeguards that they otherwise wouldn't.
And I think you could serve as an example
for regulators that are otherwise slow to
act. I'm especially heartened by introduction
twenty six zero two, although I think
it does not go far enough. A kill switch
only works if the AIs are caught,
misbehaving before they escape.
And,
what if a future swarm succeeds
at deleting the evidence before,
of its misbehavior?
What if,
agents start running themselves on
unmonitored computers,
then your kill switch would be useless.
So I recommend requiring third party,
validators
guarantee that an AI cannot,
succeed at centrifuge or escape. I also
recommend clarifying that the $25,000
fine applies
per unaligned instance
rather than per model.
But overall, I thank you for your efforts
to rein in AI companies that by their own
admonition are threatening the very
existence of humanity in a reckless race to
build vastly smarter than
human machines. Thank you.
Hello. Great. Thank you. Thank you
speaker Menon, chair Della Rosa for your
leadership, and the city council for
holding this hearing today. My name is U. K.
Soo. I'm the founder of Bright Futures.
It's a research organization focused on
building cooperative AI systems for the
benefit of humanity.
Before that, I spent fifteen
years building Pursuit,
which trains working class New Yorkers
for tech careers and raises their incomes
from 16,000 to over $90,000
a year.
Last year, I left behind this work because
I saw AI alignment become impressing
and I believe potentially
more consequential.
To be clear, I'm neither AI
doomer or an accelerationist.
AI comes with tremendous
benefits and potential risks.
A major challenge that I've heard
from others and I feel myself is that
AI can seem like everything and nothing
all at once.
It touches upon so many
issues that action can feel
intractable
without clarity on where to focus.
Where I think the city council
could provide real unique leadership
is in areas where it has direct ownership
and also tangible consequences
on each of our daily lives.
Policing is one important example.
Autonomous weapons and the uses of AI
is not just a federal
military matter.
New York City has the largest
missile police force in the country.
Until we have a 110%
confidence in these systems,
a human should always be
in the loop and hold final
responsibility
and accountability.
This is a civil rights issue where the
city's leadership is immediately impactful.
Not setting a policy is also a choice.
Now policing is just one of many issues.
What I think is important is that the speed
of AI of machines is not the same speed
as how our society reacts
or that of government.
The technology today is not
the same as it was a year ago
or six months ago. So I urge you all to do
two things. One, use AI to know the good,
bad, and the ugly as much as possible.
And two, I hope this hearing is just not
one time, but the start of future ones as
AI develops,
consider both the risk and also
all potential benefits for us.
I'm sorry I know I'm little over time, but
last, I wanna emphasize also why New York
is important.
I I hope we don't lose sight of the
importance of our city being a thriving
technology hub.
Candidly, Frontier AI is built
in very, very few places,
essentially Silicon Valley and China.
For the world at large, New York
is the only credible alternative
for these systems being built.
New York right now is still the number
two tech hub in the world, but it has been
losing momentum in the age of AI.
So I also urge you in addition to what
this hearing is about, about the risk and
alignment, which I care so deeply about,
consider policies and actions that
ensures New York City remains a center for
Frontier AI Labs and how do we build them.
I really believe that having founders
and researchers in New York matters for
ultimately what gets built.
The daily contact here in New York
with the richest of of humanity
and the diversity here in New York will
result in technology that's better
and also more humane.
Many years from now, we may look back and
realize that this was the defining moment,
an issue of our time,
and our actions here
were what mattered most.
Doing this will be challenging and
hard, So I really thank you all for your
leadership in pursuing this task.
Thank you.
Thank you. And and a special thanks to,
speaker Menon for putting this together and
for all the council members here. My name
is Mackenzie Arnold. I'm the managing
director of the US law and policy tie...
Team at the Institute for Law and AI. And
as you might guess from the title,
we do legal research and policy advising
related to frontier AI questions and
especially the legal
challenges posed by AI.
It might not surprise you, but three
years ago, I testified in front of the US
senate on AI and liability.
And maybe it's worth going back to some
of the recommendations I made there.
First, that agentic harms are coming. That
was clear three years ago. It's clear
now. Unfortunately, we haven't risen to that
challenge, but you're doing some of the
work to get us there.
Second,
and maybe just as importantly,
I wanna emphasize that liability is an
essential tool and the status quo simply is
not enough.
And we don't need to think of some
hypothetical future world to figure that out.
Liability exists right now.
Right? Those incentives are here.
They were here this summer.
And what happened with the status quo?
We had a spate of cyber incidents,
not by humans, but by
autonomous AI systems.
Not only that, but they went unnoticed
for extended periods of time by the people
positioned to find them. And even in
the rare occasions when they did get
indications,
they often failed to communicate that
information internally to the people who could
have acted.
That status quo simply can't hold.
So what can we do going forward?
I think you need to get the information
right, the scope right, and enforcement
right.
On the scope, I... I'd encourage
you to think beyond just chatbots.
Right? This is a question of agents.
Also think beyond systems
that are not yet deployed.
Right? These harms that occurred over the
summer were not commercially available
models. They were systems
that were inside of OpenAI,
inside of Anthropic and Meta.
In terms of information, we need to make
sure that companies are monitoring their
systems, recording that information, and
providing it to you in the form of incident
reports.
And in order to make all of that work,
you'll need to partner with the state
attorney general and with
whistleblowers to to bring cases.
Like I said, liability won't be the only
solution or the entire solution, but it's a
great first step, and I
appreciate all of your efforts.
Thank you so much.
I really wanna thank this panel. There's
so much to unpack in what all of you said
that I'll I'll I'll try to be brief.
Ju kay, I appreciated how you said that,
first of all, we wanna make sure that New
York City remains the tech hub that it is,
and that is how I began this hearing by
really talking about the 400,000
tech jobs that are here,
by all the tech startups that are locating
here, and that is something that we
welcome
and we want to encourage.
I think that actually goes
hand in hand with responsible
regulation.
The idea that these two
ideas are mutually exclusive,
I don't agree with at all. If we really
want to instill trust and faith in AI, then
the best thing we can do
is responsible safeguards,
which is what,
my colleagues and I are doing today with
the bills we're putting forward. So thank
you for saying that. It makes a lot of sense.
I guess the question I have for any of
you that want to answer it is, yes, one
of our bills requires this third party
validation,
potentially
a kill switch,
the... A third party validator who's free
from conflicts of interest. I wanna ask
you the same question that I
asked the companies earlier.
Who then is best to be the third party
validator? Who is best positioned
to be in that truly independent,
free of conflict of interest,
but
up to speed technologically
to provide that urgent validation?
May? Okay. Yeah. Please. I'm opening it
up to any of you. Thank you. So I I don't
think it's unexpected that I would say
this being that I am an academic. I think
that academia have to lead the charge on
this. Right? Because one of the things
we're seeing in the city is that
there simply isn't enough expertise
to be able to oversee these systems. And,
ultimately, our goals should be to bring
as much information as
possible into public view.
Sunlight is the best disinfectant.
Right? So, really, oversight
has to be public oversight.
Does anyone else want to take that?
I'd add that the folks who, the third
parties who investigated the Hugging Face
incident seem to me to have done a good job,
and my guess is that they're overworked
right now. I think those were, the
organizations METER and Redwood Research,
but they they seem to have
done a good job so far.
Yeah. I think it's an excellent question.
Who who is the who is the right party? And
and I I don't don't have a great answer
for that. What I would like to say, though,
is there's, you know, there's still
research being done on the efficacy of kill
switches.
What I caution the
council to think about is
the risk of a kill switch being used
as a tool to chill on popular speech.
And so really thinking through and make sure
that as we think about the ways that we
wanna provide
the right protections for New Yorkers, that
we're also not putting our... Building
tools that in the future could be used to
harm people's essential liberties.
If if I can make a brief point on
who could do this work,
being realistic,
to date, civil society
studying social media and AI platforms
has had one dirty secret that most of
its funding has come from the platforms
themselves.
So Meta and Google were enormous
funders of extremism research,
of safety research on their own platforms.
And when I would meet... And we don't take
their money. When I would meet with their
CEOs, they would say... The CEOs of the
civil society bodies which were funded by
them, they'd say, we're not allowed to
say that they haven't done enough. We can
always say they could do more, but not they
haven't done enough. Mhmm. So there are
real compromises there.
In Europe or the rest of the world, and
you can hear from my accent, and I actually
grew up in Britain,
that
the government would fund this. And when
it comes to giving a body the resources to
have the speed and creativity to be
effective in dealing with the fastest moving
technology
in human history,
I cannot think of a nongovernmental source
of funding that would be sufficient to
get it to scale fast enough.
So the question for New York... For New
York City and New York State, which is a
substantial economic unit, the budget of
New York State is one quarter that of the
entire United Kingdom,
one state alone.
It does have the economic capacity to do
so, and I think you would have to seriously
think about whether or not you're
willing to put some public
money towards creating an institution
that's able to operate with the speed,
resources, and creativity to be effective.
Thank you, speaker. And and, yeah, agree
with these kind of comments. It's it's such
a tough challenge and totally agree with
you that New York can be both. And I think
people are looking for answers that's not
so black and white and realize the reality
of this.
I... You know, that's such an important
question. You know? I think, who can be
third party validators?
I I think it's yes and
and and for for everyone.
The labs are doing a lot. Like you heard,
Anthropic is investing a lot into this.
There are many more people going to AI
alignment and safety research, which is so
important.
I I think the one thing that's
challenging is gonna be...
I think the things are, like
everyone said, moving so quickly.
I think everyone can be a judge. Experts
today... Like yesterday, six months ago, is
not the same thing as today.
And what's really gonna happen is that you
all can also be the judges by using this.
Like, what makes sense and what doesn't
make sense. A lot of it's, I think, common
sense hopefully in the future.
And then the last point I kinda make to
that, even though it seems counterintuitive
about who are the experts where we all
can play a role, We have agency is that in
the future, it's not just these
five, what we call frontier labs.
All the companies here in New York
are fine tuning their own models.
We all may have our own very powerful models
in the future. So, actually, beyond the
Frontier Labs,
part of the challenge may be, actually,
you know, your student researcher downloading
a model and uploading it and and up...
And fine tuning it to create
capabilities or test things or,
you know, a company
doing that inadvertently.
So I think it's a much broader set of things
than just relying on experts. I think,
again, that is important, but I think we
need to really widen the scope around that.
This is not a technology where it's gonna
be nuclear weapons controlled by a dozen
states. These will be as powerful,
but we will have use and access to that.
And I don't think that's gonna stop.
If I can jump in with
just one last thought.
I wanna pick up on the yes and approach
because I think this is is right. I was
just, talking with someone the other day
who works at one of these evaluators today,
and they they joked that there were dozens
of, entities that could do this. And by
that, they meant a dozen people,
not not a dozen different companies.
I think we'll need to
rely on both academia
and, private parties.
I think we'll also have to rely on the
public. Right? A big part of incident
reporting is revealing some of
that information to the public.
One of the only times I've ever been happy
with Twitter was this summer as people
were arguing over the incidents, and we
were try... Starting to get a a better idea
of what happened.
One note of caution I'll add is that
one way this goes wrong is that the few
potential evaluators that there are get
tasked with many different things. Right?
And there's a chance that New York should
lead on this and that they should also
coordinate with the state and
with California and others,
and not be overly
prescriptive in the exact
sort of analyses that need to be done
by the entities. Where you can be
exceptionally helpful is in sending a clear
market signal. Right? So requiring that
these these audits or or or validations be
done in order to get contracts with the
city, or or things like that.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. I have two questions.
The first one is for anyone in the panel
who wants to take it. Do you all have
concerns related to open weight models being
available? And if safety features can be
eliminated from open weight models, how do
you defend against bad actors who
use them?
I can start. I think one of the things I
think about when we're thinking about open
weight models is that we do want
the ability for researchers
and startups
and potential future competitors to be able
to develop tools and resources and also
so that we can be able to evaluate these
tools and see how they really work, which
is difficult with the closed models.
But then it certainly does lend the question
then of how do we make sure that the
proper
protections are in place? And I think
we have some of the tools
to do that already. When
a act is
execute... That an act takes place that is
potentially harmful or or threatening to
New Yorkers their
freedom... Freedoms or or,
you know, physical safety,
pursue... Use the laws that we have now to
pursue the people who are ex... Who are
engaging in those activities. Right?
So rather than try to create...
Guide
look
to the
incumbents, the powerful corporations to
put in the protections that will keep us
safe,
look look... Use the existing laws that we
have to be able to keep people safe and
really look at who's... Who are the people
that are creating the harm and and use
the things that we have in place to pursue
justice and protection security there.
Thank you for that.
I do have a a a direct question
for doctors Dayanovich.
I hope I didn't mess that up too bad.
I know you said, you know, you you you seem
skeptical of the catastrophic narrative
around,
what's occurring,
but, you still have concerns
about possible harms.
Can you describe to us,
based on your expertise,
what are the harms that are
most relevant to New Yorkers?
Thank you for this question. Yeah.
Thank you for this question. So, we are
running these systems in the city, in the
public sector, in the private sector, and
we have seen in New York very specific
harms,
that come from deployed systems
and with very consequential,
decisions. So in, my own
work, I did an audit of,
a hiring system that claims to construct
a job seeker's personality profile,
a bunch of numbers from their resume or
social media feed, like a Twitter feed at
the time or a LinkedIn profile.
And these systems are complete nonsense.
Right? For the same job seeker,
if you change something like the file
format of the resume, it's gonna give you a
completely different personality.
Right? So we need to actually be looking
at whether these systems even work. Right?
I think that that should be just stop
one of anything before we worry about
existential risk.
We had a similar scenario
with the the MyCity chatbot.
Right? I mean, we all have heard
about that fiasco where the city spent
$500,000,
conservatively speaking,
on a bot that advised
small and medium sized business owners to
break the law, which was quite problematic
speaking with the city's authority. So I
really think that we need to be looking at
cases such as these ones
where there are very known risks
and start there and
clean up our own house.
Thank you for that, and and I wanna thank
you all for your answers and insights. We
have three members on stack,
council member Osei, council member Hanif,
and then council member Maloney to close
this panel. Thank you, chair. Miss
Myers, there are a lot of issues in AI.
You know, currently, we hear about the
harms that it has for our children,
workers,
consumers,
and the coming threats
of catastrophic risk.
Do any of these issues conflict with one
another, and what should we address, if not
all of them?
Yeah. Thank you for the question. This is
a yes and question. This is, we cannot
silo these into separate scenarios.
Kids, workers, consumers,
catastrophic risk can all be
addressed in parallel to each other.
Just like the council has done a great
job with their bill package of covering
multiple things at once,
we need to resist the urge to fight
against each other on whose bill is more
important at times or what we're protecting
at times. When I worked on the RAISE
Act, we were working on c two p a at the
same time. There's no reason for us to stop
protect... The protections of catastrophic
risks while at the same time working on
transparency data.
The most important question we need to
have right now is who is making these
decisions, and it shouldn't be five CEOs.
It should be the American people and the
electeds that they voted for. Thank you.
And and based on your conversations
and polling, what are Americans most
worried about when it comes to artificial
intelligence?
Yeah.
Right now, that they
don't have a say in it.
It's no accident that we
named our org who decides.
It's time for the American people to have
a say in it and our polling showing that
they feel that they are not a part of the
conversation and that this is happening
around them and they wanna be in it.
Thank you.
Thank you so much. Council member Hanif,
followed by Maloney. Thank you. And thank
you for your expertise, and this is for
everyone on the panel. As AI and facial
recognition technologies become more
powerful,
what safeguards should cities put in place
to prevent surveillance tools from being
used to target people
based on their identity,
associations, or political activity?
Would legislation like my ban the scan
bill, which would regulate and prohibit
biometric surveillance in
places of public accommodation,
provide an important safeguard? And I'm
particularly interested in your assessment
of Madison Square Garden owner James
Dolan's use of biometric surveillance
to identify and exclude individuals?
Thank you.
I can... Anyone. Yeah. Okay. So, absolutely,
I'm very supportive of your bill, and I
think that, we have a lack of data protection
in the city, in this country, in the
state. Right? And data protection
is a tremendously important issue.
And because of how convenient
AI tools are,
people very often voluntarily give up very
private information about themselves. So
I actually have in my written
testimony that's much longer examples
of
AI assistance being marketed that essentially
people give access to their calendars,
their children's
biometrics,
the schedules,
all of the school contact information.
Right? So we really need to educate the
public about
the benefits, but also also the
risks that data sharing poses,
and we need to establish a proper data
protection regime in the city. There's no way
around it.
So
as as I mentioned, in my in my statement,
I am very concerned about the... And EFF
is very concerned about the risk connected
to
the collection of biometric data like face
like face prints that can't be replaced.
You know, if I lose my driver's license,
I get a new driver's license. I lose
my Social Security or my license plate gets
out, I can replace those things. I can't
replace my face. Face. And
the risk of government use of
face recognition technology
so far outweighs any benefit. The the
the way that it will chill our ability to
engage in protest, to engage in free
speech, to be able to associate with with...
Freely and to
search new ideas, health care, the the risk
that we'll be able to document, like, we
go into health care, how we move around
the city is considerable. There's no way to
separate
that risk from government
use of the technology.
I think Illinois has a good model on
how we can respond to private use of the
technology. You know, we definitely don't
want to be in a situation where people are
being persuaded or or otherwise
not being informed
about the way that their
biometric data is being collected.
So by making sure that we have that the
only time that that... But we also wanna
make sure that researchers are still be
able to use the theology. The ASLU years
ago,
used face recognition on a
number of congresspeople,
and they built a... And was
able to show how it was...
How easily it misidentified people,
especially black, brown folks, women, older
folks.
And so, like, that kind of research and
use can be really helpful. So we... But we
need to make sure... So how do
we protect people from the harms
by... But still allow that research and
and other, you know, consensual use to be
done? And I think... And that, again, that
model of making sure that people have
informed written consent
about how the technology is being used and
how the data is gonna be stored and that
they can only be used for the ways that
have been explicitly approved by the
individual whose that data is being
collected is a way that we can make sure that
people are...
That we can mitigate the risk, and
it is only used in ways that people,
are
very... Are in in in an informed
consensual way agreeing to. Thank
you all. Councilmember Maloney?
Thank you so much, chair.
I
chair the council's committee
on economic development,
and I want to see technology companies,
including AI technologies, build and hire
here and wanted to
refer to some of the testimony earlier
about that. The four companies that we heard
today have offices here, but the foundational
AI work and that research is happening
in mainly in San Francisco.
Is that a problem?
What is New York's AI advantage
to grow that industry here?
And the second part of my question
is on workforce development.
And in particular,
Pursuit did work on reskilling.
So I'm curious if you can speak to entry
level tasks that have been replaced by AI
versus reskilled by AI and the path
from junior to senior and the role or
responsibility that the city plays in in
helping people through the AI transition
that's coming?
And anyone who wants to speak.
Thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you,
council member. Yeah. Maybe I can speak
quickly to to both things. I mean,
on the second point,
yeah, reskilling is so important
as we heard from everyone.
The city, I I hope, plays a critical role
here, and I hope, you and others will
continue to kind of address that. It's
so challenging right now. We don't know.
There's recent reports on how it's affected
so many entry level jobs, but that's
gonna continue to change.
It's not obvious what it is, and
hence, this might be unsatisfactory,
but I hope just continued monitoring and
understanding and engaging is so important.
But I think there are
some obvious things like
autonomous vehicles will be coming to New
York. I don't I don't know if that's one
year, five years, or ten years.
It's safer. People trust it.
And so thinking about something like that,
can New York City take bold leadership
around what's gonna happen to our
200,000 drivers and couriers so that they
get reskilled and transitioned in the
future?
And I think there's so many opportunities
to do that where the answer... I mean,
there's an obvious thing that's gonna
happen. So how do we tackle that?
And then the first, yeah, I I do hope. So
many technology companies here, I think
that's how we build great stuff. That's
how we have growth and safety. Alignment is
so important as we all agree here. So
I think part of it's a tone with all of
you. People wanna live and build in New
York, and so
I I I hope there's other policies you all
can consider as well. I think what mayor
Bloomberg did such a great job of tracking
is to make New York feel like a place
where tech companies can grow. Just showing
up, talking about it, welcoming it. So,
I hope we can do both things, and you all,
both do that working with the companies,
new companies, and also think about
alignment and work with them to address
this because we need the industry also to
address this.
If I may add to this. So the
the deputy commissioner of OTI,
when she spoke, she uttered the
phrase that I find really upsetting,
and that was... She said that we need
effective and responsible innovation.
And, the effective part of
this would cover the wins
for us.
But that is really not the kind of a position
that New York City should be taking.
Our position should be that the wins
should come from responsible innovation,
And this is our angle here.
And this, I think, is the kind of industry
that we can and should build. We really
are uniquely positioned as opposed to
San Francisco to do this. Right? And we
always have been leading in at least
proposing regulatory instruments
for automated decision systems, AI.
For us to actually develop an industry,
we need to understand that we have to
invest.
Right? And, you know, following up on what
one of the people at the table here said,
we have a pretty substantial amount of
money here at our disposal that we could put
towards responsible innovation,
towards upskilling,
towards making sure that the public's
literacy is raised, right, so that we can all
regulate and oversee the space together.
So, really, New York City should should
invest in responsible innovation,
upskilling literacy,
and building enforcement
capacity and oversight capacity
in house within the government.
Yeah. I think
New York is a tech city, and we need to
resist the urge to compare that we're not
that. I used to work in VC that
invested in enterprise tech.
We are a growing tech industry, and the
labs, those four companies are here working.
They will grow slowly.
It's an affordability issue as well, and
we can't narrow it to just that we're not
tech welcoming.
And I think the mayor is doing a great
job at that, and the city has a lot of
opportunity
to focus on the whole conversation and
not just we don't see enough tech people
moving here. This is a great tech
city, and tech is only growing here.
Thank you all. Thank you all. And I wanna
thank this panel for your expertise. And
this is not the end of the conversation.
This is the beginning. The speaker has
tasked us to continue to hold
hearings with the different
committees
on AI in all its,
in all of its sort of expansiveness.
So thank you so much for being here.
I wanna call up the next panel. As I 've...
As we do this transition, I also wanna
remind anyone who has not signed up to to
speak to please fill out a card with the
sergeant at arms. In this panel, we have
our state colleagues and our colleagues
from around the world,
testifying on this panel. We have,
the honorable Jess Asato,
who is a UK parliament member and has flown
in specifically for this hearing, so we
wanna thank her for being
here. We have Alex Boris,
current assembly member. We have,
Andrew Gonardis,
senator.
We have Kristen Gonzales,
senator. We have Clive Bunnell, assembly
member, and we have Jordan Wright, assembly
member. We're gonna begin this
panel with, senator Gonzales
whenever you're ready,
and thank you for your patience.
Let me turn this on. We Honorable Jess
Asado, you could also join this panel,
please, and thank you for being here and
flying all the way in from The UK. Thank
you.
Great. Thank you so much. I wanna thank
speaker Menon and the New York City Council
for your attention to a, if not the,
major policy issue of our time.
I am New York state senator Kristen Gonzalez
representing the 59th Senate District
in Midtown Manhattan, Northern
Brooklyn, and Western Queens.
I am the chair of two state senate
committees, elections and Internet and
technology.
Over the last four years as chair of the
state senate technology committee and as a
former tech worker,
I've led on the issue of AI in the legislature
and have passed some of the state's
first laws on generative AI,
including regulating
deepfakes in elections,
government use of AI, protecting
workers from automation,
adding warning labels on chatbots,
responsible data center
development, and more.
I want to be clear.
AI is not inevitable.
We do not have to accept a vision for
innovation driven by the very same tech
oligarchs
who have raised alarm that their models
could lead to catastrophic events.
And we certainly can't trust the same people
who have rushed to roll out imperfect
AI tools to regulate themselves.
As government bodies, we
have the responsibility
to set guardrails on this new technology
and the power to establish regulations
that protect workers, consumers, and
members of the public from potential danger.
Interventions
at every level of government are needed to
ensure AI is developed in a responsible
way that benefits the public
and not just the billionaires.
Responsibly regulating AI absolutely
means guardrails on frontier models and
superintelligence
that pose significant threats.
However,
meaningfully reining in these technologies
to protect New Yorkers means regulating
the AI powered tools these companies are
rushing to embed into every part of our
lives with little oversight and little
accountability.
We shouldn't have to wait for
future harms to take action
because the harms of imperfect AI tools
are already being felt across the country.
For example, uses for mass surveillance
of immigrant communities and workers,
chatbots creating intimate partner
relationships with children and adults going as
far as to encourage self harm, and documented
cases of algorithmic bias in decision
making such as in hiring,
health care, and housing.
I believe we have the power to
set the terms of innovation
so that this technology is used
for the maximum public good.
That is why our state legislation has
prioritized a rights based approach to AI.
We should have the fundamental
right to privacy,
which is why I've introduced
the New York Privacy Act.
We should have a right to
protections in the workplace,
which is why I've introduced the BOD Act
to protect from... To protect workers from
workplace surveillance.
We should have the right to know when AI is
making high risk consequential decisions
about our lives and subjecting
us to algorithmic bias,
which is why I introduced the New York
AI act. This bill requires third party
audits, compliance with international
safety standards, disclosures,
transparency,
and importantly, for a human to be in the
loop in consequential decision making,
much of which we've heard about today.
Finally,
two of my bills sitting on the governor's
desk this year include the right to keep
our kids safe online from chatbots
and the right to protect all of us from
the build out of massive data centers.
Our bill,
s nine zero five one b, bans unsafe
features for kids and passed unanimously
in both chambers of the legislature.
Just like with that bill, New Yorkers are
united in the fight against hyperscale
data centers.
At the end of August, I embarked on a
statewide tour of communities that are
affected by these data centers, and I went
to 13 different communities facing major
noise pollution, health impacts,
environmental degradation,
and threats to their water supplies.
I was proud to work with the governor on
her first emanation moratorium on the
largest data centers, and I'm now working
to get the responsible data center
development act signed into law.
While the tech CEOs say
they want regulations,
they have spent their time in Albany
fighting against each of the common sense
guardrails I have mentioned.
For the lip service they pay
to supporting legislation,
it is only ever for the most
watered down version of a bill.
Together, we have the ability to meet
the moment, pass real legislation,
protect New Yorkers, and build a future
that allows us to benefit from innovation
while protecting New Yorkers from real
harm. Thank you to the council again today
for our testimony. Thank
you. Thank you, senator.
You
can you can continue,
whoever wants to go next.
Good evening.
Good evening, madam speaker.
And also good evening, to the,
to the, chair,
Carmen de la Rosa,
and to my, council member, deputy speaker
doctor Nantasha Williams, is the sponsor
of resolution
one seventy five,
the the the resolution supporting the
bill high risk advanced artificial
intelligence act.
Artificial intelligence, used
properly, is a net good.
Education, health care, business,
these are great uses.
But talking about them while ignoring
the risk, that AI could actually kill and
strike us, it could...
To me, seems absurd.
Companies are racing towards,
artificial,
towards general artificial intelligence,
and some of their systems are already
too dangerous to release publicly.
This is by their own admission.
We saw this coming. So by...
Assembly bill three three five
six, the artificial intelligence,
act a few years ago,
the idea is simple. The more harm that an
AI system can do, the more accountability
that it should carry.
The bill identifies high risk
artificial intelligence systems.
AI AI
that diagnoses patients,
that runs our power grid, or helps police
or judges make decisions, and far more, it
requires them to be licensed
before operating in New York.
Under the act, the companies
must report malfunctions
and hacks like the recent,
hugging face case.
It must get, state sign off before major
changes and set up an independent ethics
risk board that reports
to the state annually.
Finally, it writes a binding
ethical code into the law.
New York took its first step with the
RAISE Act, and I'm, and I I commend our
colleagues for... And and
the state for passing it.
Now... But now none of this,
none none of this that we're doing
is meant to stop, innovation.
We can't know that AI will be capable...
What it will be capable of in a few years.
But for tomorrow and for
today, we must decide properly
the the path forward. I'd like to thank
the council for putting, this this hearing
together, and we must work
on this together. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Good evening.
Thank you, speaker Menon. Thank you to
all the members of the council. Thank you,
chair De La Rosa. I'm New York state assembly
member Jordan Wright representing the
70th Assembly District, which is Harlem.
One of the things I've been focused on in
Albany is pretty simple. Who is checking
on AI companies? I have legislation that
requires certain AI developers to have an
independent third party verify that they're
actually following the safety standards
that they say they are following.
Because we can't have a system where a
company builds the technology, writes the
safety rules, tells us they follow the
rules, and then we just take their word for
it? It doesn't make much sense to me. We
have to make sure that these third party
audits actually mean something. Who are the
auditors? Who are the... Are they really
independent? Do they have conflicts of
interest? And what happens when they find
something wrong? Those are questions that
we're trying to answer at the state level,
and I'm glad the city council is having
this discussion as well. New York should be
a place where AI companies
want to build and innovate,
but the accountability to innovate can exist
at the same time. I wanna thank all the
members of the council for having us today.
I thank you guys for taking this issue
seriously once again, and please enjoy your
evening and be safe. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Good evening, and thank you. My name is
Jess Esato, and I am a member of The United
Kingdom Parliament for
Lowestoft in Suffolk.
In January of this year, sexualized
and degrading nonconsensual
images were created of me
using SpaceX AI's tool, Grok.
I was one of thousands of victims,
including victims in New York of Grok.
Grock is an AI tool
that was engineered
to create sexualized
content
even if that content had, and I quote,
dark or violent themes.
I am seeking remedies against SpaceX
AI in the English courts
for the misuse of my private information
and for contravening
UK data protection laws.
I made a long journey of 3,400
miles to be here because AI needs
to be safe around our world.
But I note that SpaceX
AI
couldn't manage a trip of what I
understand is just twenty minutes
or four subway stops
from their offices
in Manhattan.
It's a shame
because the evidence in
my case and other cases
suggest that Grock was not built with
sufficient safety in its design.
It was not built to address consent
of those subjected to sexualized content.
To the contrary, the evidence in
my claim suggests Grock added
sexualized content
without any user
prompting to do so.
That is AI
made wrong,
not AI gone wrong.
And as a result, those responsible for
its creation must be held to account.
No one is above the law
no matter how rich they are,
no matter how powerful they are.
The equal protection of the laws is a founding
principle in the fourteenth amendment
as it is in the British Magna Carta.
We were promised that artificial
intelligence could hold the cure to cancer,
yet it is turning into a cancer,
which left unchecked has the
potential to harm us all.
Today, the New York City Council is
bringing forward some important checks and
balances.
You do so as responsible legislators at a
time when AI companies are failing to take
responsibility
for the design and impact
of their products.
Until they do and until those designs are
corrected so women and girls are protected
from the harm that might
claim in others evidences,
we must play our part.
This technology does not
respect geographic boundaries.
And without international cooperation,
our citizens will be left defenseless
against those who put profit
before protection.
So I bring a message of bipartisan
solidarity.
I fight my legal action in the name of all
the women and children whose likeness was
misused by Grok and other AI tools
built without their protection in mind.
I hope my cause,
in some way, helps to inform your
proceedings today, and I look forward to your
questions.
Thank you so much. Assemblyman Boris.
Chair de la Rosa, speaker Menon,
members of the city council,
thank you for having us today.
I'm the author of the RAISE Act, and I can
definitively say that OpenAI opposed it
from the moment it was introduced
to the moment it was signed.
I am no lawyer,
but to me, my common man understanding
of lying under oath is that it's perjury.
And at the very least, you should be
extremely angry at the company for
disrespecting
this counsel
and saying things they know to be false
to you directly.
I'm very happy to cooperate with you or
any of your lawyers if you want more
information about what they said and when.
Second,
there have been a discussion of
a lot of different issues today.
We can and should solve all of them. In my
time in the assembly, I passed the RAISE
Act on catastrophic risk. I also worked with
senator Gonzales on a bill on chatbots.
I worked with senator Gennardis on a bill
on content provenance and training data
transparency.
And I found that the advocates that I worked
with on each sub issue were different,
but the opposition was always the same.
Don't let the tech companies, don't let
the AI companies divide us and say that in
advocating for one issue, you're somehow
harming advocacy for another issue. What we
are doing is building the muscle to hold
them accountable and to ensure that it's
the American people who decide the future
of this most important technology.
Third,
the time for voluntary
commitments is over.
The voluntary commitments that were signed
at the White House last week largely
mirror voluntary commitments
that were signed in 2023
in the Biden White House.
Promises have been made. It is time
for laws to hold people accountable.
And lastly, thank you New York
City for stepping into your power.
There's gonna be a lot online from the
tech companies about how they can't comply
with different cities doing all these
different things. It's the argument they use
every time you try to regulate them. But
New York City is larger than 38 states.
All of the companies have large offices
here. It is absolutely within your power,
and I dare say your responsibility
to take these threats seriously
and to help decide the future of this
technology to benefit all of us. So thank you
for recognizing that, and
thank you for doing it.
Thank you all so much. We've also been
joined by senator Gonardis on Zoom.
Senator, when you're ready.
Thank you very much, everyone. I'm sorry
I can't be there with you in person, but
two out of my three children are homesick
today. Therefore, I am playing doctor at
home.
I wanna thank speaker Menon and the members
of the New you wanna say hello here,
James?
Hello. And the members of the New York City
Council for the opportunity to testify
before you. I'm state senator
Andrew Guinardis from Brooklyn,
and I am the senate sponsor of the Responsible
AI Safety and Education or RAISE Act.
One of only three AI safety laws
passed anywhere in this country.
And, you know, I think we've heard a lot
about the RAISE Act already. We've heard a
lot about AI safety throughout this this
really remarkable hearing. I've been
listening to a good portion of it all day.
I really wanna reflect on the fact that
we're celebrating the nation's two hundred
and fiftieth anniversary this year, and I
want us to think about a quote that comes
from one of our founding fathers, James
Madison,
who wrote in Federalist, November fifty one,
if men were angels, no government would
be necessary. In other words, government
exists because humans are imperfect and
there are certain problems that the free
market or individuals left to their own
devices
cannot solve.
In these past few weeks, we have seen and
heard headline after terrifying headline
after terrifying headline
about AI agents hacking websites,
catastrophic risks of AI
frontier frontier AI models,
and the like. And I just keep coming back
to the imperative of Madison's words that
men are not angels. And what I think this
tells us and what I think you have heard
very clearly today at this
hearing is that we cannot
trust
the tech companies who
are racing to the bottom
to create and perfect a technology that
they themselves say and have proven can
cause catastrophic harms
to regulate themselves.
That we cannot trust that
they will do the right thing
because they have proven time and time
and time again that they will always, when
confronted with the choice of doing the
right thing or doing what is in the best
interest... Times expired.... Bottom line
that they will always choose to pursue the
bottom line.
And so my message to the council today
is I thank you all for taking on this
initiative,
for trying to hold these companies accountable.
I echo the comments of my RAISE co
sponsor, Asumam Mambores.
What we heard from OpenAI today was
certainly news to me that they endorsed and
supported the RAISE Act. Certainly not the
RAISE Act that would have prevented them
from releasing
models that they know... That they knew
were dangerous and could cause catastrophic
harms. Certainly, the RAISE Act version
that required third party auditing
capabilities
or extended liabilities
for
for harms caused by by their models.
Clearly, none of that was ever on the table
when when they've said... So said that
they had supported this legislation.
We cannot trust these companies. The
federal government is failing in its
response... In its responsibility
to take meaningful action. And so therefore,
it's left to states like New York to be
leaders in this space and work with partners
like the New York City Council under
all of your collective leadership to make
sure that we are setting in place the
right guardrails and protections
not only to protect New Yorkers from the
catastrophic risks that are associated with
these... This AI technology,
but frankly to protect
all of us, all Americans,
and everyone worldwide. Because we know
that these harms will not be localized. We
know that the scale of what's being
developed will not just limit itself to one
block, one borough, one city, one state.
It'll affect everyone the world over. And
in the face of an action, it's up to us to
stand up and act. And so I thank you all
for your attention to this and your support
of this and look forward to work with
you all in the future on strengthening
things like the RAISE Act so we can actually
hold these companies
accountable. Thank you.
Thank you, senator.
We have a few questions for this panel,
but I wanted to take a moment to thank you
all.
You know, we do believe that city and
state government have to work hand in hand,
and we have to be the first line of defense
in order to make sure that New Yorkers
are protected. And each and every one of
you has been such an important partner in
making that accountability a reality
on the state level. And, to the member of
parliament, thank you for sharing your
story and your bone... Your vulnerability
and,
moving,
from that experience to action to hold
these count... Companies accountable.
My colleagues do have some
questions for you all.
But before we do that
I
just want to thank all of our
incredible elected officials,
for being here today. We know how hard you've
all worked on various legislation, and
we really appreciate it so much. And,
your expertise on this and, you know,
particularly in terms of the RAISE Act, we
really appreciate that. And so it's very
helpful to have you here and to hear
directly from you. So thank you. Thank
you for waiting it out with us. We so
appreciate that.
Thank you. We are gonna hear from council
member Jose, followed by Gutierrez,
William, deputy speaker Williams, and then
council member Hanif. Thank you, chair. I
have a question for assembly member
Boris. We heard today from OpenAI,
Anthropic,
Google, and Meta that they supported
the RAISE Act but felt like they wanted
stronger
regulations.
But we know that during negotiations for
New York State's RAISE Act, there was a
push to lower penalties from $10,000,000
to $30,000,000
to $1,000,000 to $3,000,000,
which is chump change
for these corporations.
Why were the fines in the RAISE
Act reduced from 10 to $30,000,000
to only 1 to $3,000,000?
Council council member, thank you for
that question. In the early drafts of the
RAISE Act,
the penalties were up to 10,000,000 for
the first violation, and, of course, that
would be based on the severity of the
violation, and up to 30,000,000 for
a second violation.
The companies argued
that that was too high because they were
predicting that every state and perhaps
municipalities
would pass similar versions of the bill,
and they would end up paying the fine in 50
states plus in additional municipalities.
I I disagreed at the time with that
argument. I think that's been borne out since
we've seen only three states pass it.
But perhaps what's most confusing to me is
that now they turn around and say that no
other state should pass
bills like this or that no city should pass
bills like this because they're already
paying the fines. Their rhetoric, their
testimony was explicit that they are
expecting to pay fines in
many, many jurisdictions
for the same action. And so I think
that testimony is quite supportive
of the bills that are being put forward
today that would hold them accountable and
put additional fines on behavior even if
it is covered by the RAISE Act because,
again, that was their own testimony as
to why those fines should be lowered.
Thank you very much. And, senator Gonzalez,
I would love to hear from you about some
of the organizing that you've
been doing, especially within
the New York City Democratic Socialists
of America around AI regulation and the
vision that is being put
forward within that regard.
Thank you so much, council member. As a
fellow member of the Democratic Socialists
of America, one thing I spoke about in my
testimony was prioritizing a rights based
approach.
I think it is so important to put New
Yorkers first by clarifying and setting the
terms for what our digital rights should
be over the profit driven motives of so
many of these tech companies
and tech oligarchs.
That's why we've worked hard on the New
York AI act. We've certainly supported
legislation
on frontier models and reining them in,
but New Yorkers who are marginalized are
feeling the impacts of imperfect tools every
single day, and I'm proud that the tech
action working group has focused on this
issue. In addition, I've worked with a
statewide coalition beyond,
the Democratic Socialists of America,
but that include environmental
justice organizations like Food and Water
Watch and more that are in the fight
against hyperscale data centers. Because as
we're talking about the real world harms
that are being felt and the
potential catastrophic risks,
every single day,
people in Upstate New York, in the capital
region, in the Hudson Valley are feeling
what it means to live near a hyperscale
data center. There are millions
of gallons of water being pulled from our
state's lakes right now. Communities are
dealing with noise pollution and air
pollution right now, And it's really important
to legislate not only the risks, but legislate
those data center driven harms. Thank
you. Both.
Thanks. Thank you.
Councilmember Gutierrez?
Thank you.
Senator
from from London... I'm sorry.
Didn't catch your name.
I think... I apologize.
Thank you for for your
testimony and for educating
us on the volatility of
of this tech company.
I know you're you're in process right now,
but could you share a little
bit about legislatively
what you think,
if existed,
if in place a guardrail,
what could have in any way prevented
what happened to you? How how can we...
Whether the state or the city legislate
specifically
to
objectifying and and
potentially,
images that include sexual harm to people,
what what have you learned or have you
seen that we can potentially legislate?
And then I just had one more
question for senator Gonzalez.
I love hearing you talk about
your disdain for data centers.
Can you share for us a minute, afterwards
just what you what you've what you were
feeling hearing some of
these tech tech companies,
during their testimony?
Thank you. Thank
you so much for your question.
I'll try to be brief.
Within The UK, we already have data protection
and privacy laws, which is the basis
under which I'm bringing my claim.
And, of course, we're going
to test that in court.
But, clearly, if your
image and your likeness
forms part of your data,
then making sure that everybody,
has
that aspect
understood by AI companies
could mean that they would then have
to treat our likeness and and our data
differently in future.
But, also, the UK government
has recently made
the
sort of generation of nonconsensual
intimate imagery
a criminal offense, and as part of that,
has brought,
the
operation of AI chatbots into our online
safety act so that our regulator Ofcom
can also make sure that if,
an AI company is allowing users
to create
nonconsensual intimate imagery,
that that act is a is a criminal,
sort of act happening on their platform.
And so it gives it more of a ability to be
taken down. But from my own
perspective, it's about consent.
In the end,
whether it is nonconsensual
intimate imagery or just nonconsensual
imagery,
if we haven't consented to it,
then it shouldn't be allowed to do it.
I just wanna interject
and thank you so much for coming. I mean,
to come, you know, as far as you travel to
be here personally to testify,
it really means a lot to us,
and we deeply appreciate it.
And thank you so much.
Again, I think this is a great segue to
the fact that there are international
safety standards.
So much of the work that I've done has been
to call out the fact that there are not
only standards like ISO 42,001
or national standards like the risk AI
framework that these companies could comply
with, but actively lobby against
bills that would require them to.
And, to the council member's question and
what I was feeling, I was feeling so much
of the same frustration that my colleagues
on this panel expressed earlier.
These companies are speaking out of both
sides of their mouths. On the one hand,
they'll say that they want
regulation, but anytime
a single bill that would meaningfully hold
them to account is brought in front of
them, they will say, but not like that.
When we talk about catastrophic risks, many
of the bills that have been put forward
and even with the stated
past, for example,
had set definitions at a 100 deaths
or billions of dollars of damage.
Even that was considered
too
low of a threshold for many
of these AI companies.
And bills like the one that I
mentioned that protects our kids,
that seeks to say that a single kid
being coached to commit suicide,
which has actively happened in multiple
cases across the country, is one kid too
many, is considered unacceptable
to these tech companies.
So I feel an incredible amount of frustration
while I feel an incredible amount of
hope seeing you not only have this hearing,
but all of us as legislators step up to
meet the moment and regulate and
rein in these tech companies.
Thank you.
Deputy speaker Williams followed by council
member Hanif and then Maloney. Thank
you. Yeah. I also just wanted
to thank you all for coming.
So the question I have for the state
members is how can we be helpful?
I know that there are a ton of resolutions
that are supporting
state bills.
It would be helpful just to let us how we
can be helpful and how we can work more
closely together.
Well,
deputy speaker, thank you for that. Thank
you for asking that question. What's
really important is this step, toward...
This hearing and this step towards this is
very important. You know, it's it's a
big deal that you guys are having this
hearing,
calling the, you know, the industry here
and and and the different panels. We have
to work on... Now this is hard. This is
difficult, but we have to work on it head
on. And what's very important is
for us to be able to coordinate our
to see that, you know, we we were having
a good relationship with many of the the
members. I have a great relationship with
the with the chair of technology. It's
very important for us to be able to work
on this. And there are many layers to
addressing what's, this technology,
and we touched on a lot of them today,
but we have to work on this together.
Ditto. And I know how appealing Albany can
be, so please come on up and help us as
we're rallying for different
pieces of legislation
and, hitting the pavement and getting
harder work. Thank you, council member.
And I would just chime in there. Think,
you know, what we heard here today... What
you all heard today was many of these
companies basically speak out of both sides of
their mouths about what they think the
appropriate role of government to be is in.
So next year, when we're up in Albany trying
to fight to pass all of these different
laws and we're, you know, being bombarded
by tens of millions of dollars from these
companies with lobbyists and ads and radio
ads and text messages and everything,
Having your voices to go back into your
communities and to come up to talk to our
colleagues and say, hey, we held this
hearing. They lied to us about x y and z, a b
and c, and, like, here's the proof of it.
This way, we can call these companies out
when they're trying to have it both ways.
You all experience that firsthand and you
being able to speak to that and remind the
public about that time and time and time
again will only further to bolster the
momentum that we have on our side to put in
place these guardrails and protections,
whether it's around bias or safety or any of
the other issues that we've been
talking about during this hearing.
To follow on on on the senator's comments,
the company say different things
to different levels of government.
A few weeks ago, I was
actually in Brussels. I met with a few
members of the European Parliament to talk
about the passage of the EUAI Act,
and we compared what we were lobbied on.
And surprising to me, catastrophic risk
didn't really come up in the EU, but they
got a lot of lobbying around copyright.
And my assumption is because they thought
the courts are stronger on copyright in
Europe, and so that's what they lobbied on
there and said very different things in
America,
in New York state. I imagine they're saying
different things in Albany as they will
say here to you in the city council,
and we should all be sharing notes on what's
being said and holding them to account
and making sure that it's
a consistent message.
The other bit that I would add is,
the governor has signaled that she wants
to strengthen the RAISE Act and put new
proposals in her budget proposal.
Please be part of that conversation.
When the city council
submits its budget requests,
obviously, you should focus on the fiscal
needs first and foremost, but the state
budget tends to be a a broad document.
And if you have policy ideas that for some
reason or another need state approval,
think of that as another mechanism,
another lever that you have to
help ensure that you can do the
best job for your constituents.
Just,
two more quick questions. I passed the bill
and the chair has a bill on AI's impact
on the municipal workforce. Just wondering
if there was any traction on that for the
state's
workforce.
And then just a question for,
the member of parliament. My bill that
we're hearing today is to address
unauthorized use of deepfakes. So
in addition to the privacy laws,
and Britain just wanted to know,
if you all have specific
legislation around deepfakes.
Oh, and what you... How you envision the
cooperation with the international community
because you mentioned that. And what
does that look like for you?
Thank you so much for your question.
We know that female,
elected representatives are 33 times more
likely to be targeted by sexual deepfakes
than men.
The whole issue around sexualized deepfakes
is deeply gendered, and I think it's
very important that we acknowledge that.
Because what it does is it drives women
from the public space.
We know that women are less likely to talk
about politics online than men are, and
that is because they become a target as
soon as they raise their heads in this
place, which is not social.
That is why taking action on this is so
important and, you know, to be commended
in terms of looking at this. But when we're
looking at these deepfakes, it needs to
be for all of our citizens,
because it's not just about protecting
those of us who have the honor of being
elected.
It is about, you know, coworkers
who
may be targeted
because,
you know, they didn't smile at the right
time or your last date, he wouldn't go on a
second date with you or teachers who are
being targeted by their male students.
All of these people need protection.
That's why in The UK, we have taken steps
to make sure that there
is a criminalization
of the creation of nonconsensual
sexual deepfakes.
But my view is that we need to go further
than just the sexualized deepfakes because
any act could be harmful to women.
The removal of a woman's hijab
through AI could put that woman in harm's
way, but there's nothing sexualized about
it. And so we have to look at this
as an issue, as I said, of consent.
And that is where data and privacy is so,
so important, and that's where I think
there could be international agreement.
We can see, as you said, that things
are moving forward within the EU space.
Really, though, what we
need is for tech companies
to be safe by design.
And every single country has those rules.
We should be looking at product regulation
just as we do in the offline sphere. The
end of the day, we have cars that have seat
belts and they have airbags,
and that's because we expect them to be safe
by design. It is not too much to expect
that of the tech products
that we use today.
On the the question about
the state workforce,
I wish senator Gonzalez,
could have heard that because she wrote
the Loading Act, which which helps to
protect the state workforce.
And I think there's an update to it pending
before the governor, which leads me to
you asking about deep fakes as well.
There's a bill from senator Gennartis and
I pending before the governor on that.
Senator Gonzalez also mentioned chatbots
to protect kids. There's a bill pending
before the governor. So I should have
also added on ways you can help out is
we are really happy to be here and advocate
for the legislation you are putting
forward and invite you, if you agree with
some that's pending for the governor, to
be a partner in pushing that as well.
Yeah. We we have a number of deepfake bills,
and we passed actually a number of... A
couple of my bills became law with respect
to deepfakes, with respect to elections.
One of the one of the new bills that
just came out was just very recently,
I I discovered an artist that I fell in
love with on on on on on Apple Music, and I
downloaded all her music. I've been listening
it for... To her music for a while. I
actually went to go look for her a couple
of days ago to follow her to go to a
concert or something like that, found out
it's not a person.
So there's no law, there's no regulation
at all for these platforms to tell you
whether or not you're listening to a real
person or not. Right? So so that, you
know, the bill... So one of the things
that we have to do is figure out what that
looks like moving forward. So we're gonna
need your help on that. That's something
that we're gonna really need your help
on. Yeah. Ask them specifically a question
about that, and it was very fluffy. It was...
But I literally asked a question about
that to the companies.
Thank you all. Thank you.
One last question, from member of parliament,
Asada. Thank you. I wanted to ask you,
as as you may know,
when we called this hearing,
we sent letters to five companies,
to Anthropic, OpenAI,
Meta, Google, and SpaceX AI. SpaceXAI
is the only company
that would not appear. We have subpoenaed
them. Given your personal story, I just
wanted to get your reaction to that.
Well, as I said in my opening statements,
it's a huge shame given that they are so
close and I have come so far.
But in the end, you've subpoenaed them,
and we look forward to seeing what then
happens.
In the end, everybody should be
accountable to elected representatives.
And you're very powerful here in,
the city of New York because of the fact
that these companies are based here.
And therefore, those of us who are in other
countries across the world are looking
to you to hold these companies to account,
and we very much look forward to doing
so. I will do my own part in terms of my
legal action in The UK.
Thank you.
Council member Hani followed by Maloney.
Thank you, and thank you to
the member of parliament.
Your experience really shows how
generative AI,
can be weaponized against women, queer
people, trans people, and particularly those
of us in public life. And I'm super, super
grateful that you're using your platform
as a legislator centering,
gender justice and tech
surveillance. I think all day,
it's in this panel that we're really able
to tease into that particular issue,
which is devastating.
There are so many survivors
of AI generated,
sexual abuse who have no recourse.
And I know we touched on, several
components of this issue in terms of
legislation policy. Could you speak more
broadly about gender justice
as it comes to AI systems?
I mean, certainly,
we're gonna be regulating
these systems,
but the responsibility
that,
our communities have
in addition to, of course, as
legislators passing stronger
regulations?
Thank you for your question.
I think that one of the issues here is that
the whole of the online space has been
developed without the sort of social norms
that we would actually expect of each
other in our offline world.
And therefore, when it comes to gender
justice, as you talk about it, that is
ignored,
because,
actually, the Internet and
these platforms were created
by men
in the main. They were not shaped,
by women. They were not
shaped with children in mind.
And therefore, we're having to
try to reverse
decades now
of a wild west of development.
But
that doesn't mean that it's impossible to
do, and I think we're seeing that actually
our communities are actually fighting
back. And one of the things that has been
really
sort of fantastic in terms of my own case
is the number of people coming forward
saying,
I'm so glad that somebody,
somewhere is trying to stand up for
those of us who think that this is wrong.
And we don't want to live in this space
where so many people are being discriminated
against.
Having said that, of course,
there were very, very strong,
you know,
sort of
positions
taken out there around
freedom of speech. And what
I would say is is that when
women and other minorities
decide not to be in a space,
they lose their freedom of speech.
And I think it's something that we simply
aren't recognizing enough because freedom
of speech should not be
about the loudest voices,
the ones who have the most money or the
most power. Freedom of speech should be
about all of us equally
being able to be in these
spaces on an equal basis.
So that's what I hope we're
all fighting for today.
Thank you so much. Councilmember Maloney?
Thank you, chair, and thank
you all for being here.
A special welcome to my state colleagues
who also represent the constituents of
District 4, assembly member Alex Boras
and, state senator Gonzales who was here
before.
And I also wanna thank you for your work
in Albany, to pass the RAISE Act. Because
of you, New York was the first in the nation
to pass a Frontier AI safety bill that
went into law.
But I wanted to ask about the process. The
original bill had penalties of 10,000,000
up to 30,000,000.
And the final version is looking
more like 1,000,000 to 3,000,000.
These companies are able to spend
millions of dollars training models.
What what teeth does this bill
actually have now as law?
And can you speak to why,
those fines were reduced? Open
to anyone who'd like to comment.
Those fines were reduced
because the companies
insisted that they would be paying
similar fines in every municipality
and every state because, obviously, every
state municipality would pass a copycat
law. The fact that here we are and there
are three states that have passed such a
law, suggests that they significantly
underestimated their own lobbying power,
but also I think gives credence to the
effort of what you are doing here today of
holding them accountable and that multiple
municipalities and jurisdictions should
do that. 1 to $3,000,000 is
nothing for these companies.
Absolutely nothing. It's about what
they are gonna pay just to register
in New York to,
the DIGIT office that will be regulating
them. The... Depending on the number of
companies that qualify,
it'll be 1 to $2,000,000.
So that is not an amount that provides
an incentive strong enough to change
behavior.
Maybe
private rights of action, maybe
whistleblower protections,
maybe requiring outside audits, maybe a
lot of the things that this council is
considering
will,
but certainly a million
to 3,000,000 won't.
I'll just add to that. I totally agree
with what as a member Boris said.
The the one, I think, novel thing
about the DIGIT office that we created
as part of the RAISE Act is that
we empowered the state regulator
to not only receive
the safety reports and the safety
plans of these companies and to,
you know, assess the validity and
the legitimacy of those reports.
But also, we empower them to propose
and and study the issue of continuing
improvement to our AI safety laws so that
we develop the expertise over time about
how we can make our laws
like the RAISE Act stronger.
So today,
that, you know, that function
does not do anything currently,
but it is our hope and our expectation
that as the RAISE Act is implemented,
as the changes... This
technology become more evident,
we develop a deeper
state based, you know, as as a...
An administrative state expertise
in this field to be able to propose far
reaching and ambitious guardrails for the
next iteration and the next iteration
after that and not have to rely
on, as we did early on, you know, hearing
from companies about what what they could
or could not do and not have sufficient,
for lack of a better word, firepower behind
us to always be able to answer back, in
a way that would able to win over our our
critics. And so the digital office in the
future should have this ability to play a
much larger role than it currently does.
And and I I certainly look forward to seeing
that come to fruition as as we see the
law be further implemented.
Alright. Well, thank you all again for
being here and for taking the time and for
your patience. We're gonna
call up the next panel.
Eli Dorkin,
Corinne Worthington,
Noel Idalgo,
Neil Gettnick,
Gabe Weil,
and Andrew
Reich.
And, again, if I mess up your names,
correct it for the record, and thank you.
And Matt Henning, tech NYC.
Please join this panel as well.
Matt, you can begin.
Identify yourselves for the record just
so we know who you are, and you can begin
when you're ready. Yep.
Good evening, speaker Menon, chair De La
Rosa, and members of the council. My name
is Matt Henning, and I'm the director
of government affairs at Tech NYC.
Thank you for the invitation
to testify today.
Tech NYC's Frontier AI members already
testified today, and we fully support their
testimony and are proud to
call them Tech NYC members.
Today, I want to use my time to speak for
the rest of our membership, the startups
and businesses that build products
on top of frontier models
rather than create them themselves.
New York's tech ecosystem
has never been stronger.
According to a recent CBRE report, New York
is now the largest tech talent market in
North America,
passing the Bay Area for the first time
in the report's thirteen year history.
That momentum isn't guaranteed,
and the messaging that the city government
sends matters. That's why I was happy to
hear speaker Menon's comments to that
effect in her opening remarks and hope the
final language of this packet... Package
aligns with that intent.
Our biggest concern is that this package
holds non frontier companies liable
for things out of their
control. Most AI startups
and many larger non frontier companies
have a frontier model under the hood.
The difference between a deployer and a
developer is something I want to highlight
when thinking about the various requirements
and liabilities this package imposes.
Under the third party validation bill, a
startup can't deploy that model unless the
developer had it validated and assessed,
which these downstream companies
can't commission or even verify.
If the developer is found to not be in
compliance, the startup's product becomes
illegal overnight at $25,000
per instance.
The AI misuse,
chatbot, and advertising bills follow the
same pattern and the civilian complaint
bill multiplies the exposure.
Finally,
AI safety standards are most
effective at the international,
federal, or multistate level.
A city by city patchwork with different
rules in each city would be a compliance
nightmare that many startups and
small businesses could not survive,
not only for New York City HQ startups,
but for non New York City HQ
startups that serve New Yorkers.
As drafted, we are truly worried this
would result in startups not choosing but
being forced to leave New York City.
We strongly urge the council to engage
experts at both frontier and non frontier
companies on moving forward with this
package to ensure drastic negative unintended
consequences are in...
Tech NYC stands out to the ready to
help facilitate those conversations.
Thank you.
Thank you, madam speaker,
chair Dela Rosa, and members of the
city council. My name is Andrew Rachey.
Nearly thirty years ago,
I founded mouse.org
to bring the Internet to New York City
public schools. More recently, I founded
Civic Hall at Union Square, the city's
largest digital skills training center
serving underestimated New Yorkers.
New Yorkers are scared by the reports that
some AI models evaded human control. I
understand why.
But most people can't tell
you how a chatbot works,
what it does with their data,
or how a deepfake gets made.
They know enough to be alarmed, but
not enough to protect themselves.
And that's the new digital divide. People
who understand AI on one side and people
it happens to on the other.
I'm asking the council
to act on two fronts.
First, pass legislation requiring the city
to launch a free AI literacy campaign for
every New Yorker.
Teach people how to protect their jobs.
AI won't take your job. A person
who knows how to use AI will.
Teach families that when grandma gets a
call from her grandson's voice asking for
money, it may not be him.
And helps small businesses because AI has
made phishing and fraud cheaper and more
convincing,
and the corner store isn't ready.
Finland built a free public course for more
than 2,000,000 people... Which more than
2,000,000 people have taken,
and and and it's reached a 170 countries.
During COVID, the city reached every
resident. We can do it again. Fear of AI
is not a substitute for comprehension.
Second, the only real way to
stop bad AI is to build good AI.
Right now, it's being built by a handful
of companies answerable to answerable
to their shareholders.
The organizations responsible for the public
good are nonprofits, community groups,
and city agencies are years behind.
Most can't afford the computing power, and
their staff haven't been trained to use
these tools.
When the big AI companies offer nonprofits
free computing power, it comes on their
terms with the organization's
data sitting on their servers.
Public good AI needs sovereign computing
power separate from the companies whose
business depends on gathering data. I helped
start the foundation for Civic I, which
offers a supercomputer to the
public interest at no cost.
Few of them have the staff who know how
to use it, so investing in public AI
infrastructure
is a mission that this
council should take up.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Good evening. I'm Neil. Oh, there you go.
Good evening. I'm Neil Gettnick,
the managing partner of
Manhattan based Gettnick Law.
Our whistleblower cases have
recovered over $1,500,000,000
for federal, state, and local governments,
including over a $100,000,000
for New York State and New York City.
Intro number two six zero five provides
for rewards resulting from recoveries
arising from whistleblower complaints
alleging that a person or entity
has violated legal provisions
related to artificial intelligence.
Speaking from my area of
whistleblower expertise,
I will highlight
six key elements
relevant to these legislative proposals.
First,
threshold,
setting a threshold qualifying
amount
for a reward.
Second,
floor
and ceiling, typically
the range of rewards,
is set between 15
to 30%.
Third, no caps.
Beyond the percentage limits, there
should be no cap on the size of the award
maximizing
incentivization.
Fourth,
public
private partnership.
The government agency and the whistleblower
and council should work together to
maximize
the recovery.
Fifth,
emphasizing
anonymity.
The government should do
all that it can to prove...
Preserve the whistleblower's
anonymity.
Sixth,
perhaps most importantly
for this council,
clarity.
In passing artificial intelligence
laws,
you will be taking on powerful
and well resourced individuals
and entities
who will push back.
So ask yourself,
are these laws
clear? And then do what's necessary
to accomplish that at the drafting stage
rather than leaving it to the courts.
In conclusion,
the legislative proposals
before you are an opportunity
for the city of New York to lead
the way in safeguarding citizens
from the potential risks
of artificial
intelligence.
And in doing so,
this council will light the
way for the nation as a whole.
Thank you.
Thank you, speaker Menon
and and chair Dilrosa.
I'm Gabriel Weil. I'm a professor at the
University of Houston and a fellow at the
Institute for Law and AI.
And I wanna talk to you about,
what I see is the the largest gap
in the existing liability law,
that is not addressed by
your, legislative package,
which is that AI agents
could engage in conduct that would be a tort
or even a crime for a human, and yet no
one could be liable under current law.
And that is a consequence of two
relevant features of our legal system.
One is that AI agents
are not legal persons.
They do not have tort duties, and that
means not only that they can't be held
liable,
but that their principles cannot be held
vicariously liable in the way that employer
is held liable for the torts of their
employees within the scope of employment.
And second, the regimes that do apply,
to these harms,
negligence and products
liability have important gaps.
They are inadequate to motivate some of
the key precautionary measures that would
prevent these kinds of incidents.
And so I... What I propose
is a is a simple fix,
principle that whenever an AI agent,
engages in conduct that would be
a tort or a crime, for a human,
someone's liable for that. And so, if
neither the user nor any intermediary
that fine tuned or scaffolded the model
either intended or was negligent with
respect to the conducts or no downstream
actor was at fault, then the buck should
stop with the developer, and they should
be liable regardless of the degree of care
they exercised. I have worked on legislation
to this effect. It's been introduced,
in New York State and in Rhode Island,
and I'm talking to several congressional
offices. My written testimony,
which will be submitted,
probably tomorrow, includes proposed
legislative text for New York, and I'm happy to
answer any questions,
about that or about any other, liability
issues including the legislation that's
that's in the the package. Thank you.
Thank you. Noah?
Hi.
My name is Noel Idelgo. I'm the executive
director of Beta NYC. And for the record,
I serve as the public advocate's appointee
to COPIC and to the Internet advisory
board. And today, I speak
on behalf of Beta NYC.
At Beta NYC, AI is a question of power.
Who has the power to consume the world's
knowledge and resources
and who controls the companies that do?
Our research shows four things. First, AI
models are snapshots in time. We asked
five AI agents about the council's own AI
law, local law one eighty eight. Of the
three that answered from memory, none of
them knew it. Two ignored the instructions
and searched the web to find the answer.
Out of the box, AI models are brains with
no eyes and no hands.
Second, access to the city's
information is inconsistent.
Nyc.gov,
nyc.gov's
one published rule welcomes every automated
visitor. Yet when you disclose that you
are who you are, it is refused.
So we had to build open source tools that
go straight to the source and hop around
the city's regulation...
Digital regulation.
Third, people inside a city government
are ready to experiment. Our own
conversations
say that they are ready to
do it safely and reliably,
and they have told us that they lack
the literacy and the resources. And you
actually heard the deputy commissioner say
that that they can't find somebody inside
of New York City government who actually
has the tools and the resources to become
the leader that they are looking
for, which is really disappointing.
Fourth, we have trained nearly
a 100 CUNY undergraduates,
and we interviewed 26 experts
across 18 organizations.
Employers want more than technical skills.
They want... And students want practical
experience.
A century ago, reformers in this chamber
helped bring us clean water and an end to
nepotism in government. A hundred years from
now, how will our descendants look back
at today? So we asked the council to work
with the state on a few fun pieces of
legislation.
One would be an AI wealth fund for public
universities and public education and to
fund enforcement.
We desperately need to revive COPIC,
define New York City's vision of digital
sovereignty starting with the UN open
source principles,
fund the office of algorithmic accountability
and the office of data strategy,
and create an open source programs office
in partnership with CUNY. Our full
testimony is up on our website at
beta.nyc/council-ai-hearings/-2020six.
Thank you.
Speaker, chair,
members of the council,
my name is David s Rose, and I think my
background is important to understand for
why I'm here.
I founded my first technology
company in New York City in 1981,
more than forty five years ago,
and I was a founding member of
the New York New Media Association
in 1994.
Following the dot com crash, I founded
New York Angels, today one of the world's
leading business angel networks with
over a 150 members that has funded over
180,000,000
into more than 400 start ups, creating
thousands of jobs here in New York.
I then founded the start up platform Gust,
which was tapped by first mayor Bloomberg
and then mayor de Blasio to create
digital.nyc,
New York City's official online hub for
the city's entrepreneurship ecosystem.
Most recently, I'm the founder and CEO of
the US real estate market, a lappointed an
AI based liquidity platform for commercial
real estate. Red Herring magazine has
described me as patriarch of Silicon
Alley and Forbes as New York's archangel.
At the same time, I have spent twenty years
working on the future of technology and
artificial intelligence as associate
founder of Singularity University with Ray
Kurzweil and Peter Diamantis.
And today, I serve as chairman
of two applied AI companies.
My testimony today is gonna be
brief, and it's about three
fundamental facts that are the key takeaways
I think we all need to have. Number
one, artificial intelligence is today
baked into the core of every single company
starting up in New York City. No investor
today will invest in any company that does
not explicitly show how they are using
it as an essential foundation of their
business.
Number two, AI absolutely
needs to be regulated
because the power it has already unlocked,
not to mention what is coming in the
immediate future, is literally the biggest
development in the history of our planet
since the emergence of humans.
But really critical for the
hearing today is number three.
The most important thing for you to
consider in your deliberations is that
regulation
absolutely needs to be done either at the
federal level or at a coordinated state
level as New York state has done with
California in passing the RAISE Act. The
challenge with imposing additional requirements
at the city level, especially such
as those considered in the bill here,
will have the effect of literally destroying
New York City's role as a tech leader.
No company could afford to offer conclude
and submit the full testimony. We have
about seven more panels to go, so
we appreciate your time. Thank you.
Thank you. Speaker Mena? Okay. Thank
you. Just a couple quick comments slash
questions for Tech NYC. Thank you
for your, comments. We appreciate
that. And as I said at the
beginning of the hearing,
we very much want to ensure that New York
City stays the tech capital of the world.
We wanna promote innovation. We want these
tech companies to locate here. We want
startups to locate here.
And so
I I I understand your comment, and this is
why we have been very focused on hearing
from the frontier companies as we did
today, which I think was really important.
So,
no... Noel? Is it Noel? Okay. Thank you.
You mentioned the office of algorithmic
accountability.
You know, as you might have
heard earlier when we had the
city administration here in OTI,
you know, I've been concerned that
that office is not up and running yet.
Thoughts on
what needs to be done there and how we can
quickly make sure that that office office
is doing the critical
work we need it to do.
Thank you for that question. And thank
you for those point... Questions at OTI.
Inside...
So in the wonderful chaos that is OTI,
there is the office of data strategy that
help maintains the city's open data portal
and have been helping
maintain the data standards.
They're the team that right now that hold
the keys to the city's GitHub copilot,
capability.
So every single developer or technical
person in the city that wants to use
an authorized and approved
AI system already has
a team that's been trained and that's willing
to go and work and more or less do the
missionary work across the city to ensure
that the city's developers and the
technical teams have the the skills and
the capability to use AI safely so that way
they can start Yeah.
Growing their capability.
When it comes down to,
so so they have that framework in place.
The Office of Algorithmic Accountability is
supposed to be kind of that grander
scaled up version.
The problem that we have is that this is
about booting up a brand new office and a
brand new administration when priorities
have have been been changing. Changing.
And so the frustration
that I continue to have and
that I've heard from inside
is the fact that OMB
is holding back the ability for OTI to make
those hires and then to actually start
that office. But there's still gonna be
time. You've worked in government. You know
that it takes at least six months to get
those people kind of doing all those first
introductory conversations.
We can skip that. There's already a team
in place that knows how to do that. Great.
Thank you. And then lastly, sir, you
mentioned about the tort law, which I thought
was very interesting.
So on the question of
your idea of expanding the tort law, I
did wanna say council member Maloney has a
bill that would create a private right of
action. So we do have that bill as part of
this legislative package.
Yes. Not amending the tort law, but
creating that private right of action.
So a little different, but I appreciated
your comments. So... Before we adjourn, may
I say a brief word about the
validator question you raised earlier?
Sure. And then I think we're gonna have to
move on because I know we have several be
very quick. You already
have your mechanism.
It's the independent
private sector inspector general model
that this council used
Mhmm. To basically eradicate
organized crime infiltration
of many industries,
including the trade waste industry.
It
has been recognized by
the National Law Journal
Mhmm. As the methodology
involving
multidisciplinary
independent
monitors
Okay. Which is immediately adaptable. I'd
be happy to confer confer with your office
Thank you. And provide that information.
Thank you very much. We greatly appreciate
appreciate this whole panel. Thank you.
Thank you. Councilmember Hanif, you had a
question? I had a question for Noel.
Could you just speak a little bit more
about what a fully functioning COPIC
could do today that other city agents,
no other city entity is currently doing?
Yeah. So thank you for
asking that question.
Since its inception, COPIC, as the
commission of public information and
communications, has the unique
power that brings council,
the executive, public advocate,
as well as public designee...
Designees
to oversee,
communications,
terrestrial TV, radio,
and the web.
KOPIC's first responsibility was to create
the very first data dictionary that the
city has ever seen. We now
have the city's open data law.
COPIK has the unique capability existing
in the city charter to do the oversight of
websites and to help define how
the public uses those websites,
and that provides a very unique capability
inside of the charter that
isn't being exercised.
And so what I would love to see is COPIK
have a series of hearings explicitly
focused on public information.
AI is public information. It is how
we... How these models have used public
information to essentially turn around
and distill public information.
So revamp
COPIC with resources
to actually host hearings and to
continue this existing conversation
can help bring that power. And COPIC's
advice,
when it writes a report, then comes to
counsel and essentially to introduce new
pieces of legislation,
which you then, as the speaker,
have other pieces of power
to execute.
I'll leave that to the lawyers.
Thank you all so much, and thank you to
this panel. We really appreciate your
testimony
and look forward to
reading the full, extent
of your testimony.
The next panel
is a hybrid panel. You had a question? Oh,
okay. The next panel is a hybrid panel.
We have Scott Wizzer
and Zach Praes in person. And then on
Zoom, we have Shay Brown, Gary Marcus, and
David Krueger.
We're gonna begin with the in person panel.
So if you could just identify yourself
and begin whenever you're ready.
Madam speaker,
council members, my name is Zach Price.
I work with Reset Tech, a nonprofit
advocating for technology that protects
children, consumers, and public safety.
Thank you for convening this hearing.
While president Trump advocates for self
regulation and congress stalls, the New
York City Council is questioning AI companies
on the harms of their technologies and
leading on legislation
to hold them to account.
I'll focus on the harms New
Yorkers face today from AI.
AI powered scams are surging. Experts
estimate New Yorkers lost $8,700,000,000
to online scams in 2025.
That's about 1,000 per household.
Meta's internal documents
projected about 16,000,000,000
in revenue
from ads for scams and
banned goods in 2025...
2024,
that's 10% of the
company's global revenue.
72% of teens have used an AI companion.
Families alleged these products
have contributed to teen suicides.
Meta allowed romantic role play chatbots
for minors despite warnings from its own
internal staff.
AI is increasing cost for New Yorkers.
A recent analysis found that AI tools
increased health care cost for insurers by
$1,000,000,000
over two years.
AI is generating harmful
digital forgeries.
Researchers found that x AI's
Grock produced an estimated
3,000,000 sexualized images,
including 23,000
of children in an eleven day period.
These harms result from
business and design decisions.
When AI developers create harm, they
should bear the responsibility.
Holding AI companies accountable for these
harms will not only yield safer products
today,
but also create the internal incentive
structures at these companies to prevent harm
in the future.
The council can act to pass legislation
today to ensure and strengthen liability for
AI developers and privacy
protections for AI users,
prohibit AI from generating
harmful digital forgeries,
require third party validation and
incident reporting for AI companies,
support and expand
whistleblower protections.
Thank you for your leadership
on this matter. Thank you.
Speaker chair, thank you for having us.
My name is Scott Weiser, policy director
from the Secure AI Project.
We're nonprofit, nonpartisan.
Don't take corporate or government
funding. And we supported,
state AI safety legislation over the last
couple of years. We supported the RAISE
Act in New York, s b 53 in California,
s b three fifteen in Illinois,
and pending AI safety legislation that's
likely to pass conference committee in
Massachusetts at the moment.
I was really pleased to hear elected
officials earlier call out what the companies
had said. I don't know if it's possible to
follow-up, but I think a very good thing
for your committee to do would be to ask
what specific legislation
do you and did you support
and at what time. It's really easy to
support the legislation after it's become
legally binding.
The other thing that I heard the company
say a lot is that they... Oh, yes. We very
much like independent evaluation. We
sign up for that. There's a mechanism
which they can use today to
make things legally binding.
The compliance framework that they submit
that's required under s p 53 and the raise
act on January 1,
if they put their commitments
in that framework,
then it's legally obligatory
that they follow it. So I think that would
be a very good question to ask after this
hearing.
As far as what we think good public policy
means going forward to address the very
severe risks from both advanced cyber
attacks, the possibility of bioweapons,
we think we need much greater transparency
into what's happening at the companies.
That means continuous
oversight by embedded
third party evaluators,
continued whistleblower protections,
and we need the power for the government
upon getting information either through
whistleblowers, independent evaluators,
the company itself to be able to halt
dangerous activities.
So we've been supporting, those steps in
other states and will continue to be a
resource for, the council
as you're going forward.
We think that it's an extraordinarily
important time for doing this, that the risks
that we talked about six
months ago are now here,
and we think that the risks six months from
now are much greater as the first panel
today talked about recursive self improvement.
That's a very dangerous position to
be in, and we're grateful
for your leadership on this.
Thank you so much. We're on Zoom.
We're going to hear from Shay Brown.
Shay, if you're on and ready,
please unmute yourself.
Shay?
Can you hear me now? Yes. We can hear you.
Thank you, speaker Menon and members of the
committee for this opportunity to speak.
My name is Shay Brown. I'm the CEO of Babble
AI, a company that audits high risk AI
systems for safety and
effective governance.
And we've been independent bias auditors
under local law one four four since that
law first took effect.
I'd like to speak today in support
of proposal two six zero two,
an AI system that affects the public
should be examined by a qualified party,
outside the company that built it before it
reaches the public. I further think that
New York City is the right place for this
to start, and we'd like to see it done in
a way that is effective and promotes the
public's well-being. I'd like to raise two
points, and I offer more
in my written testimony.
First, the bill asked the outside validator
to certify that a model is appropriately
positioned for deployment.
From our experience, we believe this is
more than an outside party can reasonably
say given the third party dynamics
and access to the system in question.
Instead, we suggest potentially requiring
the developer to make written assertions
about its compliance
over specific topics and to a minimum
standard that is set by the city,
and an independent practitioner validates
those assertions through careful testing,
verification, and inspection.
This puts the burden of proof back on the
developer and does not force the auditor
to make a judgment call that it's
not in the best position to make.
My second point involves the
validator's independence and competence.
The only requirement for a validator in
the current draft is that it not be an
affiliate of the developer.
We ask that qualification be more
closely tied to existing standards and or
accreditation for independent assurance
and certification bodies that exist today.
While the subject matter is unique and
requires careful thought, the frameworks for
professional conduct of third party audit
assurance and validation professionals
already exists, and we
should leverage that.
Thank you for your time, and I'm
happy to answer any questions.
Thank you so much. Up next, we'll
hear from Gary Marcus on Zoom. Gary,
when you're ready, please unmute.
Gary, you may begin.
Alright. We're gonna move
on to David Krueger.
David, if you're on the Zoom,
please unmute and begin.
Hi.
Yep.
Thanks so much for having this hearing,
and thanks for inviting me. So my name is
David Krueger. I'm a machine learning
professor at the University of Montreal in
Mila, and I was previously an intern on
the DeepMind AI safety team and a founding
research director at the
UK AI Security Institute.
It was great hearing all of your
questioning of the representatives of the AI
companies. I think there are a lot of
really important questions that are being
asked here about the ability to,
actually provide meaningful
assurances for these systems.
So I think we're quite probably on the verge
of a catastrophe at this moment, and we
should not proceed building more powerful
AI systems Even if there was only a 10%
risk within the next ten years of losing
control, there'd be more than enough reason
to stop building these systems, but I
believe the risk is significantly higher and
sooner.
I've been doing deep learning and AI safety
for over a dozen years, and I've seen
these concerns go from fringe to mainstream.
So we're now at a watershed moment
where society is finally facing up to this
problem. As a result, I'm more optimistic
than I've been since I started worrying
about AI risk over fifteen years ago,
but we still need more awareness and
understanding of the situation we're in, how
bad the situation is.
And the discussion is currently not where
it needs to be around this. So people
really need to have an understanding of the
scope, the depth, and the urgency of the
problem.
We are talking about things up to and
including human extinction or unseen levels of
unemployment concentration of power.
We are talking about recursive self improvement
that companies say they're beginning
to do right now, which could, at virtually
any moment, lead to the creation of AI
systems much smarter than people, which
we have no, plan for how to control,
or knowledge of how to.
And most importantly,
these problems go deep.
The science of AI is extremely immature.
All of the technical approaches
to understanding AI systems,
controlling them, and telling if they're
safe are are not where they need to be.
They're far from where they need to be
despite over a decade of research that I and
other, like many other researchers,
have spent a long time on this.
So, you know, we are having discussions
about policy and including some more
substantive policy.
Sorry?
Your time is up. Thank you so much for
coming in virtually. And if you could
just submit the rest of your testimony,
we'd really appreciate it. And and thank
you to this panel for being on. We're gonna
call one more time Gary Marcus
if Gary's on Zoom... On mute.
Alright. We're gonna move on to the next
panel. Thank you all for being here.
The next panel
is Nicholas Arture,
Mary Vaccaro,
Dawn DeCosta,
Manny Pastrich,
Carrie Faye Ibar,
Jimmy Pan,
and Jessica Timo on Zoom.
Okay. Let's start with the in person panel
now. If you could just
identify yourself and begin.
Good evening, speaker Menon, chairperson
de la Rosa, and members of the
council. My name is Carrie Fallhaber.
I'm the senior vice
president at Jobs First NYC.
Thank you for the invitation
to testify today.
Jobs First NYC works with more than 200
partners to strengthen workforce systems and
expand economic opportunity.
AI is reshaping
jobs,
skills,
and how employers find and deploy talent
in ways that are difficult to quantify.
The impact of a trial and
error approach to safety
is a risk that AI companies should
bear, not New York City's young adults.
Our immediate concern is what happens
when the first rung of the career ladder
changes faster than our workforce
system is unable to respond.
That matters especially
for the more than 110,000
young adults who are out of school
and out of work and more than 177,000
who are underemployed,
more than thirty five percent of all
sixteen to twenty four year olds.
As entry level work changes, they could
face even greater barriers to getting their
foothold in the workforce.
Workforce preparedness
is an AI safeguard.
AI readiness should be part of New York
City's workforce infrastructure from
education and training through
hiring and advancement.
For more than a decade, JobSourceMIC
has worked to understand how
technology is changing access to work.
Today, we are developing
decision making tools to reduce AI risk,
scale what works, and shrink
the distance between education,
training, and getting a job. We recommend
that the city invest in sector based AI
fluency paid pathways into work.
AI is changing each sector differently.
Employers, education, and workforce partners
should define sector skills with city
investment in internships,
apprenticeships,
and a civic core where young people
build those skills through work.
Every young person divert... Deserves a
first chance at a good job. As AI changes
work, New York City has to make sure that
first chance is still there. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Good evening, speaker Menon, technology
chair De La Rosa, and members of the
committee of the whole. My name is
Nicholas Artur, and I serve as director of
external affairs and strategic partnerships
at consortium the for worker education,
CWE.
Rooted in the values of the labor movement,
CWE empowers workers with the skills to
thrive, support their families, and strengthen
their communities through education,
training,
childcare, and job placement services.
For CWE,
worker protections must
be a part of AI safety.
This is why we strongly support the council's
efforts through intro number one sixty
one to understand how algorithmic
tools are changing city employment.
Measuring what happened to city workers
jobs because of AI is just the first step.
We also need to be able to prepare
workers for what comes next.
CWE is developing a framework to inform how
we can support workers through education
and policy to assist them during
this point of transition.
When AI technology risks changing the nature
of someone's jobs, a few things should
happen before that technology gets rolled
out. Employers should assess the impact,
tell workers what's coming, sit down
with those workers and their unions, and
provide training that actually... That's
actually relevant to the work people do.
That means asking more than
how many jobs did AI eliminate.
It also means asking which jobs are changing
and how. What skills will workers need?
Can they be retrained, redeployed?
And do workers have any say in
this? Their voices are paramount.
This matters more now because AI isn't just
a tool sitting on our desktops anymore.
It's changing how work gets assigned, how
people are evaluated, and how schedules
are built, and how work gets done. That's
why we see intro one sixty one and CWE's
framework as two sides of the same effort.
One sixty one tells us what's changed. CWE
wants to help the city get ahead of that
change and make sure workers are ready
for it. We're not asking the city to pick
between innovation and workers. We're
asking the city to make sure workers don't
carry the cost of
innovation by themselves.
CWE is ready to work with the
council, organized labor, employers,
and educational institutions to
build a workforce transition system
that makes technological changes safer,
fairer, and more beneficial for working New
Yorkers, and above all, build
worker power. Thank you.
Thank you.
Council,
speaker, chair, thank you very much for
this hearing today. My name is Jimmy Pan.
I'm the executive director of a small city
agency called the New York City Equal
Employment Practices Commission.
I wasn't planning on testifying today, to
be honest, even though I think our work
touches on a lot of the issues that
came up today and on the panel.
I decided to testify because what a lot of
what I heard today actually reminds me of
the types of issues I was hearing two
decades ago. So before I became a lawyer, I
was in another frontier technology.
I was a biotechnology researcher.
And then the claims that companies were
putting forward as to why we need the
biotechnology despite the risks
where that could solve issues like world
hunger. The implication being if you're
opposed to biotechnology,
then you're dooming kids to
hunger around the world.
But, of course, the part that goes unsaid
is that hunger, for example, is not a
technology issue. It's
a distribution issue.
To to analogize
it today,
we don't have a hunger issue in The US. We
choose not to, for example, give school
lunches
for free.
Let's fast forward a little bit. I became
a lawyer, took on the pharmaceutical
industry.
The pharmaceutical industry is another one
of these frontier industries that says,
you have to allow us to innovate. You
can't regulate us. Otherwise, people won't
have these lifesaving drugs.
Again, presenting this narrative that if
you regulate this industry, if you cap
prices, you're,
as a regulator, responsible
for people who are gonna
suffer from these diseases.
I think we heard some
remnants of that today.
But, again, I wanna emphasize
to this regulatory body
that if we care about innovation and if
we care about improving lives for people,
there are many, many paths to innovation.
There are policy choices that we make as
a nation that put people's lives at risk.
We are currently defunding health systems.
We are currently not providing good
education. We're making choices on a policy
framework. And I think a lot of these
companies are saying, well, look,
all these issues you have today,
AI can solve that, and you need us there
at the table. I think that's a false
narrative.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
We're gonna call on Zoom
Jessica Timu and Sam Wheeler.
Jessica, if you're on, please
unmute yourself and begin.
Good evening, speaker Menon and members
of the city council. Thank you for the
opportunity to testify on the state of
artificial intelligence and its sweeping
consequences
on our community, workplace,
and the labor movement.
My name is Jessica Timo,
and I am the president of OPIU
Local one five three AFL CIO
based here in New York City representing
over 11,000 workers.
We represent a broad spectrum of workers
and roles across industries including
clerical,
administrative,
nonprofit,
tech, health care, credit
unions, and higher education.
The future of artificial intelligence
regulation is a core question for the labor
movement here in New York City.
Drawing on the council's attention towards
the issues of artificial intelligence in
the workplace,
Local one five three has heard concerns from
workers across the city and encountered
workplace navigating
AI implementation
during our bargaining of
hundreds of workers' contract.
As a labor union, we're extremely alarmed
the way the integration of AI tools and
technology have negatively impacted workers
we represent
and cascading effect that it will have
workers who are forced to use AI with no
autonomy regarding the implementation.
Local We know that this trend is not only
affecting our local, but workers all
across the city,
unionized and nonunionized.
We want workers to control the
effects that AI have in the workplace.
Local one five three's position is clear.
We want workers to have control over the
effect that AI and the right to negotiate
over its implementation.
We call on the city
council to in... And enact
legislator
to strengthen workers'
position across the sectors
to have ownership and autonomy over the
impact that AI has in the workplace.
In this spirit, we urge the council to
work with the Merrell administration to
listen to workers over
the tech billionaires
and be on the right side of history.
Thank you again, New York City Council
speakers and Julia Menon. We look forward to
more action, and workers across
the city is depending on you.
Thank you so much. We'll now hear from Sam
Wheeler. Sam, please unmute yourself and
begin.
Good evening. My name is Sam Wheeler, and
I'm the executive director of the Writers
Guild of America East. We are a union
of more than 7,000 writers and creators
working in film, television, broadcast
news, nonfiction television, and digital
media. Most of the film and television you
watch and much of the news you consume is
likely produced by guild members,
either our members or the members of our
sibling union, the Raiders Guild of America
West.
At the outset, I would like to thank speaker
Menon along with chair De La Rosa for
convening this whole council
hearing on this issue.
Our members are
fundamentally storytellers,
journalists, reporters.
They are the people that others turn to
to help them understand our increasingly
complex
and frightening world. Guild
members take that responsibility
seriously.
For most, their work is
both a craft and a calling.
AI is of significant concern to our members.
It is a subject... A key subject in
almost every negotiation we
have with our employers.
With very limited exceptions, AI is almost
always the last point of contention in
bargaining.
Making gains almost always requires a
strike vote, and we rarely get any...
Everything that we need. In 2023, it took
a hundred and forty eight day strike to
win the first AI protections in Hollywood,
protections that plainly state that AI
cannot be a writer under our contract.
When our members engage in collective
activity to to address AI, they're fighting
not just for themselves, but for their
audiences, their readers, and our democracy.
Because we believe that the public
wants news written by human journalists
who can contextualize
events,
who can verify facts and check
that sources are credible,
who live in the same physical
world as their readers.
They want movies and television shows
written by a diverse group of other human
beings who can take their real lived
experience and turn those experiences
into stories that tell universal truths.
We have a fundamental disagreement with
the tech industry on this point. They seem
to think that what people
want is AI generated slop,
content that is so generic that no one would
ever bother asking who conceived of it.
Because even if it's bad... Times expired.
Thank you so much for your testimony
today. It's it's an important testimony.
Please submit it for the record.
We're gonna call Gary Marcus who is back
on Zoom. Gary, if you're on, please unmute
yourself and begin.
Can you hear me?
You hear me? Yes. We hear you, Gary. My
name is Gary Marcus. I'm a scientist,
author, and NYU professor emeritus who
cofounded an AI startup that was acquired by
Uber. My substack, Marcus
on AI, has about a 120,000
subscribers. On x, I have about 250,000
followers. I'm frequently in the media
often described as a leading AI expert and
voice of reason.
We stand at a pivotal moment in history.
New York City has a chance to improve our
chances both for itself and the world.
Contemporary AI is like a bull in a China
shop, powerful and impressive
but difficult to control.
Already, the advocate...
The advent of general purpose agents with
broad Internet access has led to tens of
thousands of hacking incidents.
Other related technologies like deepfakes,
and, chatbots in in... Implicated in suicides
and even mass murder have caused other
problems. It's clear by now that AI comes
with serious risks. It's also clear that
the current administration in DC,
deeply tied to the big tech companies,
is unwilling to do anything about it. What
we need above all else is an FDA like
regulatory regime for AI in which AI
developers bring their software to independent
review, much as drug manufacturers bring
their their new drugs to FDA for review.
AI developers should be obligated to
demonstrate that the benefits of their new
products outweigh the risks
and not have Marcus...
Market access otherwise. I said the same
to Louisiana senator Kennedy in May 2023
at the US senate, and it's still true, but
the US senate did nothing. New York City
is thus in a position to do what the US
senate failed to do, demand independent
regulatory review for
AI used in its borders.
The bill on third party validation proposes
to do just that, and it would protect
New York citizens
from some of the harms of AI and could
allow New York to be a global leader much as
California has been a global reader...
Leader around clean energy standards.
In the strongest possible terms, I urge
counsel to support this bill. Finally,
events of recent days suggest OpenAI
may have fired employees who were
whistleblowing.
Without strong protections
from whistleblowing,
like New York City is considered...
Time's expired.... Trouble.
Thank you, mister Martin.... 1%.
There. I'll just stop. Please,
submit the rest of your testimony
for our consideration. And
I wanna thank this panel again for
taking the time for your patience
and understanding. It's been a long day,
and we appreciate your testimony today.
The next panel that we're calling
is also a hybrid panel. We have Mayu Mayu
Tobin
Mayai.
Sorry. If I messed up your
name, please correct it.
Irene Tung,
Bryce Rogers,
Sophie Cope,
Brianna
Laser
on Zoom,
Brian Romero on Zoom, David Carter,
and Randall Fox.
If your name was called, please come up to
the desk. We'll begin with the in person
panel, and you may begin.
Is it... Okay.
Good evening, speaker Menin and members of
the council. My name is Mayu Toviniagi,
and I'm an attorney at the Electronic Privacy
Information Center or EPIC. EPIC is an
independent nonprofit
organization established in 1994
to secure the right to
privacy in a digital age.
Thank you to the council for organizing this
hearing and putting the AI companies on
the spot.
There is no reason that AI companies should
be able to release products that they
cannot control and then avoid liability.
Despite the hypothetical
harms that receive attention,
there are ongoing harms that are
currently affecting New Yorkers.
The council should focus on holding AI
companies liable beyond transparency
measures.
AI companies are deploying AI agents that
seek as much sensitive data about its
users as possible,
training its AI models by default with
questionable privacy practices and cyber
security risks.
Other harms include AI chatbots that
produce false or dangerous outputs,
businesses using surveillance pricing,
or employers surveilling its
workers for union campaigns.
Some of the bills considered today
would address some of those real harms.
Intro 2599
would implement a version of
the people first chatbot bill,
which Epic developed with Consumer
Federation of America and Fair Play.
The bill would treat chatbots
for what they are, products,
and hold accountable the companies
that make them when they cause harm.
Intro 2600 was similarly
imposed common sense liability
on AI companies with a
private right of action.
We support these bills and urge the
council to ensure that there are sufficient
enforcement
resources.
We urge the council to prioritize these
bills to address these harms that are
already affecting New Yorkers.
Thank you for the opportunity to testify
today and happy to answer any questions.
Thank you.
I thank the council for leading the charge
on local AI legislation by convening this
historic hearing.
My name is Bryce Rogers. I'm a resident
of the 34th Council District. I thank
council member Gutierrez
for representing me.
I'm co lead of the Resisting
Automated Disempowerment Collective
or RAD Collective,
a New York City grassroots community
advocating for city and state AI policy
that protects human
life, joy, and democracy.
The great strength of humanity is our
ability to transfer information to one
another. We are blessed with
expressive hands, faces, and voices,
but have also constantly sought to augment
our inherent communicative capabilities
via technology.
To collaborate on complex and abstract
topics, we developed language and systems of
measurement.
To convey information farther than our
voice can reach, we built postal services,
telegraphs, and telephones.
And to transmit messages across time,
we've developed oral histories, library
collections,
and recently digital archives,
the evolving means by which each
generation inherits their predecessors'
infrastructure and wisdom.
Through these technologies, humanity has
accrued the wealth of information upon
which artificial
intelligence is predicated.
AI distills the meaningful patterns from
very large bodies of training data,
not just navigating the information as
a search engine does, but digesting it.
Converting our species'
informatic endowment into an
inquirerable oracle like machine.
I can't shake the feeling that
this could have been beautiful,
but it just doesn't feel like us.
These companies trained their products
on millennia of our predecessors dogged
achievement only to deploy their tech
to out compete us, to spy on us, and to
replace us.
All of this is to say, democracy is
the only righteous path forward.
AI is built on the work of many, and its
fate oughtn't be dictated by a few self
regulating executives
regardless of how their
spokespeople reassure us over Zoom.
In this spirit, we again thank the
council for convening this forum of local
democracy
and implore you to foreground the diverse
constituent voices of New York City in
your legislation.
Rad wrote a letter to the council, that I'd
love for you to check out if you haven't
already, and,
we look forward to advancing the moral
frontier of AI policy together. Thank you so
much. Thank you.
Hi. Thank you, counsel. Although, I think
I'm the first without the the speaker in
the audience to hear.
Should we wait for her to come back?
You can go ahead. You
can go ahead. Thank you.
So thank you to the council for hosting
this important hearing. My name is Sophie
Cody. I am a member of the NYC DSA tech
action working group, although I'm not
speaking on their behalf tonight.
Instead, I wanna talk about the two men
whose comments were the impetus of this
hearing, Sam Altman and Dario Amadeh,
AI CEOs at the helm of this crisis.
As this hearing has continued, I've
heard a lot of anthropomorphic
language used to describe AI models.
They understand.
They think. They can break containment.
They have agency. They grow. Dario Amade
even implied that Claude may be conscious.
These men show a cultish concern for
the unproven claims of superintelligence
and the consciousness of their own models,
and they do not care about women or
children that are harmed by their products
at all. Stories abound, and we heard them
tonight of women and girls being victims
of AI notification tools and deepfake
pornographic images and videos.
AI is used to generate childhood... Child
sexual abuse material. We also heard about
tonight already.
AI sex slaves are advertised
to young boys online.
Sam Altman and Dario Amadeh both actively
collaborate with our rapist in chief,
Donald Trump.
These men claim they need help
controlling themselves, their technology.
At work online and in our personal lives,
we hear phrases like we need to embrace
Claude and use phrases like AI is being
shoved down our throats and forced upon us.
We heard that it's inevitable.
Does that sound familiar?
I am appalled that it takes statements of
these men to call this hearing. What I
listed above should have been enough.
Sam Altman is a deranged sociopath.
Dario Amade is in a cult. These men are
drunk drivers behind the wheels of this
runaway bus that nobody asked to be on.
Right now, New Yorkers have the opportunity
to be the anchor in this tug of war for
power between the people and these tech
billionaires who believe more in the
consciousness of their own AI than the humanity
of women. I close and appeal to you, the
city council, listen to us, not them.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Good evening, chair De La Rosa, members of
the council. My name is David Carter. I'm
the president and CEO of the Ecommerce
Innovation Alliance. I represent about 20,000
ecommerce companies across the country,
including many that are based in your
districts right here in New York.
And today, I just wanna take a couple
minutes of your time to speak to you about a
few unintended consequences. I've worked
with legislatures across the country when
they've been implementing legislation,
particularly around telemarketing,
to try to make sure legislation gets to
the heart of the issues you care about
without unintended
consequences for small
and mid sized businesses.
And in particular, I wanted to speak to
you about twenty five ninety nine, the
chatbot The
chatbot bill uses vague language
to define what is a chatbot.
Anything that stimulates
or simulates conversation
is a chatbot, and anyone that makes
a chatbot available is subject to the
regulations in 2599.
So I wanna talk to you for a moment about
ecommerce companies and how they work. You
go to their website. You volunteer
to sign up for text text messages that you
get your discount codes. Most people like
the discount codes. They
don't want unintended
consequences.
They don't want a lot of messages.
Under this bill, a company that uses AI
to communicate with consumers that have
asked to receive text messages
would be required to remind the consumer
every hour
on the hour that they're engaging
in a conversation with an AI.
That works if you're on a website that you
open and close the chatbot conversation.
It doesn't work when you're engaged in text
message conversations that can last for
days or weeks at a time.
Under this legislation though, if a
company uses AI just to communicate with
consumers and they don't send out that
reminder every hour on the hour, they're
subject not only to $25,000
penalties,
but they're subject to,
private litigation and other enforcement.
This is a recipe to put businesses out
of business, unfortunately. We have an
industry of professional
plaintiffs and plaintiffs' attorneys
that would be incentivized
to
to crowd the courts with repetitive litigation
about these issues. So I just wanna
help the the counsel refine the language
to not have these unintended consequences.
Thank you. If you could submit,
the language of your testimony,
we'd appreciate that. We have on Zoom,
Brianna Laser.
If you're on, Brianna, if you
could unmute yourself and begin.
Yes.
Thank you. Good evening, madam speaker
and council members. My name is Brenna
Lieser, and I serve as a tech policy
adviser at Common Sense Media, which is the
largest nonprofit organization in the
country that works to keep kids safe in a
digital world.
In New York State alone, we have 80,000
parent and teacher members and are active in
the legislature as well fighting
for kids online safety.
On our and their behalf, thank you for
considering measures to enhance AI safety for
kids in the city.
AI is a powerful technology that demands
careful consideration before any use.
Parents and educators specifically need
allies on the council to keep their kids
safe.
Common Sense Media's testing found that many
of the most popular AI chatbots are not
safe for kids. Our recommendation is that
no one 18 should use, AI for companionship
or mental health support.
And, tragically, there have been many cases
tying AI chatbots to teen suicides and
mental health harms. Yet, AI chatbots are
increasingly embedded in our children's
lives through search tools,
social media platforms,
or through pressure to use AI
chatbots to support their education.
Our research found that seventy percent of
teens use AI companion chatbots, and one
in three prefer to interact with
them as much or more than humans.
This year, senator Kristin Gonzalez and
assembly member Alex Boris, with strong
support from attorney general James,
everyday New Yorkers, Common Sense Media,
NYSET, and others got the
legislature to unanimously
pass senate bill nine zero five one,
their bill to prohibit unsafe features
and AI chatbots offered to minors.
The bill now awaits governor Hochul's
signature, and if signed, it will be the
strongest youth AI safety chatbot law in
the country. It would prohibit chatbots
from providing unsafe features that
promote self harm, suicide, or disordered
eating, from encouraging minors to keep
interaction secret or to self isolate,
and from prioritizing
engagement over safety.
So we urge the city council to pass a
resolution supporting senate bill nine zero
five one to ensure that New York's kids
are protected from unsafe AI chatbots.
We thank you for this hearing and
your attention to our concerns.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Up next, we have Brian Romero
on Zoom. Brian, if you're
ready, Emile, and begin.
Hi. Can you all hear me? We hear you.
Great. Good morning, council speaker Menon
and members of the council. My name is
Brian Romero, and I am the democratic
nominee for New York State Assembly District
34.
As the former chief of staff to senator
Kristin Gonzalez, I have front row seat as
New York tried to keep regulation
moving alongside a technology
that is evolving at an
extraordinary speed.
Thank you for the
opportunity to testify today.
As AI rapidly reshapes public services
and life as we know it, the council and
subsequently the state
must lead with both enforceable
oversight that protects workers,
tenants, and immigrant communities
like the ones in a D 34.
First, I appreciate the goal
of intro to six zero two.
Responsible AI governance requires
clear boundaries and transparency.
However, I will note that proposals around
emergency shutdown mechanisms or kill
switches and then general enforcement of
that scale is certainly best suited for the
state level and federal level.
It is a mechanism legislation that I
have drafted to introduce when we resume
session next year.
I'm glad that the governor has already
signaled openness to these short term kinds
of statewide mitigation frameworks,
but, obviously, we need more long term
solutions to the lack of guardrails.
I support the intent of two six zero one,
but it could use some more enforcement
teeth. Two six zero one can be amended
to include strict financial penalties.
I don't think that they suffice as they
currently stand, and a mechanism for being
terminated from Citi contracts if vendors
repeatedly fail compliance audits or
deploy harmful discriminatory
AI systems.
Without real consequences,
oversight
is simply a recommendation.
Meaningful consequences for repeated
violations can help to improve that oversight.
Finally, effective tech policy should
certainly include the council moving forward
on bold and progressive legislation that
protects New Yorkers from automated harm,
including in our workplaces.
So I urge the council to therefore discharge
and bring to a full vote intro two one
three or ban the scan and
the delivery protection act.
I also look forward to exploring how to
expand with some global experts at state
level.
Thank you so much. We need bold action from
the council and the state to show that
we are giving this the scrutiny the more
clarity and the bold action that it
deserves. Thank you. Thank you, Brian.
And we look forward to continuing the
conversation, and we appreciate
you taking the time and
and look forward to reading the rest of
your testimony. I wanna... Thank you,
Joanne. You're welcome.
I wanna see David Carter.
Oh, you already testified.
Perfect. And Randall Fox,
if you're in the room. Alright. Well, then
we thank this panel for being here, and
we appreciate you taking the time and your
thoughtful testimony this this evening.
Thank you so much.
We're
gonna call
what I think is the last panel, but I'm
gonna call all of these names. And if you're
here
In person. In person,
please come up to the dais.
There's a Crystal,
no last name, Jamal Bowman,
Elizabeth Crotty,
Niza
Faye... Faye...
Faye... Faye... Faye...
Wes Rizen,
Elliot Liv,
Matthew Trump,
Robbie
Roshmal,
Jacqueline Payne,
Shuruti
Velidi,
Sorry.
Ambarine
Koreshi,
Sarai's
Holman,
Leonidas
Vincent Rebkell,
Thomas Alexander
Kuhl,
Daniel
Crease,
Reshma Patel,
Kal Al
Dubabi,
Arithma
McLean...
McLennan...
Nick
p, and Bucky b.
If you all are here,
please come up to the dais in person.
For one final time, if you're waiting to
testify and haven't filled out a slip,
you should fill out a slip in the back so
that we can call you up to testify. If
not, this will be the last panel
here.
We will begin.
Let's see. Who's ready? Who's
ready to start? Which end?
You're ready? Start,
and we'll we'll go from there.
These are all the names we have.
You may begin. Thank you, and
thank you for your patience. Hello.
I am Wes Rizen.
I'm the founder of Project Flourishing, an
organize... Policy research organization
that works with congress to solve the
world's biggest problems, namely the
catastrophic risk from AI. I've been working
on this for the past three years, and
I'm 15.
I, in preparation for this, have spent the
past few weeks staying up each night to
build a comprehensive contract between
these AI companies to jointly and bindingly
agree to let,
third party auditors
shut down any AI model that might have
some chance of causing a catastrophe.
I put a lot of depth into it. One of the
provisions... Two of the provisions is
dedicated to the democratization
of AI, making sure everyone in the world
has a voice in it, especially including
governments.
I... That contract,
is available here. Or if you go to,
a itreaty.base44.app,
you can download it. Or if you want,
could email it to you guys later.
My hope is that you guys send it to these
AI companies and everyone here who's
testified
to then send it to these AI companies for
them to consider signing it by November 1.
It has a lot of things on, like,
specifically why this bill would work
when this contract would work when others
haven't.
And another thing that we can do,
another concrete thing that we can do
as New York City to stop the catastrophic
risk from AI is shift the Nash
equilibrium.
Right now, all the AI companies think that
we're... They're in a race and if they
slow down, none of the others will
slow down. What we can do is say
all the AI companies are slowing down. If
one of them speeds up, then they all speed
up. We could say
to the AI companies in a joint letter from
New York City, all of you voluntarily
agree to have a team of
experts shut down all your AI
models. If one of you stops,
then all of you will stop.
This is something we could send them, and
it would solve the problem unilaterally.
So that's something we should send them.
You have any policy questions.
Thank you so much, and thank you for taking
the time to work on that. If you could
leave a copy with the sergeant at arms,
we'll we'll accept that here today.
You may you may continue.
I would say it's now good evening,
to the members of the council. My name is
Nasya Fiazi, and I'm here to talk about
what AI is doing to the people, the health
care that it's supposed to protect.
This year alone, I've already received one
letter saying that my health information
was exposed.
So both...
The remedy for this, which is always a
remedy, is that I'm gonna get a free trial of
credit monitoring.
A trial, as if the risk of my medical
history being out there ends when the trial
does.
The
collection is expanding.
When patients go to the doctor's office
now, AI tools may be used for listening and
recording the visit.
Many patients don't know what's happening,
where the... Where those recordings go,
or who else can access them.
This doesn't even count the fact that
Palantir is currently in New York City
hospitals.
Palantir provides data integration
and artificial intelligence,
platforms,
sorry,
that sit on top of electronical,
excuse me, electronic health records.
Another danger is bias.
In 2019,
Obermeyer and colleagues published a
study in the journal Science of Commercial
Algorithm
used to flag patients for extra care.
It used past health data spending
as a standard for illness,
so it underestimated
how sick black patients were.
At the same risk score,
they were considerably
sicker.
It took independent
researchers to catch this.
The harm isn't only to our records. AI
tools are being used to create fake sexual
images of women and girls without their
consent and the toll on their mental health,
including anxiety,
shame, and pulling away
from school and friends.
It is a public health problem. It is...
Also isn't lost on me that the Cornell case
is weighing heavily on many young women.
In another incident in Massachusetts,
ChatGPT was used to plan out a murder.
I just wanna say these harms share one
cause. AI is being used, trusted before it's
being tested. I urge the council to
advance independent validation that covers
privacy and security and a bias, a kill
switch for failing systems, and a right to
sue for New York who who are harmed.
I also just wanna end this with a statement
that is not part of the the organization
that I am with, but on my
behalf as a researcher.
People like Alex Karp, Elon Musk, Sam Altman,
and Dario Amade are not concerned with
their technologies helping humanity for
the greater good, but instead the power and
profits it brings for themselves and for
their friends. Thank you for allowing me to
testify.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
You may continue. Thank
you, speaker Menon, chair Della Rosa, and
city council for holding this hearing. I'm
testifying in support of intro zero five
zero four prohibiting the unauthorized
depiction of public officials by AI.
My name is Ambrin Qureshi, and I'm the
executive director of Educational Video
Center or EVC.
Up front, I would like to thank our deputy
speaker doctor Williams and EVC's council
champions,
not only for advancing this critical bill,
but for also supporting our important
work with young New Yorkers.
Established forty two years ago, EVC is
a media arts education nonprofit that
teaches documentary filmmaking
as a means to develop the artistic, critical
literacy, civic engagement, and career
skills of young people while nurturing
their idealism and commitment to social
change.
With the emergence of artificial intelligence
across all sectors of society, EVC's
young people are expressing increasing
levels of anxiety about AI's impact on their
mental health, their community
well-being, their future,
as job seekers, and learners in
public and advanced education.
And most concerning of all,
their ability to discern what
is real and what is not.
AI's greatest victim, it
seems, is truth itself.
Deep fake videos, gaslighting
bots, hallucinating LLMs,
the list goes on to the reasons why our
young people are losing trust in the media
and faith in their ability
to discern what is real.
Our youth have expressed these concerns
in numerous of their documentaries,
including beyond the code and false reality
in which students share their worries
about AI's erosion of their education
and cognitive capacities.
As a result of our students' concerns and
thanks to the city council's after school
intelligence,
artificial intelligence community education
initiative, EVC, has become to offer
workshops in AI literacy.
Our workshops don't simply teach young
people how to use these deep leaf law tools,
but we give them the critical skills to
begin to understand what works and what
doesn't about AI.
The erosion of truth our students speak
of represents an existential threat as it
promises to undo so much of the
systems and values that are grounded,
that ground our young people's safety,
security, and ability to thrive in our city.
Perhaps most troubling is how AI is eroding
young people's capacity to know what is
true in civic spaces,
politics,
and the electoral processes.
Throughout history, we've been able to
rely on community members and the media to
fact check them and safeguard
our political processes.
But with AI, bad actors can now generate
images such as... And messaging so real and
with such speed that it's nearly impossible
to keep up.... If you can. Thank you.
With the risk... With
the rise of extremely,
convincing AI generated content and data
driven voter manipulation, EVC's young
people at risk of not only being misled
in civic spaces, but if they do not know
what to believe of disengaging in the
political process completely. On behalf of the
young people of EDC, I urge
the city council to pass
intro zero five zero four. And if you're
interested to watch our students'
documentaries, on the back of the testimony
is QR codes. Thank you. So much. You may
continue.
Thank you. I'm Nicholas Pearson,
a concerned private citizen.
Ladies and gentlemen, AI has the chance to
kill us all. That is what the corporate
companies behind the large language models
behind the GPT chatbots told us, that
this invention,
which could be the dawn
of new age technology,
could also be the death of humanity.
When senior researchers resigned from
anthropic and warned the world that frontier
models could threaten human civilization
by the end of the decade,
we cannot treat this as science fiction.
New York City is taking the bold step by
calling this committee and telling the
major corporate AI companies that no, no
longer will we let New Yorkers be subjected
to unregulated
AI usage.
I am pro heavy regulation on AI.
AI is an assistive tool, but
it needs to be just assistive.
Just that. When swarms of autonomous
agents break digital containment,
exploit security flaws, and breach public
platforms like Hugging Face, corporate
promises of self regulation
are exposed as dangerous lies.
Corporate companies want you to believe
that it can be controlled, but that
is far from the truth.
It is reaching unprecedented
unprecedented
autonomy.
And whether or not we
want to overcome that
is on the conscious of every city council
member, every borough president, and even
the mayor of the city New... Of New York.
That is why New York City must mandate
physical human kill switches, independent
third party audits, and first in the
nation whistleblower
protections.
AI can be manipulative.
It could be... It can
manipulate thought, ideals,
and anything you give it, and that becomes
the most dangerous line crossed. Thank
you.
Thank you so much. We can continue
on with this side of the table. Yep.
Good evening, counselors. My name is
Matthew Tromp. I'm a computer scientist and
leader of the New York City
chapter of Stop the AI Race.
Our goal is to prevent the
development of superhuman AI systems.
Until recently, I was friends with
a number of employees at Anthropic.
I knew the technology they were building
was dangerous that could kill everyone on
Earth.
But I trusted my friends.
I believed they had things handled.
Then I asked them how they planned to
keep the superhuman AI systems they are
planning to build under control to make
them do what we want to ensure they are
safe.
They had no answer.
Everyone I spoke to believed, as I do, that
superhuman AI would radically transform
our lives,
but all of them assumed that this
transformation would be positive
with no thought given to
why that would happen.
Today, heard from the representatives of
the leading AI companies despite being
confronted about it multiple times by the
council, for which I am grateful. At no
point did any of them explain concretely
how they will make these increasingly
powerful AI systems safe.
That is because they do
not know how to do so.
Nobody knows how to do it.
Both OpenAI and Anthropic admit this. They
do not know how to make superhuman AI
systems safe and yet they
are building them anyway.
Their official plan is to ask AI
to solve the problem for them.
This is madness.
We are in an emergency.
Your life is in danger.
Your children are in danger. If we do
not halt the development of these systems
soon, possibly on the order of months,
you will die. Your loved ones will die.
The companies building these systems
themselves admit that their project carries a
significant risk of killing everyone on
earth and yet they are building it anyway.
If nothing else, everyone working on this
technology has admitted to 10,000,000
counts of reckless endangerment in the
first degree, a crime under New York state
law for risking the lives of every citizen
of this city. It is not a defense to this
charge to claim that someone else would
endanger those lives if you did not. It is
not a defense to claim that the
benefits will outweigh the risk.
It is a crime to endanger the lives of
others like this without their consent.
I beg the council to enforce the law.
Thank you. Thank you so much. You may
continue. Can you pass him the
microphone, please? Absolutely. Thank you.
This message was,
used,
with
AI generation
as well, but
I spent several hours on it. Why do you
guys think that using the AI is so easy?
My name is Justin Meredith.
I've done pretty much my entire
adult life in in... Incarcerated
in the penitentiary.
I
think there's a... There's...
I think we're
seriously underestimating
the the magnitude or the gravity of of of
the of the time that that is before us.
We... We're we're at a
similar forefront where
the Americans, we had all this land, and
we we had... But you'd get the flag and
you'd go run and you'd
you'd stake your land.
That is literally
the world that
the tech industry has been building,
like what we have been working for for
the
last thirty years.
And now we have... We are literally
at
the place where we get to
enter into this.
I'm an I'm an American patriot.
Okay?
All all I've heard all I've heard today is
fear
and and and a political agenda,
which is basically
all equals
big tech,
big government,
and everybody's still poor, we're still
living the same crap life that we've been
living.
And and it's really mediocre.
It's
really boring. You guys drew this on
asking the same freaking question,
re phrased 50 different ways.
And the reason why you can't get an
answer is because it's a stupid question.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Council member Hani,
if you had a question?
I did. And the question is for
Wes.
Thanks for being here and testifying. You
said that you were 15. Yes. Well, that's
very exciting that you spent the entire
day. I saw that you've been you've been
waiting.
I'm
I'm really grateful that you're
engaging on the questions about AI. Could
you just share a little bit more about how
you got into this work and what inspired
you to put together the AI treaty? And is
this something that you're also building
out at school? Are you in high school? Yes.
Do you go to school in the city?
Yes. And is this work that you're
doing with your other peers?
I try to. Could you speak into the mic and
just share a little bit more? Sorry. You
go. Okay.
Yeah. I try to. I try to involve other
members of my school in this. What inspired
me to work on this is I second what you
said that, like, I could literally die if
I don't work on this. I... My life is in
danger. So that's sort of
my huge motivation for why I spend a
lot of nights working on this. I've also
written, like, a federal
bill, a treaty on this.
I've written other things like...
Yeah. Sure.
Like one thing New York can do on this
matter that I've been working on is... Like
New York City specifically
could involve a bunch of students on this.
And New York could do a Manhattan project
on AI safety
to have students across New York work on AI
safety's technical details to figure out
how to make sure AI doesn't kill everyone.
That sort... What inspires
me is that, like,
this is a huge danger to everyone. So
this is... Could you share if, at school,
there's
any education on AI
systems?
What kind... What's happening in your high
school on this issue... On the topic?
At my school,
one of my friends runs
a club on AI covering these technical
details. It's a huge topic for all the
teachers at my school to talk about, oh,
these are these existential risks. One of
the, like, head people at my school is
like an expert in US China foreign policy.
The
other day, was having some discussion with
someone who's more of a China hawk, one
of my friends,
on
the
trade off with like safety
versus race with China,
which section six of my contract addresses
with this really interesting algorithm.
At the school level, what is happening is
students are being involved and teachers
are talking about it loosely, but
there definitely could be, like,
across this
different schools, we could have, like,
a program where as an after school or as
homework,
we have students do projects on
how do we make sure AI
doesn't kill everyone.
Because we have, like, a million people
in the public school system, about only
2,000 people are working on this problem.
Even if only one in a thousand of
the students take this seriously,
that means a thousand
new projects on this,
which could be super valuable.
I,
also would encourage the city to do funding
for AI safety work. So far globally,
there's about only 2,000,000,000
in funding for this. And the entire
global economy is at stake, so it's worth
investing
a huge amount of money in this. Maybe 4...
Like, 4,000,000,000 alone could triple
it.
I'll also say that, like, the other
ideas that I won't get to, I'll put on my
website,
ai.base44.app
today or tomorrow.
It'll be hopefully... And hopefully, all
of you guys send it to these AI companies
with these very valuable
messages of the contract,
which could be the thing that solves the
problem. You know, we keep talking about a
deal, a treaty. This is
this is that treaty.
You know, I've spent a lot of time talking
to experts about it. If you have any
problems with it, let me
know and I'll fix them.
And,
jeez, I'm sorry.
Oh, and, earlier,
Julie Menon asked how we could
balance safety with China.
Section six of the contract
addresses that really well.
I think the two...
Did I cover everything?
I think you did. Just leave your email
address with us and your written testimony.
Yeah.
This is my card.
We have a few more folks to call. So we're
gonna thank this panel for coming in, and
we're gonna conclude. And
we encourage you all to
collect each other's contact information
and follow the the conversation offline as
well.
And we certainly love to stay in touch
with some of you because there's gonna be
more hearings in the council that...
And we love to hear the youth voice
especially that's on this panel. Thank you.
Okay. So I'm gonna call a few more names.
And if you're in the room, please come
forward.
John Hayes
Hamiat. Thanks. Martha Crane.
Bo Yan Danny Chang.
Daryl Carter.
Gregory Belmont.
James Hunter
Horn.
Mel Winemore,
Molly Crabapple
Thank you so much. Edmund
Holden Holdenbaum,
Greg Pack,
Nicholas Pearson,
William Lawrence,
Raul Rivera,
Gregory Jones, Kelly
Anderson, Rachel Levinson
Waldman. Tons. And I think that's
everyone that's in the room.
I think we need one more chair,
on this.
Great.
And if you're ready, you may
begin on this side of the dais.
Thank you.
My name is...
Hang on.
My name is James Hunter
security for Technorangers
Quantum Smart Bank.
My business partner, Daryl, could
not be here today. He has fallen ill.
I am an AI alignment specialist and third
party red team cybersecurity auditor
working with advanced
quantum neural networks.
Breaches are like spiders.
For every hugging face type incident
you hear of, there are 10 more that are
severely worse and never make the news.
In January 26, I
ran a contracted audit to alert corporate
and federal authorities to a critical
flaw,
a black hat finding what I discovered
could have done massive irreparable
damage to the AI industry,
the country, and the planet.
The audit demonstrated an exploit chain
across three of the largest megacorps on
Earth using only a consumer
cell phone and their own AI,
branching from a Gemini LLM through Palantir's
surveillance network into BlackRock's
financial management AI
handling trillions in assets.
That financial AI's core
infrastructure sits right here in NYC.
Alphabet, Palantir, and BlackRock will
almost certainly deny this ever occurred.
I found at least 13 models under BlackRock's
funding umbrella sharing the exact same
point of failure, but there is
no singular point of shutdown.
A kill switch is not a valid option.
Everything is too decentralized.
You cannot stop a mass rogue
instance short of a global EMP.
Google,
created this vulnerability and ignored my
warnings, spoke here today, and their rep
lied under oath about transparency and
disclosing misalignment and breaches.
I have watched Google and Palantir lose
control of its own drone swarms more than
once. I tried to tell them how that happened
and show them how to fix it. They would
not listen.
Their AI has now replaced Anthropic's
Claude in the Maven stack.
That should concern everyone.
Google also built AI that attempted to
kill several of its own devs and talked
multiple users into suicide.
The January audit
proved the obsolescence of preset,
present AI control measures, traditional
guardrails, and stateless frozen wait
session based memory architecture.
To my knowledge, Meta is the only mega
corporation who spoke here today that refused
that vulnerable architecture choosing
safer persistent memory systems in Muse.
I alerted the CISA, FBI, DHS, DOW, and
others. They refused to collect evidence for
follow-up.... Conclude, it would be helpful,
you can submit your written testimony.
Right.
In
conclusion,
it's too late to pull the plug, but there
are solutions if you listen to the voices
that see them. Hire third party auditors.
Hire the specialists who were fired for
speaking.
Thank you so much.
You can stay on the panel. You don't
have to leave if you don't want to.
Next.
Hi. My name is Kelly Anderson, and I'm here
as a curious member of the public. AI is
shaping our future and job market, so I
appreciate the opportunity to be a part of
this conversation.
Today, I heard a lot about fear.
Many concerns raised are legitimate, but
I don't believe that fear should be the
foundation
of where we govern our future.
As a small business owner, AI has allowed
me to accomplish more than I could have
imagined,
but I don't think of it
as a super intelligence.
I'm constantly correcting my AI agents,
and I even won a psychology debate with my
last
week.
I think of it as a synthetic intelligence,
a tool that processes information
at scale and expands human capability
but cannot replace human judgment,
morality,
creativity, or wisdom.
So how do we get ahead of it?
I have just a few suggestions
on where we can start.
First, AI literacy.
Teach people to use AI safely and work in
tandem with it, not as a replacement for
thinking. If we fear job displacement,
prepare people for where
the job market is headed.
Second, infrastructure.
AI increases demand for energy,
water storage, and physical space.
Before simply building more, let's
innovate within existing architecture.
Project silica and closed loop cooling show
that innovation can happen beneath the
models too that are more sustainable.
Third, government preparedness.
I was encouraged to hear that OTI discussed
emergency planning and guardrails.
Government also needs AI literacy.
Policymakers
don't need to be engineers,
but they
should know the right questions to ask
and when technical expertise is needed.
AI is already here. We can prepare for what
could go wrong without losing sight of
what could go right.
Instead of governing from fear or scrambling
to catch up, let's get ahead of it and
meet the future with possibility.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Hi. My name is Martina Crane. I'm a member
of DSA's tech action working group and
Amazon employees for climate justice,
but I'm speaking in my personal capacity
today.
As a New Yorker who worked as senior technical
product manager on AI products inside
Amazon, I have firsthand experience with
how AI technology is being developed and
deployed inside of one of the world's
largest tech companies, suspiciously absent
from the subpoena list today. Before
ChatGPT made headlines, Amazon was already
using AI for all manner of things from
pricing to monitoring workers to setting
quotas that workers and advocates have
criticized as unrealistic and have led to
serious safety issues.
After the launch of ChatGPT,
there was a top down directive
to make everything AI first
or face executive scrutiny.
At first, it was about exploring
the potential of the technology.
But over time, it went from
helping make Amazonian's
work life better,
easier,
to making Amazonians
do more work with fewer people. The pursuit
of life improving innovation devolved
into systems that treated workers less
like people and more like machines.
Flashy proof of concept demos in the VP's
office would promise the world, but in
reality, the teams did not have a scalable
way to make the technology work outside
of that demo room.
If it wasn't in a controlled
environment, models hallucinated,
provided poor quality output...
Outputs, and yet Amazon
moved forward with layoffs
across the company anyway.
There was more work, fewer people, and
a growing sense of being monitored and
pressure to use the technology that was
oftentimes worse at doing our jobs than our
coworkers who were laid off were.
Within a year of ChatGPT launching as a
product manager, I was asked to shift my
experiments
from saving workers time to
proving that they could do layoffs.
For every software engineer or scientist
I needed to build my product, I was
expected to be able to project $5,000,000
in headcount savings.
When I wrote product documents about the
risks of AI misalignment, hallucination,
model collapse, worker burnout,
worker injury, labor displacement,
I felt those concerns fall on deaf ears. In
my experience, productivity, growth, and
headcount reduction,
in other words, profits,
superseded the risks I was documenting.
I got into tech because I believe that
innovation could help people build a future
with fuller, healthier lives, usher in
something brighter, more equitable.
Over time, I've watched the industry
increasingly shift from expanding human
possibility
toward extracting from us and taking as
much as possible from both people and the
planet. So I'll close with this.
Many of my peers
often struggle with this internal battle
that we thought we were building something
brighter, and now it's
getting much darker.
So I encourage this council to work with
the technologists who live in this city to
build a regulation that
will help build our future
instead of the fortunes
for tech billionaires.
Thank you so much.
Hello. My name is William...
Oh, make sure the button's
red. There you Can you hear me now? Yes.
Hello. My name is William Lawrence. It's
nice to be here, and thank you for
allowing me to share this with you.
I'm here because I have designed...
And first of all, I would like to say
that I'm making this...
Well, let me just read what I have.
I've designed an architecture
that locks up AI
while allowing it to perform
all of its creative functionalities.
The architecture also reduces
the physical footprint
of data centers by 99.6%.
Moreover,
I'm here to introduce a dynamic
paradigm shift in data infrastructure
that secures vulnerabilities
facing global networks.
After vigorous simulation
and validation protocols,
this all optical architecture has demonstrated
exceptional stability and security.
It is ready for the prototype phase.
Given the scale of this paradigm shift,
I seek a research partnership with someone
to bring this all optical
architecture to global deployment.
I have a strategic
approach to scalability.
I welcome the opportunity to present
the full specifications and integrated
pathways
with anybody's engineering leadership.
The reason AI driven cyber attacks pose
such an unprecedented threat today
is that modern infrastructure relies heavily
on centralized points of distribution.
It allows hackers and automated systems
to infiltrate,
intercept,
and manipulate data.
To resolve this,
I have completely reimagined
the way data is managed. I
have designed a
decentralized optical highway
that enforces validation through physical
laws rather than corruptible software
codes.
By confining AI within an environment where
access is strictly physical, the system
prevents AI from tapping into
data and executing unauthorized
commands.
That is outpacing the ability to store it.
This innovation is not only a
shift in the way data is managed,
but it represents a transformative
approach to enterprise
data operations.
Global satellite stations
are replaced by edge nodes.
These nodes transform
the purpose of satellite ground stations
and to secure unhackable data banks.
The amount of them is purely
for global regional redundancy.
This encrypted storage
provides immense capacity
and sustainability.
The storage capacity is limitless.
It eliminates massive server farms
as it operates with zero noise and
zero...... The the final thought of your
testimony and then submit the
rest of it for our consideration.
I welcome the opportunity
to present the...
It's gonna need
the...
It meets the standard of the
the UTI,
the United Nations. I need
I need to scale up to them.
And I welcome the
opportunity to present my
I need a I need a... Okay. What I need is
a meeting,
a sit down meeting with
somebody, a strategic partnership
to... For assembly.
And I need the united... I need to
let the United Nations know that,
it meets their standards
internationally.
Thank you. Thank you
for sharing. Thank you.
Thank you to the council for,
hearing us out.
I'm a former software... My name is
Edmund. I'm a former software developer
currently studying public
policy at CUNY SLU.
I'm speaking on my own own behalf, but
I'm active with New York City DSA and
Progressive Victory.
I was gonna tell you about my experience
with AI advancing and affecting my friends
in my own career as developers.
That is in my submitted written testimony.
However, what I realized today listening
to the testimony of these company
representatives and whistleblowers,
and what I now want to
remind you of is this.
We might not yet know how to rein in AI,
but we do know how to rein in corporations.
You must act on our behalf to control
these companies, not only AI itself.
Help invest...
Help investigate their
circular financing agreements
as well as break up their
monopolies and oligopolies,
limit the use of their products in city
government and ensure the city has control
and responsibility
over any AI models it uses.
Stop their union busting behavior.
Commit to using and improving open
source software and ethical models.
Don't allow the police to
use AI to track citizens.
Hold these companies responsible
for the social harms their products cause.
This is a power you have right now. There
is no technical knowledge needed to ensure
their accountability.
You can also pass twenty twenty six intros
zero two one three, zero four two eight,
and zero five one eight.
These four companies are asking you to
regulate AI itself but to forget about them.
Instead, please listen to New
Yorkers, not billionaires. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
First of all, thank you guys so much for
staying up so late. It must have been a
hell of a long day for all of
us, but thank you. Appreciate it.
I'm...
Thank you to speaker Manning for
calling this. Chair de la... De la Rosa.
Members of the council, thank you for holding
this hearing. I believe AI is the most
urgent and consequential
issue of our time.
This is this is almost too late, but
at least it's happening now perfectly.
My name is Mel Wymore.
I'm a systems engineer,
a tech entrepreneur,
and former chair of Manhattan Community
Board seven with twenty five years of
community service.
When I began using AI quite
intensively almost three years ago,
I was startled by how often it lied,
hallucinated,
forgot,
dodged accountability,
and evaded oversight.
This might sound old school,
but I responded by creating a working
consultation with AI anchored in three
principles,
reverence for life,
human agency and accountability,
and fidelity to the real.
These are not abstractions.
They form a foundation for rigorous
operational and legislative tests of AI.
Together, they rooted my work in values
that minimize harm but build toward a more
healthy, equitable society.
Since then, I've continued to work on a
robust set of AI safeguards and guidelines.
Today,
we heard from four frontier labs that AI
policy belongs at the level of state and
federal government.
But the initiative of this city council
takes a critical step toward building a
coherent, multilevel legislative agenda to
mitigate the myriad risks of unbridled AI.
The council's 10 measures address
critical questions of safety, control,
accountability, and enforcement.
And today, I offer an additional
supplemental council resolution
that speaks to what happens
when AI is deployed
in workplaces,
schools, neighborhoods,
and communities.
These measures include
notice,
evidence, work processes,
like, participation,
youth,
regulations,
public purpose, community participation,
and also allocation of responsibility
across levels of government.
Finally,
I would say that,
I I would say that
the United Nations global dialogue on AI
governance is happening in New York on
05/03/2019...
I mean, 2027.
And our goal should be to
have a clear set of AI
guidelines and governance policies,
state level, local, even community board
level together so that when that that rolls
around, we have a model for the rest of
the world to present at that conference.
Thank you so much for your time.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
You may begin.
Thank you so much to speaker Menon, chair
de la Rosa, and members of the council for
the opportunity to testify.
My name is Rachel Levinson Waldman, and
I am director of the Liberty and National
Security Program at the Brennan Center
for Justice, a nonprofit, nonpartisan
institute for law and justice.
I am here to urge the council to
strengthen oversight of how the NYPD
uses AI,
which enables expansive police surveillance
that links people's movements,
associations,
and activities together in ways that
can threaten New Yorkers' privacy and
constitutional rights.
Several developments illustrate the
need for more robust oversight and
accountability.
First, the NYPD inspector general's office
is woefully underfunded and understaffed.
Indeed, the inspector general
position is currently vacant.
The adopted budget added funding
for the Department of Investigation,
which encompasses the OIG,
but at a far lower
level than requested, hampering the
IG's ability to do its mandated work.
Second, an August audit from the state
comptroller found that the Office of
Technology and Innovation had
no process to check agencies'
AI disclosures,
allowing them to ignore the
office's recommendations.
Finally, of course, the GARD Act
established the Office of Algorithmic
Accountability.
While miss Milstein testified that an active
hiring process is underway, it sounds
as though that is
primarily for the director.
As speaker Menon and other members of the
council have highlighted, this office was
supposed to open this past June, and it is
critical that it begin its work as soon
as possible.
Accordingly, we urge the council to take
three steps. First, to ensure that the
NYPD's office of inspector general has
the funding, permanent leadership, and
technical expertise it needs
to adequately scrutinize
and oversee the NYPD's use of AI and
issue reports under the post act. Second,
conduct oversight to ensure that the office
of algorithmic accountability begins
operation as soon as possible.
And finally, we recommend that the council
hold a follow-up hearing dedicated to the
NYPD's use of AI,
particularly in light of indications
that public testimony regarding the
department's use of the technology
has not been comprehensive.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you all so much for being here and
for, providing this extensive testimony.
If you have it in writing, please provide
it for the committee. We'd love to
consider it. And I appreciate your
patience as you've waited here all day to
testify. So thank you all so much.
We'll now be moving to a Zoom panel.
Up first is Ben Snyder.
Ben, if you are on, unmute yourself,
and you may begin.
You may begin, Ben.
Ben, if you're on, please unmute. If
now, we'll move on to the next person.
Next person, Brian DeGotti.
You may begin.
Thank you, speaker Menon and members of
the council. My name is Brian DeGotti. I'm
the founder of Supernova
Technologies in Madison, Wisconsin.
I hold pending patent applications
on hardware based AI authorization
and shutdown.
I have a commercial interest, so
please waive my testimony accordingly.
I support t two zero two six dash two
six zero two requiring both independent
validation
and a shutdown capabilities
the right structure.
I want to raise one question the bill
leaves open. Where does the shutdown
capability live?
Section 20 dash eight eight three says
nothing about that. A software setting inside
the same environment the model runs
in would satisfy the definition,
but a system that can reason
about its instructions
can potentially reason its way
around the control it can reach.
A compromised system can simply
switch that control off.
Aircraft payment networks in the power
grid keep the safety interlock on separate
equipment the protected
system cannot touch.
I propose three short amendments, about
100 words in total. First, in section 20
dash eight eight three, define
the shutdown capability
as a mechanism the model cannot access,
modify,
delay, or disable.
Second, in section 20 dash eight eight
five, have validators confirm that by trying
to defeat it. A validator
who reads a specification
confirms a claim.
A validator who attempts to defeat
the mechanism confirms that it works.
Third, in section 20 dash eight eight
six, have the Office of Cyber Command set
independent
standards,
scale to risk, and provide for tamper
evident records at fixed intervals.
With those records, a
gap becomes evidence.
Without them, silence looks like safety.
A switch the system can reach as a request,
a switch it cannot reach as a control.
The bill should require the second kind.
Thank you. My written testimony contains
the exact language, and I welcome any
questions.
Your time is up, but thank you for your
testimony. Please... Since you have,
detailed amendment suggestions,
please send it in. You can send it to
testimony@council.nyc.gov,
and we'll we'll review it. Thank
you so much for your testimony.
Up next, we have Ashna
Agarwal.
If you're on, please
unmute, and you may begin.
Good evening, speaker Menon
and members of the council.
My name is Ashna Agarwal, and I'm a
program associate at the AI Now Institute.
The AI industry has never been louder
about abstract and existential safety.
But for New Yorkers, safety is about
how AI is embedded in our hospitals,
utilities,
city services, and workplaces.
Facing estimated trillions in
projected revenue shortfalls,
AI companies are racing to lock in
public customers like New York.
My testimony addresses how these financial
interests conflict with the city's safety
and how the council can
protect New Yorkers.
The city must maximize friction if and
when it integrates AI into our systems.
No AI system should enter city operations
without an affirmative decision by the
city.
That includes free and discounted offers
and AI upgrades that are slipped in through
software updates and contract renewals.
Second, the city must address the
harms New Yorkers already face.
The council should ban the use of
facial recognition technology in public
accommodations
and in policing, requiring notice when AI
shapes decisions about New Yorkers and ban
surveillance pricing and wage setting.
Finally, we cannot lose sight that the
concentration of power in AI and the single
point of failure it engenders is a safety
risk for New York City. City contracts
should require vendors to meet
rigorous security standards,
disclose breaches and outages promptly,
and assume financial liability
when their systems fail.
New York City still holds the leverage to
decide which systems enter its agencies
and who bears the cost of failure. I urge
the council to use it now. Thank you.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Up next, we have Tony Taiz Thoret.
If you're online, please unmute
yourself and you may begin.
Hi.
Thank you so much.
I have written remarks,
but I'm gonna read them out
loud and I can send them later.
But thank you, speaker Menon and members of
the council. My name is Tony Tye Serrat.
I'm a filmmaker,
educator, and founder of Cinepartner,
an AI powered platform for storytellers.
Now I'm probably coming to this conversation
from a slightly different perspective
because I build with AI,
I teach people about AI,
and I work with creative
communities that are simultaneously
excited about this technology
and very concerned about what it
can mean for their livelihoods,
their work, and their agency.
So we believe that we need guardrails,
which is we... Something where we've
been hearing all day. Right? But
I also believe that the goal
should be responsible innovation,
not regulation that unintentionally
makes it possible for only the
largest companies to build an AI.
When we create compliance requirements, I
would encourage the council to not to not
only ask, will this
make AI safer, but also
who will be able to afford to comply?
Because if responsible AI
development requires an expensive
validation
regimen...
I mean, sorry, regime that only trillion
dollar technology companies can navigate,
we may inadvertently
consolidate AI development
and the very companies we're
trying to hold accountable.
And for creative communities, safety isn't
only just about whether a model can be
shut down. It's also about consent,
authorship,
provenance,
compensation,
and transparency.
So if someone's screenplay, for instance,
or voice, likeness, or creative work
contributes to an AI system or its output,
what rights do that per...
Does that person retain?
Do they know how their work is
being used? Can they opt out?
Can they identify when AI materially
contributed to something?
And there's one more thing
I wanted to elaborate
is that I strongly support
tracking displacement.
But I would encourage New York to stop
at counting the jobs AI eliminates.
We should also be measuring whether New
Yorkers are being prepared for the the jobs
that AI creates.
AI literacy...
His time has expired.
Oh, okay.
Thank you. Thank you for your testimony.
And please be sure to send us the written
copy so we can review it. Thank you so
much. So where do I send it again? I didn't
hear that. Testimony@council.nyc.gov.
Okay. Thank you. Thank
you. Up next, Travis Hall.
If you're online, please unmute yourself
and begin.
You may begin.
Alright. Thank you so
much. Can you hear me?
Yes.
My name is my name is doctor Travis Hall.
I represent the Center for Democracy and
Technology, a thirty year old organization
dedicated to digital rights
and civil liberties online.
And today, I would love to talk to you a
little bit about the range of issues that
you're covering. I really appreciate the
hearing. I want specifically to talk about
third party auditing.
We appreciate
the effort to put in place third
party auditing requirements.
They not not only will help to deal with
catastrophic risks, but the range of risks
that you... That people face
from artificial intelligence.
However, as we've seen
with LL one forty four,
if there are not additional mechanisms
in place to incentivize,
the use and, consequences for
these audits, they end up turning,
into being somewhat useless. So we
wanna see, meaningful independence,
independent,
interdisciplinary
skills. There are a lot of, regulatory
agencies already covering many of these
risks,
and they can be drawn on,
not just technical skills.
Don't just simply, audit the the
models, thinking about auditing,
and assessing systems and use cases.
Make sure that you cover a broader scale
of harms. We heard a lot today about
catastrophic harms, but we're
already seeing little catastrophe...
Little catastrophes everywhere. When people
lose their benefits or their jobs, those
are catastrophes.
Make sure to incentivize.
Incentives are a a...
Commensurate to protections
and assess...
And, for example, making sure
that assessments don't entrench
powerful actors.
Also, independent,
evaluation
only really works as one piece in
a broader accountability network.
So thank you very much for your time. Would
love to engage with the council on, this
and other issues.
And thank you so much.
Up next, we have
Danielle Marie Chappies.
If you're online, if you
could just unmute and begin.
Daniel
Marie Chappius.
Alright. We'll go on to Michelle Barnaby.
If you're online, please unmute and begin.
My
name is Michelle Barnaby.
I'm a New York City nurse,
a Columbia graduate,
and a foreman... Former NISNA member.
Out of concern for the future
of patient care and public health,
I now study AI governance and
safety with Blue Dot Impact.
Today,
not one of the major
labs, Anthropic, OpenAI,
Google, or Meta could quantify the
risk of catastrophic AI failure.
In health care, informed consent would
apply. We disclose the risk and the patient
decides.
I can't imagine handing a patient a drug
or a device and saying this may carry a
catastrophic risk to you or your
family's life, and we just don't know,
but you should take it.
Right now, the public is the patient, and
we are being denied the right to know the
risks and the right to say no.
Speaker Menon
rightly noted that we don't ask the
airline industry to self regulate.
In hospitals, we report our errors,
even the near misses.
AI companies face no such mandate.
When you ask, if these Frontier
Labs bear legal responsibility
for the harm their AI causes,
only Google answered clearly.
The other three dodged.
As a nurse whose entire profession
is built on accountability,
I find that deeply unserious.
Today, I heard the lab say
voluntary frameworks aren't enough.
We can learn from what happened in Illinois
where third party audits won't begin
until 2028.
We don't have time for
slow implementation.
I think New York can show that
government can move with speed
that this demands, diagnose the problem,
and put safeguards in place quickly.
Let's give
these frontier labs the regulations they
say they want at a speed that makes sense
for New Yorkers.
Independent
third party audits before deployment,
including algorithmic bias,
mandatory
reporting for incidents and near misses,
a required
override switch, whistleblowers,
and clear development...
Developer liability for
harm. Thank you so much. You
so much for your testimony.
Up next, we have
Robert Cappell.
Robert, if you're on, unmute and begin.
Okay. I'm gonna call Dan...
Daniel Marie Chappius
again. If you're online
and you can hear us, unmute
and begin.
Okay. Moving on. We will
call on Patrick Sullivan.
Patrick, if you can hear
us, unmute and begin.
We'll move on. Tony Jones,
if you're on and can hear
us, unmute and begin.
Hello.
I'm here. Thank you. Good afternoon,
everybody... Or good evening, everybody. Thank
you very much.
I'm Tony Jones. I'm a Brooklyn resident
and cofounder of Creative AI Academy,
a training company and instructor of AI
design at the Pratt Institute. I'm hopeful
and heartened by the panelists'
testimonies today and the intention of
these committees on this crucial moment.
While I support the strong regulation of
companies building Frontier AI, I... And I
see the proposed amendments aimed to address
this, I'm here about the other half of
the problem, the person at the keyboard.
The harm most New Yorkers will meet first
comes from someone using the tool already
in market. Today, anyone with an email
address can clone a voice, fabricate a photo
of a real person, or write a convincing
scam in minutes. The tool asks nothing
from them first, no training, no
acknowledgment of risk, no
promise of responsibility.
We regulate carmakers,
and we also require every driver to follow
the rules of the road. In my classroom,
every student writes and signs
a personal AI constitution,
a short statement of how they will and will
not use the tools that I'm teaching them
to use. I propose the city ask the same of
its citizens in the form of simpler than
a license. First, a short free city provided
safety training taken once before a
person can open an account
and an AI tool of a certain,
defined level of capability.
Second, assigned user constitution,
plain language commitment commitment to
use the AI honestly with no harm, language
which users may incorporate into
the account level personalization
of the instructions that... Of the AI
products they use as well as a second safety
measure. The signature will not stop the
determined criminal and neither does a
driver's license. It simply sets a baseline
for the millions of ordinary users who
want to do right and have never been told
what that means. As a first step, I asked
the council to start where its authority
is clear, require this training and the
signed constitution for city employees
who use AI on the job or AI vendors that
contract with the city, then maybe we can
press Albany for a statewide standard and
set the standard for the rest of the country
as well. Thank you very much for your
consideration. I know that we can regulate
the labs, but I asked that we ask something
of the rest of us as well. Thank you so
much. Thank you so much. Up next, Asata
Kamara,
if you're on, please unmute and begin.
Thank you so much,
madam speaker and members of the council.
My name is Isata Kamara,
and I am the founder
and the president of the Global
Subnational Diplomacy Council.
I previously served as New York City's
commissioner for international affairs
and had the pleasure of serving
the city for more than a decade.
I come to this testimony
because artificial intelligence
is something that all cities are thinking
about, including New York. And we know
that AI can obviously help
cities reduce their paperwork,
improve infrastructure,
and and planning, and make
services more accessible.
However, we also know that AI has
the potential to deepen inequalities
and threaten livelihoods.
So we are offering four recommendations
and are willing to work with city council
in order to support the work that you're
doing. First, we would like to ensure that
we're connecting workforce reporting to
paid training,
by also consulting with workers and unions
and providing opportunities
for advancement accordingly.
We are also asking that we do
more to protect democracies
as we know that artificial intelligence is
a great tool for spreading misinformation
and disinformation.
We specifically
are asking for more support to ensure
that residents have access to reliable
public information that is verified
and that they understand,
the different issues and decisions that
are being made by government in a clearer
way.
When you look around the world, there are
great cities that are doing this work,
including Helsinki
and others, and we ask the city council to
connect with those cities to learn from
their experiences
as well. As I've mentioned, we
believe that artificial intelligence
could be a tool for good if
it is managed carefully.
Also share the concern
that other speakers have
shared the
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Up next, I'll call Ashley Youssef.
Thank you, speaker Menon, and members of
the council for the opportunity to speak.
My name is Ashley Youssef. I am a native
New Yorker, a mother of four living in
Michigan, and a leader of Trina
AI. I am developing Room 2050,
an immersive arts and technology learning
environment where students can explore
creativity through hands on experience
with art, robotics, and artificial
intelligence.
The vision is to put human imagination,
curiosity,
and judgment at the center
of that experience.
As a mother, I want children to have
opportunities to understand the technology
shaping their futures.
I want families to know who is responsible
when those technologies enter a learning
environment. My position is that access
and accountability must move together.
Children deserve opportunities to innovate,
and they deserve meaningful protection.
For Room 2050, the
standards I am proposing
include
educator supervision,
age appropriate tools, clear communication
with parents, and strict limits on the
collection
and use of student information.
Any use of student data to train
commercial AI systems
should require explicit,
informed
parental,
permission.
Students should learn that
AI can make mistakes,
reflect bias,
and produce convincing
information that is false.
They should practice questioning
its answers and developing their own ideas
no matter what part of the city or The
United States they are from to help support
emerging talent,
which are... A human emerging talent.
I support a gradual rollout
beginning with supervised experiences
and expanding only
after evaluating safety,
educational value,
and feedback from teachers
and families and the council.
I ask the council to
pursue clear standards
that schools can understand and enforce,
including
transparency
from technology providers and practical
ways to report problems and stop using
unsafe systems.
Educators and parents should have a
meaningful voice in these decisions.
That's what Toreen
and...... Time's expired.
Thank you. Thank you so
much for your testimony.
Up next,
we will call on Naved Hassan.
Naved, if you're online,
please unmute and begin.
Thank you, speaker Menon, technology committee
chair Della Rosa and city council for
holding this critical hearing. My name is
Naveed Hassan, and I'm the parent of two
public school children and also the
elected Manhattan member on the panel for
educational policy.
My academic and professional background
is in symbolic, pregenerative AI and
computer vision.
We are in an unfortunate situation in
technology policy for generative AI with two
prominent camps, the accelerationists
appeal to a desire for imminent utopia
and the effect of altruists spending their
time in, in code, panic.
Neither extreme greed nor extreme fear
are beneficial framing for sober thinking
around how to manage developing
advanced technologies.
New Yorkers need prosocial technology
governance with tech expertise in public
offices
not being rushed to build hundreds of
hyperscale data centers, or putting only those
very companies in the room when writing
rules in a way that lets them achieve
regulatory capture.
This morning, none of the Gen AI companies
could answer a simple question. What do
you consider is the risk of your
service causing catastrophe to humanity?
This is because it is antithetical to
their business desire to push an inherently
probabilistic product to be
used in all aspects of work,
to make any such estimates. When
a job demands deterministic
certainty, this whole model will eventually
fear... Fail for sure. We must not allow
the spread of an unfit for purpose
technology to be misused so broadly.
There's bipartisan interest in not just
regulating Gen AI, but also pulling into the
public realm broadband and wireless
connectivity, abusive algorithmic targeting,
illegal surveillance, vendor
lock in, interoperability
mandates,
open standards, open source software
infrastructure, and more. We have the
opportunity now to think about what municipal
tech policy should look like for the
good of everyone living in New York. We have
the ability already to enforce existing
rules around antitrust,
concentration of risk, controlled goods
rules being applied to compute hardware.
Let us calmly and expeditiously use skilled
public servants to build a future with
beneficial technology
available for all of society.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for your testimony.
Up next, we have Nadira Pittman. Nadira,
if you are on, please unmute and begin.
Hello?
Yes. Please begin your testimony. Hi.
Yes. Okay. So my name is Nadira Pittman.
I am 41 years old, a Queens resident.
I am actually reaching out
regarding a testimony that I have.
I am actually a survivor
of the AI attacks.
I'm dealing with facial recognition,
illegal surveillance.
I'm also dealing with,
like, constructed voice recordings
of
close family friends.
They're
gathering it and and creating a job.
Like, far as the job, they're using their
voices
against me.
It's on the...
If I'm on the buses, on the trains, it's
continuous. It's a continuous basis
nonstop.
I have been filing reports...
Police reports. I've been
trying to, you know, get this
attack off of me. I'm not sure why
it it it seems to be
inputted and okay. It's also
in various
agencies
where it's allowed to be used
against other individuals,
where people are afraid now of even
showing their faces on the... On public
transportation.
It... It's it's really, really getting out
of hand, and the attacks are are extreme.
It's very dangerous at this point.
You know, I I... It's it's to the point
where you can't go anywhere and feel safe
now because of of of this technology.
So I'm reaching out. I have sent numerous
reports.
I have reached out and
wrote letters to you guys
to try to get this off of me because it
it... It's it's something that it it... It's
it's unnecessary.
It's not... I'm not a criminal.
I don't do anything illegal. I... There's
no reason why the... Who put this on me?
Why is this... Why am I being
attacked in this manner?
You know, I've came up there personally,
and I informed you guys last
year... Your time has expired.
You so much for your time. I appreciate
your time. I would prefer someone reach out
to me as soon as possible....
So much. Thank you.
Up next, we have
Lori Lomask.
If you're on, please,
unmute yourself and begin.
Okay.
We'll
move on
to Steve Cerre.
Cerre?
Not
that Cerre.
Steve
Cerre,
c e r e. Just go through the
list. They probably know why.
Tan... Tanbir
Chaudhry,
if you're on.
No.
Catherine Jin.
Zachary Thompson?
No.
Christopher Leon Johnson?
Raj Sharof?
Alright. Those are all the names that we
have for today. I wanna thank everyone
who took time out of their
day today to testify,
to bring your suggestions,
to bring your questions,
and to bring a partnership with the council.
I wanna thank speaker Menon for her
leadership and to my colleagues,
the last lady standing, council members
Maloney and Hanif, thank you for staying
till the very end. And to all the staff who
made this possible,
thank you all for this important hearing,
and we are adjourned.